we live we're actually Street Life
fantastic welcome to fight companion
Calabasas and it is for the Jake Paul
Woodley fight live on Showtime
pay-per-view only and I have quite the
cast with me it's probably the best show
uh going on right now we got Josh
Thompson my left
we got Brian the kid count finally
making appearance on calabas fight
companion an MMA royalty the legend
Rampage Jackson
and he's super nice in person yeah it's
really nice he's so nice and of course
my man Bradley Martin here damn I can't
follow up after that one
you got a diamond bracelet and you're
pulling it off oh yeah it's some this
right here I'm surprised you're not at
the fight man usually like you know
you're at the you where were you pretty
much all the other people yeah with
Takashi it was crazy with those boys
yeah with the whole team but this one
you you decide to lay down uh I needed
to be back in La for some time really
yeah because working on my podcast yes
I've been slacking on that one I can't
slack on it anymore it's been bad you
got to stay consistent my man let me
make sure these light bills stay on uh
we got a bunch of smooth operators
around the table tonight thanks to
manscape the official electric trimmer
of the UFC you know we've got the
viewers from around the Galaxy when your
balls are Bush free it's an out of this
world experience so get ready take off
with manscape and then their new
lawnmower 4.0 join the two million men
worldwide who trusts manscape and trim
with confidence all the thick boys
tonight get 20 off and free shipping
with the code CFC manscape.com that's 20
off and free shipping with the code CFC
manscape.com we got the Lincoln code in
the bio
all right boys it's going down this is
the biggest fight in a long time I mean
UFC's got been laying low also you know
biggest fight I saw you like what but
I'm just saying like well I'm just
saying like as far as like the UFC
hasn't had any like big pay-per-view
it's been like fight nights fight nights
oh yeah so this is kind of what
everybody's been waiting for I thought
the uh Conor McGregor fight was good
that was last time yeah
that's a big one but I'm just saying
like since then a blockbuster you like
what have they done for me lately okay
does anybody have any inside info on
this fight does anybody know like
anything about uh Jake Paul's fight Camp
I mean I know a little bit okay the guy
that's fighting on the card tonight he's
fighting the uh Tyson's Fury brother
yeah
oh okay he's on he was on love Island
yeah yeah I saw it I saw the guy posted
something by him being on love Island
like making out with a dude or something
uh um
behind the scenes oh I don't know I saw
it on on this guy no no I saw it on
pretty boys
um Instagram page he made like a meme
like a funny thing the guy clowning him
yeah he was clowning but anyway I
trained with that guy Tonya McKee's gym
and he said he's been sparring with um
that's how he got in the fight he's been
spawning with Jake Paul yeah he said he
said he said Jake Paul's a real deal you
know what's weird is every single person
I know who's like worked with Jake Paul
or watched him Spar everyone's like dude
the guy's the real deal everybody that's
what he said I haven't heard one person
like I can't really fight never do you
know what I keep going back to when Rory
McDonald fought Tyron Woodley got on his
grill and just kept jabbing him and
Tyron Woodley had some trouble with that
so and you think uh Jake Paul's as
talented as Royce
I do not think that and I'm glad you
said that however I see what you're
saying I am saying if I'm Jake Paul I'm
thinking to myself that jab when he was
in his prime he had trouble with that
jab now Jake Paul's got a long Chad I
haven't seen the Box really let's be
honest but that's my thing like no one
like you no one at this table can tell
me that Jake Paul's the real boxer like
we saw him starch Nate Robinson that guy
he's a basketball basketball player
start's been asking Ben Aston is there
for a paycheck so my thing is we have no
idea how Jason reacting gets hit if he
gets dropped if he starts if he's behind
four rounds like that show's a true
fight it's more than anyone like when
you're down on the cards like a
Fighter's heart is what's going to make
it or break it and I'll say this
and the reason why I put a lot of money
on uh Woodley is because you put money
on with me I love that you did that
because a he's UFC alumni but also B if
he comes ready like if he's if he
mentally wants to be there and compete
he should beat the [ __ ] out of it okay
so now I have to ask this question bring
it is this a real fight how dare you how
dare you I'm just saying listen if this
guy gets more fights it's worth more and
more money he's a prize he's making
himself to a prize boxer you're right so
like I can see if that's a narrative but
my only thing is is Woodley this would
be such a black guy on his entire career
if he gets knocked out by the kid who
had a Disney show you know what I'm
saying like everybody's not gonna play
that game so when they come to Woodley
go hey man here's five million where
they're paying them to take a fall how
much money is it Willy's probably making
probably 10 million I bet is that the
biggest pay to have his career yeah yeah
and is he done with his career seemingly
yeah yeah but here's the thing so he'll
make more if he wins there's a
guaranteed rematch clause so if Woodley
wins they have to fight again that's the
deal oh okay so that does make it more
interesting I didn't I didn't even know
about that and if you know what and
Willie's a good buddy of mine he doesn't
he doesn't play those games okay
he's a real yeah okay let me ask you a
difficult question he he's you got money
on him you love him he's awesome
would you say in the past four years
maybe three years he hasn't been he his
enthusiasm for the fight hasn't been
what it was and I thought he was on uh
food truck Diaries when I went to Miami
before the Logan Paul Floyd fight right
and we did it next to the pool that's
what I told him I said bro I'm not
trying to like make funny nothing but I
said sometimes just you I'll see you in
the middle of fight like look at the
clock bro like you just seemed checked
out and he's like yeah I am he's like I
just haven't I haven't felt like doing
it I've been anyways I've also been
wiling out bro he's like do you think
all the time this one he's taking
serious from what I hear he's been
taking very serious text with him he's
taking him dead serious so and also I
know Woodley's background's wrestling
with the Kim box do like he's using that
wild card for a hot second man my friend
said my friend said if I was in
Woodley's corner I would pay Jake Paul
to say as many bad things about his mom
as possible you don't mess with Mama
yeah Jake Paul it's gonna work oh deal
okay yeah I couldn't pass it up I
couldn't pass it up because you're
taking Jake Paul yeah I couldn't I
couldn't pass it up [ __ ]
sorry now my out 11 Grand if Jake Paul
wins yeah I am dude
you know what I love that you're going
with with your boy Woodley I got it I'm
going with Willie you can't turn your
back on him you know I suffer from peer
pressure and I don't have a lot of
people okay
what about the size difference yeah it's
a big size taller but Woodley's a big
dude man like Woodley's jacked yeah but
I mean literally I still think Woodley
has power dude like Woody's an athlete
go ahead and take a look at Woodley's
legs and ass that's awesome look I know
he's got power I'm not saying he's in
power but he's the same physical body
weight yeah yeah tell me tell me who
have you seen Woodley starts in one shot
not once I have uh what's what's that
kid's name nope
he hit him one time kind of stun him a
little bit Robbie Lawler Robbie Lawler
he knocked Robbie Lawler into into the
corner and that was that
yeah I guess you would say lower before
the next one
with a nice shot and then she set him
back on the fence and he hooked somebody
else into so you don't think uh Woodley
has power no I don't think he has the
one crunch power now we have to remember
though too is we're not wearing he's not
wearing four ounce gloves he's gonna be
wearing 10 ounce gloves so that's the
other thing Paul Got The Knockout power
in this fight well I mean look Ben
Astron hasn't been knocked out except
with the flying knee yeah but now he is
his chin wasn't going after that fight
so and he didn't train yeah yeah you
know what I mean so like he's been known
to have a good chin for all the damage
look at the Robbie Lawler fight he got
rocked he was getting his ass beat on
the ground everywhere and he still
didn't go out still came back
boxing rounds are not the same there's
no clinching there's no holding there's
no wrestling as far as Robert Guerrero
the ghost I've sparred with a lot of top
boxers I'm telling you right now once
you once he starts trying to Grapple
them they break it up they break it up
that's gonna be the rest that's his rest
period is when he starts to get tired he
will tend to talk so you tell me you're
banking on uh uh I think Paul who hold
up who's who's never been in
Championship rounds ever and mentally we
have no idea
I agree with you you're gonna side with
that he also he also Woodley who's a
Hall of Famer he also trains with a lot
of top level boxers and professional
what's called world champions former
world champions and they've said no he's
got the gas tank he's got to go but are
they you're just cracking him though you
just told me a second ago everyone you
talk if you say he's a good boxer but
it's legit inside the ring inside the
practice yeah
when was the last time you saw tea would
go real hard on the game for the full
duration
for a long time trying to AKA trail with
him about a BJ Penn's Place we've been
friends for a long time it just at 39
years old like I have to touch back on
what you said the motivation I know sure
he's motivated for this but how much
does motivation get you through when
you're 39 years old the conditioning the
body he's carrying the muscle we're
gonna find out yeah I think it's 100
real fight I think 100 no he's not like
just kidding no no no no how do you sure
with boxing you'll see in Showtime
Showtime when I play that game that gets
out everybody's screwed it just seems
like it just makes it you know why
because you come from the YouTube world
smoke all lives in that world but you
know it doesn't limit the world the
fight game especially a guy like I mean
he was talking about in this that the
fight game is changing the whole thing
is about this they're going to try to
knock you down you know what's weird
about this like this YouTube Crossover
with the fight world is I think all of
it stops if Jake loses if Jake get
starts there'll be a rematch that's what
I'm saying it all stops you think so yep
that's what I'm saying though Jake
Paul's the the face of it why would they
want this to stop then they don't but
but again you can't I don't know man now
I I see where you come from but I just
don't think like Woodley's not going to
partake in that because this would be
the biggest black guy of his career no
Plankton it'd be the biggest black guy
if if he gets starched by Jake Paul now
this is a real fight no it's a real
fight for sure it's a real fight this is
not for sure you'll see I mean let's say
it is real who do you have
[ __ ]
Woodley
yeah I go with Willie only because I've
seen him fight a ton I've never seen
that's my thing I'm not gonna put money
and I love notice just notice I bet a
thousand on Jake Paul because I so
believe in the fact that they want more
fights like this oh for business
absolutely Jake's their Cash Cow Jake's
their Conor McGregor yeah I better he
does I understand what he was saying
because what are you saying because you
think look at his last opponents though
he's been like he hasn't fought like
this they can actually beat him this is
his first time somebody actually
possibly can beat it and it's still
someone smaller though and it's still
someone smaller and older
it's brilliant matchmaking but like Jake
Paul's team's not stupid like people
think these guys are stupid he's got
real sparring partners who were former
Champions and stuff apparently in this
in his room yeah oh yeah two of the guys
the question I was I asked him is the
question is are those guys like when
you're sparring with those guys are they
moving around with you or are they
actually giving you real those boxers
their first four rounds they're like
kind of like Muay Thai guys they take
the first four rounds to kind of warm up
with each other other and then after the
fourth round third fourth round they
just start piecing you up so as a guy
who's an MMA guy you're going to their
wrestler you're not if you're going in
guys have been throwing the right hand
since they were seven in that mid
distances boxers obviously what happens
to guys like you when you go into the
train so this is what I want to like
tell so I would go as far with Robert
Guerrera he'd do 12 rounds I would do
the first four right I was like his
warm-up rounds okay and I was in like
the best [ __ ] fighting 25 minutes with
but he's not trying to [ __ ] getting
ready to fight for getting ready for
like the third or second or third fight
with Gilbert phenomenal shape by the
fourth round I was exhausted yeah
exhausted they're just their angles them
their movement the way they touch you I
mean they put me on the stanky leg
anytime they want you know it's like
they cut the angle and I turn right into
it boom yeah it just it doesn't the
style of box man I'm not saying that
Jake Paul is that guy right what I'm
saying though is that one guy when he is
just focused on boxing you learn how to
cut the angles you're learning how to
step off you're learning how to counter
off of the slips those are things the
MMA guys don't do they don't they don't
just focus
he's been at wildcard since 2009 2009
with the highest level okay okay but how
is how has it looked lately
that's my point like but look who's been
fighting Vicente Luke that wasn't a good
fight no it was a great fight it was a
great fight he wobbled him I I get with
you but I get what you're saying who's a
striker and that was actually a good
fight who's before that you have Colby
Covington right who just kind of mopped
the floor with him Gilbert Burns right
mop the floor with him but all Grapplers
yeah bar Usman mopped the floor with him
all Grapplers but didn't but uh but I
want to go back but do the grappler um
which one uh
dropped him yeah hit him rocked him yeah
four ounce gloves makes a big difference
crazy explosive yeah
and he's a Jitsu guy now you're
comparing now you're saying you're
saying oh a world-class Jiu Jitsu guy
has good enough hands to piece you up
well he did did Wonder Boy Thompson he
caught wonderboard Thompson with with an
overhand right or whatever yeah not
really he hit him he caught him no he
wobbled tomorrow Usman but he also
I promise but what I'm saying though is
you're I'm saying a guy who doesn't
really he doesn't really train boxing
Jake Paul's been dedicated to boxing now
let's just say five years four years
right okay he's been and now he's
obviously he's taking it very serious
because this is Cash Cow this Showtime's
paying him 15 million dollars yeah
you're making money yeah he's making
money Jake Jake you know can you talk
about have you ever seen the the so I'm
all about building a guy up yeah I
thought I thought I was straight
but but I'm all about building guy up so
she has you know he doesn't have a ton
of experience obviously his his brother
others Tyson Fury who's the best boxer
in the world have you seen the record of
opponents that Tommy Furious thought no
the this is I'm not even trying to make
you guys laugh the first the first
ponies flat is 11 and 120.
hold up look at this these are his
opponents again Tommy I love you ten and
102. holy the next track the next guy's
oh and 26. okay the next day it was 2
and 26. then he found a guy who's on 11
then for the guy who's 0-9 tough enough
about a guy who's two numbers and now
he's fighting a guy who's 0-1 yeah I
heard the 2-0 guy I took the fighting
like a three days nose or something like
this that's what pretty boy told him
those are not good enough
he's an MMA fighter okay
yeah man I feel you what's with the
coddling why do they caught it
like building up
like you remember like who is your job
is and then who is Chavez Jr they have
like are you talking about 100 or
something fights before they even fought
anyone with the winning record boxing
does so boxing what they'll do is
they'll they'll have you fight like your
first 20 fights against guys that are
just cans just get get to go out there
get the win build your name up pad your
record and then they'll start getting
you some more money fights and then
bigger money fights and as you start
winning and you start getting the money
fights now you start dedicating your
time mainly to it then yeah you'll find
like a real opponent to like 25 I wish
they would bring MMA fighters I think
they're doing that with Sean O'Malley
like they're they're they're bringing us
yeah the planet smart I remember I never
forgot when you said when yerry
Rodriguez was so exciting to watch and
they give them Frankie Edgar and you
were like give him anybody but Frankie
Edgar you can't remember that when they
got announced and it ruined him for I
mean no no no
ruin you out here now when we talk about
guys that that
it's funny I get a lot I get a hard time
people give me a hard time about not
liking Sean I love Sean O'Malley
he's a phenomenal [ __ ] I
Sean have you listen if you're watching
this man I love you man I love watching
him fight you already guess don't like
that guy at all right but he's the guy
that
he's the guy that will talk all of this
and then when it comes down like hey
inviting is the beat they gave him the
beat four or five times he have left the
UFC because he didn't want to fight I
get that though then he came back then
he came back with his tail between his
legs after he threatened to leave he
left they cut him and let him took him
out of the rankings
yeah he can Cameron Bellator came back
but then he actually no one picked him
up he wanted so much money he was asking
for like a million dollars was like yeah
wow and then other promotions too we're
talking to them they're like they're
like yeah no he's asking ridiculous
amount of money UFC brought him back
because his manager went back to them
and said hey yeah you know we he's sorry
he wants to come back basically that's
what happened so what and then now we're
having the same problem with him he
don't want to fight right now he doesn't
want him he's a mental [ __ ] yeah
really so what's the point of building
up Fighters though like that giving him
easy because it's long and exciting and
not that experience and you give them to
a dude with a veteran like Frank Yeager
who can just he just knows [ __ ] that
your fancy stuff doesn't work with and
it's not they just chop you down but you
want to build a guy up so he gets in
ring experience so he's seen like a
southpaw he's been maybe maybe he had a
round where he didn't do well and then
the next round so by the time he faces a
real guy he's been in those situations
because if not you're gonna ruin them
yeah the thing was so they offered Sean
the Frankie fight and I think they
turned it down smart yeah where did
zabet go he must so he's having some
injury he has some serious injuries
right now he's talking about retiring
he's basically said he's retired but
they're they're still working with the
doctors trying to get something fixed
because he something's wrong yeah
something I haven't been able to hear
about what it is I just know out of his
camp and out of people that train with
him and stuff they're like yeah
something's really wrong and they're
just trying to get it all figured out I
don't know if it's like a stomach issue
you know because there was a lot of a
lot of Fighters have been having that
like Mike Swig head he had something to
do with like his esophagus along with
some stomach issue he couldn't eat any
spiders any pepper couldn't eat anything
I don't know what it is because he's
he's a stud man the beat looks like I
thought he was going to be the next 45
pound champion you should he should be
if he just keeps fighting he's still
young though what is he like 28. he
looks 47 but
so do you think you think Cody smokes
Sean if he fights him now that's a good
fight it's actually that but that's how
talented sugars yeah good fight but Cody
hits [ __ ] hard
like like Sugar's last fight he fought
just a you know a zombie this guy was a
zombie wouldn't go down yeah I was
shocked sugar tell me that his his
knuckles his middle Knuckles still hurts
after that eight weeks later he's hit
that guy he can't hit him the wrong time
you can't say things like that expect me
to like you okay you're soft but it come
on
come on the only thing is is like how he
took those hits against that other dude
like if Cody hit you you're not getting
off the camera yeah it's like a Mack
truck yeah but there's also no reason
for sugar to fight him my sugar is doing
the Right Moves calling those guys out
but it doesn't make sense for sure to do
that like he's just keep making noise in
his Lane keep making money and then he's
so dope this is what you have to
remember this is what you have to
remember why why with sugar right why
would you want to fight someone like
that right now when you're still on your
first probably first or second you're
not making time you're not making [ __ ]
so just wait keep beating these guys
keep being the ones you should be
beating and then when you get no more
fights right does he has three more
fights and then okay I don't know what
his contract is but he's got to be
coming there so he's trying to
trust me in those three the UFC has set
his last one they're gonna throw him a
dog he's second one yeah his second and
last one or his last one they're gonna
throw him someone hard he's gonna get a
dog his second and last one they'll give
him somebody that he can beat as long as
he's ready to resign
if he's not ready to resign yeah they're
gonna get him beat by his last one
because then they say hey you just got
you just lost
the worst matchup possible but if you're
trying to get out that contract let me
educate you my friend I think they beat
after they get you beat they hold on to
you for like another year until they're
ready to let you go because they have
exclusive rights to negotiate with you
yeah you know does he want to come back
and he's not allowed to what's up he
always teases it because to see him
fight Peter yon is this the fight I'm
actually the most
sugar going up to 35 and fighting oh
this guy looks like he's never got hit
in the face I want to see him fighting
yeah
I want to see the first three Division
champion
that'd be and Henry with his wrestling I
think he has the ability to stuff
everything yeah but I mean Henry's too
smart for volcanovski ultimately he
would be yeah but he can out wrestle him
he cannot wrestling he cannot wrestling
man I would not doubt Henry in any City
no I I wouldn't either hey real quick we
know uh so you I know the guy that you
know who's fighting Tommy Fury you know
uh Tommy Fury I think he's the biggest
favorite on the card or Serrano might be
a bigger favorite but he's like a minus
2 000 or some [ __ ] like he is yeah right
now for real yeah it's a big kid right
the guy he's fighting the guy he fights
no no he's not yeah well here we go
right here this kid on the road holy
[ __ ] look at that age difference yeah
he's young yeah
this Anthony Taylor got he fought James
those are some long arms at 145. that
guy's yeah or that guy's own two you got
it Five Guys the wins the wins come
first so I didn't see what it was was it
0-2 or was it 2-0 this guy is seven
seven five that's his MMA okay
oh he got a he had a boxing match yeah
he had one and he lost
we'll tell you how you lose said 2017.
Dante Stubbs debut doesn't say oh no oh
split decisions oh okay so he didn't get
knocked out
I think he has a good chance you know
what in the gym I don't know what he's
doing but I always see him letting
people beat him up
um
letting people beat him up it looks like
he he can get out of the you know he'd
be getting grounded
he's into an MMA yeah he does MMA I've
never seen him I've never seen him box
right right there's guys like that that
look like that around the world it bugs
me it bothers me it hurts my feelings
yeah
a lot of levels number one if any woman
I've ever dated is gonna fall you know
she she's gonna leave me for him
secretly at least yeah and then I'm a
little attracted to him
this is what's weird yeah and that
bothers me too uh you just learning this
about yourself yeah you're coming out on
me I know that you have I know you feel
like yeah therapy kind of energy so I
feel like you're safe talking to me yeah
I just like to ask questions I'm
learning so him him and Tyson Fury you
know the the champ right now it's
hypnotized Fury have the same dad but
they have different moms yeah
yeah they look identical yeah yeah oh
him and his dad look identical no Tyson
but then how would it have the last name
because I thought he's riding his
brother's last name
Davis
strong
dad that looks way bigger than yeah
the dad called out Mike Tyson how tall
is the dad
Tommy Fury's mom's not Mexican six three
what no he's got to be talking to six
three yeah
the Tyson was just slumping when he when
he was sitting there he's like six three
years no I thought he was bigger he's
six six I think yeah oh yeah
wow
I don't know I just said that but she
looks Paul as well
his mom's Moana that's cool
oh here we go here we go oh wow he's up
there man
well his arms are a full 10 inches
shorter ladies and gentlemen yeah so all
right now your boy Taylor's not on this
card to
um to win no no no they want to knock
out we don't do it because you know if
you're Tommy Fury and Jake Paul have
beef so they're hoping Tommy if this is
what I'm saying though you're saying
this guy's not here to win like how do
we know that's boxing okay that's what
boxing does they're trying to build
Tommy Fury up but as Jake and Willie
boxing or he backing up already look at
the size difference you got to get
closer like the faints
you got his hands down only 10 I didn't
tell him he waited with quarters control
you're right about this guy's arms yeah
they're extremely short no I swear to
God it's like chocolate oh he's a weird
body oh he does look like a baby T-Rex
for real
sure the way he stands a little bit no
that's why we call him in the gym TV oh
don't sleep on him you guys can make in
front of his arms
do you think you could take him do you
think you can take him the way I move
I'm very sneaky yeah I catch angles they
call me the ghost they call you the
ghost who's that yeah cause you don't
see me
froggy bee little T-Rex is up the street
I'm here look at my hands are already
kind of feeling up up
and when I box I go like this
you whistle when you I Whistle nice
that's cool it is he's wearing the
American well I guess it's British
from the side they look American oh
there you go slip that shot sort of say
hello
Keep Your Hands Up
see because their game plan is if Jake
were to beat Woodley oh if that lands
that's trouble yeah uh the game plan
dude he's close to getting it that's
right look at those little arms don't
work those little body shots whoa it's
tough I love this right now you guys are
you guys are sleeping on T-Rex and
that's not right this is dope I'm Taylor
I apologize
the game plan is is if Jake beats
Woodley and everyone goes he needs to
fight a real boxer they think you know
they call Tommy a real boxer so he'd
fight Tommy Nets yeah with that record
yeah with that oh somebody's going to
gas at this pace everybody calm down
it's only four rounds oh yeah
all right so wow we're bringing up we're
bringing Fury absolutely here bro that
guy's arms are gone oh he rocked him on
that shot all right Rampage called it he
has a chin yeah bro he has the tiniest
guys it's so different maybe boxing just
wasn't the sport please guys
please it's distractingly if I may he
got to live and stuff
that's why I tell them you gotta get in
there yeah
oh
yeah let's go champ that's what he said
I told him if I beat him in boxing he
can only say that [ __ ] once a month
let's go champ
here it is come on there's my fighter
Taylor let's go Taylor that's your guy
right there let's go that's my guy right
talking about t-rex Taylor
come on Taylor I'm the dog now yeah he's
a bigger please keep your hands up
please google okay
yeah Fury's uppercuts Atlanta though
yeah it's the thing that y'all sleeping
on though he got Antonio McKee in his
Corner Antonio McKee is surprisingly uh
he can be a good boxing coach as well
for sure Anthony's Corner he's been here
too long yeah
he told him
that's what I say you got a short Army
coach dude pretty good oh look you're
putting the weight on them
from his brother I bet
yeah damn
look uh Fury doesn't look bad at all
though not great though huh all right
what do you think of this matchup okay
after seeing this does he beat Jake Paul
we'll find out we don't know if we don't
know we've seen Jake now it could just
be the conflict the Styles because T-Rex
is doing work hey he's making work
Taylor stop calling me there's T-Rex
Taylor that's his nickname
bro he's getting tired who gave him
pretty boy I think he did he did hey
because he looked like that dude from
New Jack City that's where I come
yes I am wow I mean if you give me a
lineup of guys I would not be like
that's pretty boy do you see it though
do you see it yeah yeah yeah oh yeah
she's cute oh damn I mean I'm just
saying
how's Tommy Fury's nickname not pretty
boy yeah I know they got two pretty boys
fighting each other
Tommy is fantastic that's Brandon's job
here and his hair hasn't moved oh
everything his hair hasn't moved yeah
there's some gel in there oh it's a lot
of gel it's like cement
it's got cement in his hair he's got
your hair bun but his hairline is a
little bit after watching this Tommy has
he has such a long way to go
really oh dude really before I can't I
can't really tell this guy's an MMA
fighter tiny arms yeah and I hate to
keep calming help but yeah but
especially as he's fighting at 185 those
boys are some Killers man he's tenacious
though look he's no he has a heart of a
what's what's his reach what's what's
Taylor's reach 14.
14. like 62.
let's see furies
so they say they're paying them inches
Tommy's winning apparently yeah okay so
Brandon this is what I'm talking about
see even though T-Rex Taylor he's he's
got some boxing he's got a lot of MMA
fights he's already getting tired the
boxing type cardio is not the same as
the MMA card but remember this is also
four rounds no I understand
I'm talking about I'm talking about
Woodley though I'm gonna say something
I'm gonna say something though I I could
be wrong but from what I saw training in
jail with Tony McKee and stuff I don't
think pretty boy had like a straight up
like boxing camp for himself you know
what I'm saying I don't think he had a
training camp for himself yeah you know
I saw him training on his own in the gym
while we was doing yeah he's just like
other sub Jiu-Jitsu and all this stuff
he's in the corner jumping rope and
hitting the back he was doing himself I
didn't see him with no coach I think
Antonio McKee was uh was kind of
physical AJ had just fault yeah I think
Antonio he was kind of busy doing some a
little T-Rex had like that 70s boxer cam
yeah from what I saw it hit the days at
the gym when I was there I think he was
doing it himself I could be totally
wrong you can tell he's just a dog man
the reach is 76 yeah
that's a full arm that's a full arm
uh-oh but to to Tommy for his defense
this is an awkward fight to take man you
mean just because he the little arms it
didn't even reach he's not a boxer
isn't it isn't he in like a a good it's
like good for him because they got
something wait that uppercut well that's
why he's such a big favorite but it's
just an awkward fight for him yeah
they're better if the guy was a
traditional boxer because that's all he
knows oh he spars traditional boxer this
guy's Small Arms moving Wheels he's also
an athlete he just leaves with small
arms every time he's like wait you know
it's kind of obvious yeah it is what it
is
so he fought uh James Gallagher I
believe they fought at 145. so now he's
fighting a 180.
I mean by the way I think fear is left
so he and he looks awesome this is MMA
he lost a James Gallery yeah
oh they give him some dogs yeah what do
you think did they go up he went on a
streak though hell yeah dude he's won
his last one dude he had that salty
record of two and four and then just
went on a streak bro he's won one two
three four five in a row
I mean you know yeah he should have
probably lost the crystal file but what
are the Heights on these two damn he
rare naked some dude with those arms oh
he got drunk
but he's so tired he's so tired
damn I was a slip that's not fair come
on Taylor five seven five seven five six
I think it was five thousand and a half
guys Tommy
uh Tommy is uh
511.
I love Island he looks like [ __ ]
Shrek he's got long arms long arms Tommy
I mean Tommy fury it's tough when your
brother's V boxer in the world you know
what I'm saying like your brother's
Tyson Fury would you rather be Tyson
Fury would you rather look like him
that's the option
yeah sometimes
I know but I I it would be nice just to
look that good what do you think this
guy's making maybe just for a week my
whole life I want to know what it's like
to be about all the women
just come up to you yeah it's for one
week maybe I agree just a temporary Nah
if I probably wouldn't trade back then
yeah just walk around like what this
little that's a good question though
because it's not like Dyson Fury is easy
on the eyes you know what I'm saying no
he's not his body is a good question his
body is what is there you know but
but this kid yeah well apparently God
gave one a ton of boxing skill and the
other ton of looks
there you go
damn man he's not bad though I'm shocked
at how far this has gone though me too
Tommy Fury is still in there man
I'm shocked that Taylor's still in there
he should have went to acting not boxing
you know you look look really good
you're going to acting or something I
bet that's gonna happen you know what
I'm saying someone's gonna offer he
wasn't [ __ ] love about this boxing
thing yeah so let's show love Island in
America it's whatever in the UK it's
huge yeah there's like 90 episodes and
like millions and millions of people who
watch it so he makes like millions of
dollars off his Instagram it ain't [ __ ]
to do in the UK so I'm sure this yeah
it rains nine months out of the year and
the food's horrible
he's from Manchester too that's a tough
part of the UK oh it's nice out there
well my girl follows him that's fine
he basically could be your younger
better looking brother yeah
you would dog that guy what next to him
though I look like
yeah but but not compared to him that's
what I mean you guys could be brothers
same skin tones I'm like a Chrysler 300.
he's like a real Rolls-Royce you're fine
but he's just yeah he's he's a cutie pie
and you're you're a big daddy and he's a
cutie pie and that's how it is
you're enormous there's nothing wrong
with that you're rich you're rich you're
big yeah and you're getting you know
you're getting up you get older God
bless you man nothing wrong with being
big daddy he's got to accept it you've
seen his Girl Molly May
uh they didn't win the show but they
came in second base is easy on the ice
okay bring her up chin so they know
what's going on there she is very blonde
I would have guessed well I'm about to
follow her now oh it's only right it's
on Affair
equality I get one Dime Piece follow
look at them look at that gorgeous
couple yeah that's a beautiful couple
yeah what are you wearing Under Armor I
mean dude shoulders for days you think
she's in a crowd right now you think
what you think she's in it
oh no yeah I know what you're gonna say
what the [ __ ] dude so you know what the
thing about uh not hot I'm sorry
Clinton's right that's the real her
though that's the one you're gonna wake
up next to that's not right imagine
having kids with that no no so she had a
jaw on her right before when she was on
the show yeah she had all the jobs this
shows because she looked like Wagner
yeah here's the thing
she looked like giggity yeah she had
that jaw look at her face there so when
you go on the show she looks like a Dick
Tracy character but when you go on a
show please when you go on the show they
they give you like doctors give you
plastic surgery like that when you get
off they give you all these offers do
class surveys everyone who comes off
because it promotes the doctors so they
all get this free flash look at her now
she's very pretty she got her job she's
so pretty
shake the jaw down it's the coyote
generator what do you offer Tommy fury
like you're good man you think Tommy had
plastic surgery too no yeah
[ __ ] no he didn't
come on pretty boy don't fall pretty boy
how much time 20 seconds left I'm
surprised that yeah
how did Taylor not get hypnotized by his
eyes Tommy just look in his eyes bro
stare him down yeah
13 seconds of your life
you know what Taylor's game and he did
it great yeah he's a dog man he's tired
by decision Tommy Fury yeah you know
yeah here he goes caught him
so that's not the best outcome for Tommy
but even if he wins Jake wins asking me
Jake's next fight I bet yeah that would
be funny and then Jake was so lame
probably beat his ass Abby yeah of
course it'd be lame as [ __ ] but Tommy's
a real like boxer yeah but you go from
[ __ ] Woodley to this guy
that's that's [ __ ] stupid dude and he
has a huge Dame in the UK too yeah well
I mean that's what I'm saying that's
this [ __ ] is all about that oh yeah
that's why I'm so convinced
Jake just talked [ __ ] about him
sometimes like dude keep keep my name
out of your mouth like even at the press
conference and can they did this Tommy
talk trash oh yeah he's good oh no he's
not great on the mic he's not like his
brother his brother's brother I agree
him and Muhammad Ali and him yeah you
think so his brother could host the late
talk show like Tyson Fury is a monster
and he looking like Tyson fear a little
bit yeah a little bit a little more but
a better looking one yeah
you're right though you guys could be
related yeah you guys yeah you might be
related huh I mean you guys bodies are
exactly alike
yeah right Josh do you still train a lot
yeah I own gym so I have to I still have
to train my students members Jitsu most
layer oh no I do I want to Fitness gym
then on a martial arts gym so I do
kickboxing Jitsu what's the fitness gym
just all Fitness that we like hit
training Boot Camp style did you watch
did you watch the Kevin Lee uh yeah
Rodriguez no no not that one the the
Giga the Giga Barbosa yeah
Giga has a very interesting style he's
he's gonna be his background for anybody
yeah he's all kickboxing anybody who
wants to stand a bang where that guy's
gonna have some trouble yeah I I
completely yeah there it is so I
completely out
um
I I didn't think I didn't think he was
gonna be as fast as barbos I thought
bubbles I thought his boxing was yeah he
was way faster and then but then Big
John when I was talking with Big John
the last night about it was that when he
wasn't worried about the takedown didn't
matter right didn't matter what was
going on so like he he like normally
he's worried about everyone trying to
take him down he didn't have to work
yeah so then he knew Barbers were just
gonna stand with him the whole time so
that's all I had to do yeah you see just
got news kickboxing stance and he was
good right he was on point boxing did
you watch the Rodriguez Kevin Lee fight
yes I did and I was I was with my kid so
I'd see some of it but for I thought
Kevin Lee kind of won the fight I
thought I don't think he won he got
robbed right caught I don't think he
touched Rodriguez he didn't punch not
really I don't know
I watched it I thought it was it should
have been a split maybe I don't know
I mean from what I saw I was fine
Rodriguez win but when I was looking at
the TV I see Kevin Lee would take it
yeah I'm like that's weird as far as a
sport yeah MMA I think it should have
been a split yeah yeah not not a UD well
he he took him down a lot and but but I
think that Rodriguez got the better of
him punching wise yeah but that doesn't
mean you're in the fight yeah but you
take down his own when you fight Tyler
though that's the issue yeah
takedown's doing fuzzles
they do but in terms of the damage now
because now after GSP left
before you beat Bisping when he left
after that they started changing and
making sure the that the judges
understood the rules a little bit better
it's all about damage being first we've
had this conversation yeah you know and
that's the thing Big John's made it very
clear that it's the damage that has to
come first takedowns don't win you
around sure it's significance where
you're taking you're the only thing that
happens around that yes it will win you
around but you have to have the damage
you take them down yeah you've got you
got to do damage so not so then
Rodriguez
though Kevin Lee might be a little bit
just a little bit small for that but
he's too big he can't make the struggles
he needs a 65. yeah he's that tweener
yeah he's he's the cowboy Cerrone he's
that that kind of thing he's only 28 man
but yeah he's coming off that knee
surgery I think yeah but the issue with
him though is that he has I'm a huge fan
before I get in there I love Kevin Lee
I'm a huge fan his brother's a dog too
his brother his brother fights in
Bellator Keithley he's a dog too but
he's got a little bit of that mental
[ __ ] kind of thing going on right now
because there's confidence the
confidence thing's going on is there a
live chat anywhere
I thought he was in the in that fight
the whole way
nightmare oh yeah he's good on short
notice you give him a full camera
yeah without without due respect without
due respect with all the respect yeah
you say whatever you want yeah because
he just has that right
let's go you're right man you're right
though hey but with all the respect
I think Rodriguez did he start as a
boxer because his boxing looks chilling
yeah okay yeah he's a dog man oh hey so
um I see Ariel's there yeah how's that
going over and I'm here no no no no no
how do you think he got the job but
how's that going I didn't want to do it
you know God bless them I don't know you
know Showtime dessert thing I do my
thing man yeah I'm here I'll see myself
tonight I'm with you guys those boys are
in Cleveland yeah yeah Cleveland yeah I
like Ariel sometimes sometimes
feel for him I like him
he just you know he likes to kind of
cattle prod people
he's not bad he's not bad yeah I mean if
we're gonna say MMA has if there's going
to be a a good MMA journalist I would
say he's up at the top Dave Meltzer he
asked me I like those two I like him
when I say he got me sued from doing the
interview I'm telling the [ __ ] truth
I got sued I I got he broke me up with
uh a girlfriend I remember and he got me
some millions of dollars
did you lose the lawsuit I settled I
said I could have won the lawsuit but I
said let's talk about this I can't say
much but I can say but I can say I got I
could say I I got Ariel's interview
because of the questions because the
question he asked me and I finally and I
and no no no it wasn't that it was it
was it was a person it was a person that
sued me they saw the interview and they
sued me for that
defamation character yeah is this like
the official call out you can call him
out right now I wanted to pay me back
the money that he paid though got lost
one attorney that um my cousin hooked me
up with took the case didn't do the
[ __ ] job and then I went and had
another attorney a week before trial he
dropped me in and he wrote an email or
something to the judge and said oh um he
didn't pay me and um he's uncooperative
but the guy never then I never had no
communication no no communication then I
hired this big firm they knew they had
any better boss because you know it was
trial so they took my case and
everything then they told me I'll just
settled
Mr Josh and Rampage how do you feel
about when Ariel did the whole Brock
Lesnar thing he announced the Brock
Lesnar fight yeah on the UFC oh yeah him
and Dana were kind of pretty cool so
they were doing the UFC 200 right yeah
Brock was going to come in a big
announcement he was a big announcement
so that's why I didn't like him because
he announced it before and they were
cool before Dana gave him a bunch of
interviews and all this stuff
before you know and he told him hey just
don't say it but that he still did it
that's kind of like yeah journalists
they like they want the big scoop yeah
because that's why you got fired yeah
it's like right
specifically ask you not to do this so
it's like now you know that's why I like
Brett though Brett he's awesome man I
like the way he I like the way he breaks
things down you think so they've never
fought they're all the same
oh my God it's like a weatherman to me
you know what I'm saying stop okay he
won't interview you if uh on a certain
subject if you've you've already done
that interview you know what I'm saying
if some say something big happened or
something and you went on someone else
yeah you and you do an interview like I
he he don't like the interview if you if
you already done it if you do it with
him first so he don't want to do it
that's why that's why I pretty much yeah
learn uh-oh
this kid this kid's the real deal
he's the real [ __ ] deal oh yeah
as far as like being on like show like
as far as marketing oh yeah I don't have
a ton of energy yeah AJ you don't think
so I mean he's such a talent though he's
so good he's such a talent in boxing or
anything yeah he's the world champion he
Bellator he's the guy he's the guy that
I would say if it was going to make a
change over to boxing even though he's a
talented monster he could
why is everyone talking to reach he's
got power
why is everyone talking about man dragon
you're talking about the roar that they
want to well that's because I'm the they
want to see the roar I can't just give
you you can't do that
if Woodley wins he'll do it
okay you promised fire man
was like no I had nicknamese
band dragon
nicknames in the world is
T-Rex Dear Sir Sir they're really
excited about this okay I'm just telling
you right now Woodley has to win guys
we're very excited about this wait wait
don't you know warmed up okay okay
don't worry I got you I got you I'll
breathe it this way okay so scary you
want to switch spots I got fire on my
belly it might go across yeah dude they
love this hilarious no they love me I
wish I could hear what I love that kid
I've been going since he was like three
years old he's a great dude he's a great
kid
oh yeah that kid watch watch mark my
word he's going to be a legend his word
one of the best he's gonna really beat
him he fights at what 70 what's he
fighting 55 45 yeah yeah but he's gonna
go to 55 I think now are these gonna do
it heavyweight I think he's going I
think that fight he just had was the 35
wasn't it no it's a 44. he just won the
title against Patricio at 45. he's gonna
fight one more time I think finish Title
One time they didn't go to 55. to be
honest I never watched Bellator I need
to start I never do a lot of people
don't I'm gonna ask I'm asking is Aaron
Pico still he's making his cousin he's
coming back he's on a he's on a terror
right now yeah he should be he's awesome
he got with Greg Jackson's camp and they
have shaped him and made him the fighter
that he should have been before he
fought he was wrestling at 16 years old
he was wrestling on an international
level no I know this I know he was he
was managed by myself manager I loved
Aaron Pico yeah he's phenomenal man like
put it this way when he fought
yeah you start I'm going to start no
tell us why you don't want it to work I
just want to know why don't you ask
questions I'm curious no because I'm
remiss because I've been remiss and I
deserve to be called
because he's a he's a UFC guy he said
what is your missing right now he's a
UFC guy because yeah yeah if I know the
fighters but there are a lot of Fighters
I know in Bellator that I should watch
oh yeah I like who like uh uh Rory
McDonald that would be one he's in pfl
he is in pfl but keep going
well Lima the Lima Brothers which one
though the one who yeah yeah who [ __ ]
up Rory's leg uh I know which is his
first name yeah because there's one in
the UFC and there's one right Ricardo
Douglas wow wow
okay yeah and then there's uh you know
other guys for example
remiss
when I was young when I was your age you
know how all this uh YouTube stuff ends
it's gonna end no matter what happens to
Jake Paul tonight or in the next fight
he could lose two in a row it's gonna
end with Logan and Jake fighting each
other and that'll be the biggest thing
yeah they're gonna fight each other if
they're smart they will yeah they're
gonna do it
I think you were telling me the last so
which one got famous for doing a video
of somebody hanging from a tree in Japan
he was famous before that he got all the
hate it yeah
exactly what kind of hanging from a tree
you didn't hear about this people go on
commitments someone told me here yeah
and so and he went to a forest and in
the background you could see a blurry a
young man who would was hanging from a
tree it wasn't in the background it
wasn't before they were like filming you
could see that you could see that it was
blurred out but Jake was kind
I think he got kicked off YouTube for a
little bit and he kind of got like
canceled and then came back yeah yeah
and now like he now he does his uh
podcast impulsive and he's gotten older
like people realize he's like an actual
human being a piece of [ __ ] yeah he's
young he was 21. yeah you know he made a
club in the bank so he got canceled
before the council coach yeah yep yep
damn how you do that and when you're on
YouTube for long enough yeah well it was
like he was filming like every Vlog was
crazy what is he wearing did stonewash
jeans come back in style is this what
this is
wow but that's the thing with YouTube
right it's like it's always what's next
because you do a video that's what's
next what's that yeah the one thing I'll
say about the the poor brothers without
doubt they have a crazy work ethic yeah
there's no doubt about it I think where
they both standout wrestlers in high
school in Ohio no just Logan just Logan
yeah athletes it was a two-time state
Placer I think
oh he's a wrestler yeah I don't do MMA
because they know they actually Showtime
signed them to the the potential of him
fighting one MMA fight I don't know
where but Showtime sign him so it must
be in Bellator but they're talking about
him and Dylan Thanos which is a horrible
matchup for him you know it starts with
him well I don't know yeah he's got a
better takedown defense I mean that's
true
Logan Logan and what MMA in MMA yeah
how's he going to deal with Dylan
Dennis's got better wrestling hoping he
can stop excuse me
don't kill the messages I doubt they do
that he's a high school he's not doing
[ __ ] against Stone dance on the ground
no no he's not gonna take him down he's
just gonna stuff the takedowns and get
away and not boxes got no stand up but
like this like this if he grabs a hold
of here it's going to be a big problem
yeah no I agree with you I agree it's
not it's not a good matchup but yeah do
you feel do you feel pressure how you
have to always like one-up [ __ ] like
even your crate challenge you're like oh
everybody doing crate Challenge and this
[ __ ] dude is a great challenge then
he's holding weights eating yeah I mean
it's it's social media is just like
that's kind of the name of it you do
something crazy it's not like
necessarily one up every time it's just
something different yeah you know but
for sure that era of YouTube where he
was making a new video like every week
and it was crazier and he was growing so
fast yeah I mean I'm not saying why he
got there was like it's a it was like at
all a good thing but he definitely kept
that momentum and it just hit something
that he thought was going to be crazy
and it went and it went sad because when
he started that video I don't know if
you guys realize but when he started
that video he filmed the whole video and
then filmed the intro to the video which
was him being like I did the craziest
thing ever you guys are never gonna
believe this never been done before like
he he knew he had done that there was no
remorse and I filmed a crazy video about
how he's like the number one YouTuber in
the world he's doing something that's
never been done and then that was what
it was wow so it was like it wasn't just
something that happened Bradley like I
don't know in the background what was
the point of that like I went to this
Force where people commit suicide how's
that a video this is my point right like
I'm not saying it was a good video
obviously it was terrible and it but it
got so much attention but yeah I don't
know he must have done it and had
something in his mind at the younger age
that like this is the craziest thing
that's ever been done on the internet
because if you saw that going to that
Forest that's what I'm saying I'm saying
the beginning of that video he he filmed
the video and then you could tell he
filmed an intro afterwards and was like
this is one of the craziest things I'm
doing something no YouTuber has ever
done like he self-proclaimed all that
and then got taken down by obviously the
whole world that they filmed a dead body
to hang your body now I know he's grown
so much from it since but it was that
necessity like I got to keep going I
gotta do something crazier and crazy
because that's how all his Vlogs were
and that's how YouTube was at that point
but you did you do crazy stuff before
that one yeah I mean he did crazy all
the time like he like would smashed
plates and do kind of wild [ __ ] and his
audience was very young right so like
they like they're really special wild
[ __ ] it was a very fast-paced like high
energy yeah editing and all that yeah
everything so it was just on this like
it's a steamroll like momentum and it
just hit like a pinnacle of peak that
was not a good one yeah and then it
crushed them and then now he's come back
obviously in a way different way and he
and he's he's great at this podcast and
everything he's really good but that
video was interesting because I remember
watching being like what the [ __ ] like
why would you self-proclaim all that
[ __ ] yeah you don't know you're gonna
get canceled no yeah it's not like you
didn't think you don't start losing me
like yeah yeah
so it's crazy the Sim throwing what's up
with Dylan Dan is trying to fight
everyone though but he never fights that
guy talked [ __ ] to me I said pull up to
my gym right now with fight on the
[ __ ] Street you don't dance yes yeah
I would imagine yeah but he never shows
up he's good he just he just really
fights yeah he just doesn't fight though
dude why you gotta do this I never see
you fight don't fight Dylan dance he's
good on the ground he's really good
we're a class yeah world class do
whatever he wants to you think so the
ragami didn't pull too much have you
ever done any fighting
I dabble okay so yeah do you dabble that
guy made his life fighting I promise you
well yeah have you rolled with anything
I don't know about fighting he's made
his life training
like again he's good he's good though
but he's he's had but what's his body
weight yeah it doesn't matter
it absolutely matters I've wrestled with
a [ __ ] uh I've done Brazilian Jiu
Jitsu with a black belt who's 180. and I
could pick him up and slam him on the
ground like a kid really absolutely and
stuff you've done a lot of I just
dabbled at it but like I'm talking about
a black belt Edwin a Tarzana Gracie Barr
I'm having to say guy away who knows
no no there's a guy there's there's
there's Sam that guy [ __ ] me up okay
but there's a smaller guy black belt
crazy at Jiu Jitsu and like he [ __ ] me
up if I'm on the floor playing with him
but like he got me wrapped up I can
smash him on his head immediately but
I'm not doing it because like cars and
[ __ ] I'm talking about on the street I
think yeah we'll take your arm off I
think I think with the guy your size
he's going right for your ankles your
legs
or his neck nah he's gonna be hard to
get too isn't that he's well you know
Jiu-Jitsu was invented for the smaller
guys yeah yeah I mean I don't know
when he did it to Rampage video footage
of me doing this in that triangle yeah
yeah it's on my channel
he's a Hall of Fame but I was different
I was different at that moment that's
the only time I ever lost my temper in
the fight
there's a backstory behind if you watch
that video and you pause it I come off
the ground yes it's nuts
context he was fighting pride and this
guy Ricardo Arona who's a black belt
gamma in a triangle truck and he
picks him up off the mat jumps in there
and goes he goes right here right here
right here no I remember this you're not
allowed to do this but no one's ever
seen it
I've never seen this yeah they try to
get it it's like one of the best
knockouts in history they try to make it
those guys try to get me like fined and
everything from it that's why they're
smooth Rampage why are you so mad here
I'm gonna show I'm gonna show up the
story he had did something to piss me
off he backed out of a fight when I got
to Japan I had to fight Murillo
Bustamante no one no one told me about
that there's a monster and then when we
was there right here he healed he heals
me in the face and he um dislocates my
jaw right damn so he's like hit him in
the face so I go down he tells the
referee up right here
look at me I cut down cover he tells the
referee I'm knocked out right there and
the pride referees hated me yeah they
could have called that fight and that's
the tournament
you know so I could have lost that fight
because of that and that pissed me off
when he did that he told her three hours
right now you're just dislocated right
now oh yeah my job dislocated yesterday
this is what I'm saying this is how the
black belt Jiu Jitsu guy felt damn
literally felt like that I remember this
this changed a lot of this I remember
everybody was like triangles don't work
against some guys if they're strong
enough look what Rampage did
this was crazy I remember if you if you
parked at the right time I come off my
feet I was really mad at this guy
because they used to always give me
yellow cards they cheated me when I
fought uh vandelay Silva uh when I you
know I bought that tournament yeah this
is I'm gonna tell you guys something
when Chuck and Dale came over to Pride I
had they had a meeting with me uh
represent The Prodigy and they said look
Chuck the Dell is coming over from the
UFC and they said we made a bet with
Danny we got a lot of money we got a lot
of money on this fight you need to uh
[ __ ] Chuck Liddell up I said yeah but
you know I got to fight ventilate silver
next because y'all gave vanilla silver
some some Judo guy and my dumbass I was
young I told him my game but I said all
right I'm gonna do this I'm gonna [ __ ]
Chuck Liddell up but when I fight
vandelay I'm gonna have to take them
down and ground a pound it's gonna you
know it's gonna be a different fight
yeah I'm grounded pound and I'm and I'm
a [ __ ] you guys go back and watch
that fight when I I took ventilate down
ground pound like I just had a [ __ ]
war with chocolate yeah 45 minutes
before and I'm and I'm beating up
vandalam I told him my game plan I'm
beating them up on the ground they give
me a yellow car sound install it and I
wasn't even installing I was beating
them up
I was getting ready to knock him out
what's why would they be there and they
wanted Vanda eventually he was the man
he was a man over there and they wanted
ventilator to win they set the
tournament up for ventilated win like so
the guy they fought vandelay was like
they call him the ax murder he was like
a letter they called him the Gracie
killer yeah is a legend dude Legend
especially when he fought him they're
both like yeah that's lit yeah I wasn't
I wasn't nothing back then that's no I
was I was coming up in Pride yeah I was
coming up was like he was a man he was
he was a man back then but and I was I
was dumb to tell him my game plan
because yeah he told me I told I told
you know I was in the spirits I didn't
know that they wanted ventilated win he
didn't know that they didn't have your
best interest no I didn't know that and
I shouldn't have told him my game plan I
should have told him like [ __ ] yourself
telling me to go and take out um
they didn't tell me to beat him they
said [ __ ] them up show the world that
pride has the best fighters because
remember uh had knocked out um I was
over
he was losing that fight though until he
knocked him out yeah and Jack some of my
closest friends man but he was losing
that fight up until that knocked until
they knocked him out he hit him with
that overhand right yeah over him was
tough he was talking he was yeah it was
tough yeah I wish he would have stayed
at 205 because he was [ __ ] built like
a Greek God bro he was good Heavens man
I came out with that so great he was
[ __ ] 205. he looked long scares
heavyweight at all time when Kenwood uh
when he came over to the UFC and he's
fighting uh he's fighting uh Brendan
called him out on Twitter we were like
young and he was still fighting he's
like he called him out I didn't call it
over him no I thought like no no I
called out a Purdue I have a doom yeah
oh that's right and then you went
running no no you call that one of those
guys and you were like ah [ __ ] what am I
no Mark hunt yeah hunt Mark hunt that's
right that's right Wolverine was the
only guy that I wasn't like
at 205 days that's why I wanted to just
want to have us fight each other at one
point and over and we always been cool
but I was like that's a bad matchup for
me that's that's
quad diesel trip against Jon Jones like
the long arms yeah yeah I trained so
hard for John with the reach but I
didn't think about the Jiu Jitsu he had
long arms and Jiu Jitsu you feel really
strong they say like jokes Chelsea felt
so strong I mean Jon Jones cradled Ryan
Bader pages
I'm a werewolf so I get it I get it I
love asking questions like that to get
your brows up when I get mad
nobody fell strong to me even even
because no one's as strong as you that's
fine
you're strong
Jesus even randomly didn't no he didn't
feel strong because I thought he's gonna
because he's like a bodybuilder I
thought that I was like he's explode he
was explosive Kevin was explosive though
he almost knocked me out Kevin random
almost really damn what a career you
better yeah he hit me and I went down
and my hands are still up you didn't
follow up he didn't follow up on like
thank you you gotta remember remember he
[ __ ] [ __ ] up Fedor yeah and then he
knocked out uh
he knocked down Merkel he he starts
America oh yeah Jesus suplex that crazy
that was one of the the the suplex for
Fedor was one of the probably the best
suplex in the game
and then how he knocked down knocked out
so strong yeah yeah so strong he's yeah
he's a beast Mercury Beast
yeah did y'all see the pictures of fatal
against slam his face expression didn't
change no he's just chilling he's so
good man he was so good man I would hate
to play poke against that guy yeah you
guys play poker well played man
does he uh is he is it true that he's
best friends like with Putin yeah
they're close yeah
how could you not be I mean he's I
remember after that fight in Japan is
all over the newspapers look his face
they had they had in the newspaper they
had play-by-play his face because you
know Pride was so big yeah it's like in
the newspapers over there the next
morning like the national newspaper but
my thing is why I don't get why MMA
can't go back to like sell the Tokyo
Dome and stuff like obviously it's all
related to it's all related to the
Yakuza yeah but they got rid of the
Yakuza in Japan yes they got really
they're kind of still lingering around
but I get what you're saying but they
they did get rid of that's what happened
was what saki Gabara a lot of those guys
all got caught up in the media based on
the fact that Yakuza is tainting like
the Japanese name like it'd be in Japan
yeah right and so that's why they got
rid of Pride and then they try to bring
it back with dream dream kind of did
well for a little bit and then it's
weird they couldn't keep the same like
they lost it I think what happened when
pride is they lost their TV rights when
they found out they were related to
Yakuza yeah so then they got so much
[ __ ] good yeah
yeah who was who is our TV Fuji TV I
think is what it was yeah Fuji TV was
the one you gotta remember this when
they did their uran show they were the
number two
um show every year for their year-end
show yeah so when I fought on their own
show it was they did like uh I don't
know how many people there's 28 million
in Japan that's not they did it they did
26 million that's how many people have
sat at home in a group is in Japan what
yes the group is I used to love it
that's what's crazy man in Japan you
don't get no groupers in America ain't
no female group is an MMA it's all dudes
it's dudes dude they want to buy you
drinks
with neck tattoos so he would look he
would love it I thought they were on New
Year's Eve you know I'm what's called
Pride yeah right so I come out and
[ __ ] uh come out of my hotel room
girls throwing [ __ ] rocks and [ __ ] at
your at your window at night all night
while you're trying to sleep I don't
know if they're there to like to [ __ ]
you up because you know in Japan they're
trying to keep you awake they're trying
to [ __ ] you up they're thinking you
shitty food
bro Sushi like though like that he said
he said he showed up he was supposed to
fight Arona the next you know he shows
up and he's fighting who
you know when you fight a Japanese guy's
different I'm telling you I'm fine
Japanese guys Japanese guy dude they've
done so much [ __ ] to me when I find
Japanese guy the first time I fought
that was on a short notice I was
supposed to fight Ken Shamrock what yeah
I was supposed to fight Ken Shamrock
then uh Terry treble [ __ ] from King in
the cage I had just started for uh
training for cancer I had like I had
like uh three or four months three
months two months to train for kids you
don't look like that they gave me two
weeks they gave me two weeks they
changed they fight soccer and then back
then probably didn't have weight classes
they told me uh when I got there they
was like uh uh you know a couple days
after I got there they said uh you gotta
lose weight for this fire and like yeah
I don't have weight class they want me
to cut wait the day of the fight yeah
the morning you're just doing whatever
[ __ ] so I said I'm not cutting weight
the day before the I mean the day of the
fight so the day before I'm I'm cutting
weight and and uh and I just I just
couldn't lose all the weight and did I
just have my team carry me to the scales
and it was happy yeah that's when I
started my acting career yeah
but all they're doing is trying to get
put the chips in Sakura yeah yeah
they're doing whatever they can do yeah
let me tell you I think I think they're
getting something
where did you eat [ __ ] up food where'd
you eat [ __ ] up two years ago Sakura
was so famous that when I got to Japan I
was instantly famous when I got they had
like laminated like thick plexiglass uh
trading cards because you were the guy
friends like around yeah I I haven't
fought nothing past King of the cage so
when I got to Japan I was instantly
famous and plus I went to jail trying to
leave the country so it was down in the
newspaper in Japan that I had to leave
that I had to get bailed out of jail
they building up to be this badass
getting out of getting out of jail
getting out of prison yeah and so I was
instantly famous as soon as I got to
Japan isn't true they would pay you guys
in cash yeah yeah yeah yeah in the hotel
lobby yeah no I wasn't I wasn't no I'll
be in them
no they got it they got it you go in the
room and they got big stacks of money
right now and it's it's fresh off it's
brand new money brand new money you're
like you're like this you're like
licking you get it off the other one
like that that's how stupid it is I gave
people 200 bucks
for New Year's they they own the Tokyo
Hilton so we fought in Tokyo so the
actual Lobby they had all the they had
all the fighters come down at a certain
time and they had four guys black black
suits white shirts black ties sitting
there Yakuza style guys just sitting
there hanging out and there was one guy
sitting on the couch here's your bag it
was a brown paper bag of just crisp 100
bills American money not not good yeah
they get offended when you counted the
money no no he actually told me he's
like you count it oh yeah because when
they gave my money on time up in the
room you probably made a little more
than running than me so they probably
were mad at me you probably did [ __ ]
forever though after like maybe a year
or two
um fighting her I could tell I could
tell just by holding a second technique
10 000 right yeah I could tell right
just by holding it oh yeah
the only time I get on those dark arts
where they paid cash when I was fighting
no gear in Brazil and the night before
the fight these uh Brazilian gangsters
went up to my coach my coat we only had
one coach that support Portuguese and
like you translate to him and so he's
talking to me in Portuguese and he goes
hey they're gonna pay you 50 000 cash if
after you knock out uh nogara uh you
wear that you put this jersey on the
soccer shirt I'm like [ __ ] I'll do that
I don't give a [ __ ] yeah but the way
they're going to do it is they're gonna
come up to your room right now and then
put the cash in your safe and only they
know the code if you win they're gonna
call and give you the code if you lose
then come back and get their money all
right say less put the money up there
impressive I get starched right no no
gear starts me in Brazil so embarrassing
I'm waiting in my whole family's in the
in the hotel room you know my eyes out
to here and then dude
what years were these
[ __ ] mine was in 2005. 2004 2005 I
fought in Pride and then I fought again
in dream in
2007 and eight somewhere around there
20 years wow yeah I was in the UFC when
you were in King of the kids you were
supposed to fight Bobby Southworth yeah
that's how I got the pride because Bobby
said that's how I got the pride because
Bobby Southworth pulled out pulled out
he pulled out last minute so he needed
somebody yeah and and um Terry Trevor
called he he grabbed some big dude out
of the out of the crowd yeah what some
big dude and I and I picked him up and I
body slammed him yeah soccer kibara came
to the locker room as if I said he said
I like your character oh he gave me his
business card damn he said he's Pride
yeah I didn't and I didn't know anything
about pricey I wasn't an MMA fan when I
came over to this yeah so I didn't know
anything before that
are you a wrestler or what yeah yeah I
wrestle but I only saw a wrestling
because I wanted to be a pro wrestler
okay I'm from Memphis you know Bob
wasn't imminent how'd you get into
fighting though it was a it was a
mistake when I got back from college
story I heard you were a bouncer and
Tito and you guys knew each other and he
kind of like you kind of helped him
train someone told me hold on did Tito
tell you that story no I heard it
through it I heard it through it like I
guess through a media Source through
Tito maybe tutor did tell it it's it's
still been so long this is a truth to
that because I moved out here to be a
fighter so I was already training
because I was out here then I didn't
know who T there was somebody said oh um
Tito tease is here and I said which one
is he though they looked at me like you
train the MMA you don't know who Tito
team is that's a big deal back there I
said I said I don't watch that [ __ ] then
they show them they said the guy right
there with the big head like oh okay and
then and then years years later uh he
started training with my my coach the
guy I'm moving the train with Fabiano
and then they they like teamed up in the
gym now supposed to fight him in Pride
oh for real yeah yeah and I started
training and I started training with
Tito Ortiz I was helping him train for
his fights Sakura to me was my favorite
fighter for the longest time
did you guess he's a nice guy man no I'm
gonna tell you something quiet not
really I didn't know that well he is a
nice guy but I saw him a couple years
ago and he acted like he didn't know who
I was but he's like big time dude no no
but I think he was joking though but he
don't speak English but he's he's like
so famous in Japan but he I said oh
what's up Robert how you doing then then
he he was like he was like no man like
what's your name he kept fighting he
kept fighting until like he did like uh
yeah I think he was joking but I almost
slapped uh soccer Robert today because
because he he grabbed my hands and not
the cheeks he grabbed it right he
grabbed it right in the middle in the
middle oh wow
I don't know what that means because I
don't know nothing about that yeah I'll
tell you about that life that's Brian it
means business
it took it took every it took every bit
because the place where he was at it
took every bit of homes and decency
from me not to from me not to slap just
sit out at soccer rock it took
everything it took everything I had just
cracked look at your face
but no but I looked at him and I looked
at him and I told soccer I know he don't
speak English but I know he understood
the [ __ ] I said I said I said soccer up
don't ever do that [ __ ] again you know
what you know he's still a big star over
there but it's like when when you put
that amount of amount of like effort
into fighting stuff like that the that
culture never forget never forget
America they're like under the next
that's what's up about American culture
and stuff I love it it's on to the next
country but that's the one thing that
people like as long as what have you
done for me lately as long as you can't
do anything for me now [ __ ] off I didn't
know how famous soccer rubber was until
they flew me over to do a movie with him
right I'm doing a movie with uh soccer
Robert it was like uh the old school
Yakuza style yeah and uh I guess I was a
character working for the Yakuza boss
it's like old time like maybe like a
western yeah yeah but it was but it was
Yakuza and stuff like that and um so
they had me fight sakurama in this movie
right and they and they filming me doing
all this stuff to me getting my licks in
or something
[Applause]
you realize how much it's gonna actually
make it yeah not much yeah but but you
did a team too right yeah first like big
break that's the biggest movement that's
the biggest move I've ever done I I
didn't I haven't done [ __ ] big since
then by choice
now it wasn't by choice it's some it was
a lot it was a lot of hateration going
on I heard that that was Joe Carnahan
right Joe Carter has the man he's a man
he's a man
Brian's really close to Joe he's the
best man I love that guy brother for
life you feel bad we're not watching
this fight at all
you know
I didn't even know yet we don't know
these guys hey you know what but people
that are watching this right now they're
loving all this [ __ ] right here
man
I shot away from doing podcasts and
stuff because everybody got a damn
pocket I almost got one yeah
man I don't know yeah I think it's
saturated oversaturated you are such a
personality dude you're fine today I
would tell everybody not to to do one
you're one of the very few people I
would actually say you could do it with
[ __ ] I've told Brian to stop doing some
of them yeah you could do it oh you
think so everybody's like everybody
everybody
well here's the thing though like you
don't have to talk about MMA like I want
to do another one but I want to do one
separate from anything to do with MMA
are you like cars yeah you have
everything I'm type person I like [ __ ]
I'm not a fan yeah I'm the weirdest I'm
the weirdest guy
you're not weird man you're like you're
like the rest of us you like the rest of
us but I could do a car show together
yep I don't know [ __ ] about cars you ask
me like yeah but I do okay I'll go over
your house and I'll bring my cars yeah
I'll be kicking with Josh Barnett you
know back in the day hey I hear him talk
about it he knows everything he knows
he's a Gearhead yeah
he can build his [ __ ] himself Josh is he
might be you know you're not five years
my brother would be considered a
Gearhead Josh run into Gearhead Brogan's
Gearhead I'm like in the middle there
yeah I'm not a [ __ ] is just like nice
stuff I wrote him back in the day you
know what Rogan is he's also a computer
nerd like back in the day I remember
like literally before like when the
internet was when he had the internet
and I was like you have the internet I
didn't know this is 96 or whatever yeah
he was going to to Fry's the computer
play too
what was that I rocked him after the
million I would love to hear you on
Rogan Rampage because he has a Rolodex
of Pride stories too oh yeah he's never
invited oh he will yeah
right now right now Joe Joe let's get
him off he just heard it there you go
Joe
that's cool don't hear um
I was funny I was down helping Rob
McCullough and then you would you just
you just went to the UFC and I remember
you had a R8 oh yeah you had you had a
like yeah yeah
it would that's probably one of my
favorite cars based on the fact that
it's most probably one of the most
comfortable sports cars oh [ __ ] look at
this but we had I had a magazine shoot
and they actually came to the gym to
shoot me at the gym like hey whose car
is that and I was like Hey Quinn can I
use your car real quick because they
want to take some photos of me in front
of your car yeah you're like yeah yeah
just don't touch it he's like yo yo yeah
you can't just don't touch it what's
your favorite car right now
uh
I I gotta say my hell kid I see I still
got the first generation Hellcat that's
my favorite car I love that the monsters
it's American Muscle handling's not
great but whatever it depends on what
you're doing yeah
it didn't need nothing yeah they're sick
this fight just got interesting this one
this fight's a lot more balance for sure
based on the [ __ ] stats the Russian
guy I think has got the best of in the
last round yeah we had a clip from The
Ultimate Fighter days up there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah how fun was that that was
fun man hey you was probably one of the
only guys on the other team that we
liked when I was just talking about that
yeah you and I were friends yeah we're
friends and I love Rashad well how could
you how can they not be friends with you
man if they all thought you were black
yes
[Laughter]
the Orange County
it's very white age Asian Asian that's
why you're there yeah you see this
yeah look at that smile yeah
let me tell you that's my pet peeve
people think that I have an Asian fetish
oh I think it's a fattest
I don't have any fetishness okay I think
I think in my opinion I think a fetish
is a little bit too overboard for me so
I don't have any fish but I Asian women
are my favorite it's my favorite yeah I
like I like all I'm saying okay but I
like all women but you wouldn't say the
way that had oh no I'm not saying
last three women you've dated who whose
Persians Persians Puerto Rican and
Colombian okay that's dangerous that's
dangerous and Asian it's just a
preference my favorite preference I I
dated oh I go I date all girls
they're my least favorite okay I like
them though I almost married one in
college okay that's why they're my least
favorite
it's funny how the college girlfriends
they're always they just tainted you I
did man bro she man bro
I had a Mexican girlfriend she bro she
[ __ ] me up man she went to Argentina
for be a foreign exchange student [ __ ]
her host brother yeah and then I had I
had I had my oldest you know [ __ ] and I
had a kid from college my oldest son she
found out how the older son got mad that
I didn't abort him so she so when I
moved out here wow you got it so wait
you gotta go overseas you got a girl
pregnant no no no no no no she cheated
on me then you got something then I got
somebody pregnant then then I moved back
to Memphis
and um she she showed up at my front
door she found out found out about my
son got mad at me because I didn't I
didn't abort him she got pregnant on
purpose told me she was on the pillow
aborted my kid dang and then it was
wrong then was finally Gonna Leave me
he's a Savage bro then she was going to
break up with me and all the feelings
came I said no no no no no no no you
can't leave me and then after that my
old friend told me to uh used to be my
friend the one who's fought in the UFC
he told me to come out here and train
California we drove out here together
long story short my baby mama needed to
move in and my baby mom get into it she
gets because they could become friends
they teamed up on me because it's the
worst my life is a reality show for God
so
and uh and she and you know she was
right there and I'm not proud of what I
did but I yelled I really schooled at my
baby mama I really scold that is two
weeks two weeks before I fought more
even easing me for the first time and
and uh I kicked so I so I so I kicked my
baby mama out I kicked her out and and
they went together and she went and told
her family that uh I hit her that I beat
her up why did you how did you how's
that how's your son now how old is he
yeah yeah he's 22 now and does he fight
dude no that's my first son he's albino
I wouldn't let him fight he his eyes
twitch real fast and he played Sports
football but I got a 21 year old son
that's trans women
yeah wow blonde hair and blue eyes yeah
damn I met him a couple times you had
him at um at the gym yeah I was a single
I was a single parent yeah I've been
when I was fighting Japan I was a single
parent how did you find out that your
your girl [ __ ] her host bro she told
me I know she didn't tell me I I knew I
know [ __ ] man just I called her I called
Argentina he answered the phone and when
and when and when I said you know man I
speak to iron was their name I just
heard his voice how he caught in it and
then when she came from it was just
guilt and she he was laughing in the
background and she just the way she
sounded it wouldn't sound like that
didn't I didn't actually I said I said
y'all [ __ ] huh
and then she she tried a lot a little
bit at first then she then she told you
but now what really hurt me I was close
to her family she had a twin sister damn
they didn't look nothing like that she
had four she had three sisters
her dad was super cool you know saying I
was close I was close to her family and
then she goes back and tell them that I
hit her she got no she's got no proof no
scars nothing nothing no and and they
believed her but I understand you bleed
the fan but right yeah I said your
family's gonna believe you but yeah I
can't believe that she I can't believe
that she did that today yeah yeah that's
fine but you know I I did scold my baby
mama you know I'm saying the baby mama
was was reassured I was doing I was a
bouncer at the time yeah uh and at Venom
at the Vietnamese Club
that's where this fetish came from I
never had a fetish
the first time the first time I brought
a uh
my mama said she said I knew it I knew
you go like Asia girl said why did she
told me the story she said as soon as
you you was old enough to walk I lost
you in a grocery store and I found you a
couple hours down away and you was
kissing on some little Chinese girl
once you go Asian you won't go back
Caucasian
hey but hey but you're right though yeah
when you have when you have a high
school hey when you have a college
girlfriend your college girlfriend will
taint you for the rest of your life I
had a man I was a Mexican girl because
I'm half Mexican all my mom my mom's
younger yeah
yeah so my mom said my mom's half and
I'm a mom's football I'm half and so
then date like out of date of Mexico all
through college [ __ ] man brutal and then
my mom's the youngest of 13. and so she
got a lot of sisters and they're they're
all 13. they're all divorced oh yeah
they're all divorced white girl uh is
your girl white now yeah no no Asian hey
yes
hey hey you go you go there
Korean Chinese okay yeah I don't I don't
really date videos no I got a lot of
Vietnamese um I got a lot of Vietnamese
homegirls and stuff like that and I love
the Vietnamese culture but for me in my
opinion I could be wrong but this is my
opinion for what I learned from working
at the Vietnamese bars and clubs yeah
most all my friends in Vietnamese yeah
they too much like black people
oh
the Vietnamese girls
they too much like almost like girls
so I was like
NFL
I could be friends with them I've dated
one Vietnamese girl she's from San Diego
yo she's from San Diego
[ __ ] who do you find the most yeah yeah
for me it's Vietnamese Vietnamese girls
are that they're the most beautiful
Koreans are bad Koreans are bad but
they'd be a lot of plastic surgery
though he
all you can do is the guys wear a
shining shirt you know you don't have a
[ __ ] there's no like surgery that
really gives you I guess you can do a
lot of steroids man can you imagine
taking your kid to get past the surgery
because if you don't have you not seen
that have you not seen that picture of
that Indian dude who's got the the
biceps surgery for guys's money right
chin that guy yeah the end of the Indian
guy has a fake that's gross the oil yeah
or it's like like if you have hair
issues he has to refill that everything
so often I want to get a hair transplant
but it's gonna look dumb
I don't want to make your head any
bigger than it is yeah you're actually
not a bad looking guy for the age you
are yeah I'm just being honest man I
hope I hope I look as lean as you at
this age for sure people get stem cells
you look even younger it works where did
you get yourself where'd you get yours
at I got mine done in Columbia with uh
through Jamie Varner Jamie Varner is
working with a company I think down at
Panama or Colombia accelerators
you've done stem cells I have not but I
want it I haven't done a lot
like
it's life changing the shot's not paying
I got him both of my knees and my in my
in my hand because I had a real bad bone
bruise or something and then my right
shoulder and and you swear by it yeah
yeah why would you get it brother my
shoulder's [ __ ] up it's been [ __ ] up
for a long time it's like well you gotta
stop trying to walk in them goddamn
crates yeah
Logan said he had a labrum tear and then
did stem cells and then yeah
surgery so wow life changing and they
could put in your penis too really to
make it bigger no but they said Kelly
just perked up real quick
like like Home Improvements
all the time or is it like no no it's
like it's like from what they explain
it's like you know if you're the type of
guy that need like you know dick pills
like you won't need the dick pills
that's what they were telling me I
almost did it but I didn't do I took it
out because I couldn't think of it
on your dick
you don't need the pills man take your
ham Bean what's that yo henby it's a
African yeah
see for me I don't at 54 I'm I'm lucky I
get good genetics I don't need pills yet
but I can't the minute the [ __ ]
minute I feel any of my energy go down
or my energy I can't wait to get on
testosterone I'm gonna get [ __ ]
jacked nobody don't make those ears
bigger
so this way you're saying to take
Rampage yeah you take that take it in
the morning
you take two in the morning and two at
night then you don't never need to take
no dick pill
is
yeah
y'all asked me a question I never got a
chance to answer it because yeah when
you asked me how did I get started yeah
yeah because the whole got the Tito
thing yeah yeah so uh I was I was um I
went back to Memphis I got out of
college and I used to be friends with
this guy used at the wrestle in college
I mean in high school and he was trading
MMA and were you a good I know me in a
reputable are you a good wrestler in
high school I just started assistant I
was undefeated until Regional finals
okay did you but did you play a sport in
college or no wrestle oh you wrestled in
college and that sucked I won one
wrestling match okay yeah that sucked
but you know I liked I was new to it
yeah you liked it and and uh so he took
me to the MMA show like a little small
shows and I saw this fighter there I
didn't know who he was and um he
triangle took somebody the guy Tapped
Out the referee stopped the fight he put
his foot in the guy face and pushed him
off and I said I want to fight that guy
he a [ __ ] dick and then my friend
started training for a fight three days
notice they said hey you want to fight
I'm like uh fight who is they say you
remember that guy you said you want to
fight they said yeah opponent pulled out
and I get that it's Mike Powell
he was he was like undefeated in Memphis
he was the biggest the highest he was
like perfect and what happened I I ended
up beating him by decision damn I ended
up my first fight ever my first fight
ever I beat him by the seat and they
said oh you're a fighter now and then
then my friend he moved to uh he went
and followed in UFC 19 or 20 something
like that and he and he met Fabiano and
then they became friends and then he he
flew out to California with his wife and
stuff and started trying to six months
later he he sent for me I quit my job
left my I left my family everybody and
it was a pretty fast Freddy once you got
to California I can't remember I'm bad
with time but I was out here I was there
for a while and Fabiano he didn't he
didn't he didn't charge me God was broke
as [ __ ] I couldn't I couldn't afford
rent I just left everything I took me a
while to fight took my six months to
find a damn bouncing job down made like
45 dollars a [ __ ] night and so
Fabiano he didn't charge me so he he
threw this show that's where I met uh uh
Joe daddy Stevenson because he beat my
friend he beat the [ __ ] out of my friend
on this show and I fought for free he
was trying to pay on it now man you
don't charge me I fight for free so that
was my that was my uh second fight my
second amateur fight and then
um then after that I think I fought
Marvin Eastman and King the case and
then that's what we're not racist yeah I
remember so many wait you fought Marvin
twice I [ __ ] Marvin twice yeah I
didn't know that I didn't know yeah he
beat the [ __ ] out of me the first fight
was that a lot of memories but that was
your first fight that was your first
fight in UFC right when you first got to
use yeah yeah that was my deal see the
UFC they bought W what was it WFA they
brought WFA for my contract because
remember remember Chuck was coming back
or avenging all his losses yeah that was
the last guy he knocked him out with
that left hook right there yeah I was
the last I was the last guy you and
Chuck are cool now man Chuck is cool I'm
gonna tell y'all how chuck chuck messed
up he mixed up uh that that that that
that that was a right hook that was all
his fault because oh oh we missing it
gave me the hardest body shot I ever
received in my life right and when he
hit me in the body I made a noise and he
remembered it I mean he hit me and I
went for the takedown and then the bell
rang right so when we fought when we
fought and and UFC he was trying to set
me up for that body shot same body shot
and that's what [ __ ] that's what that's
what lost him to fight oh damn he was
trying to go for that body shot oh
that's it and and I I counted the butter
shot and hooked and and I came you guys
worked on that in Camp yeah who no no no
but but that's my style when people go
for the body I have I have like
working with a boxing coach I think for
that camp because I remember you gave
him a shout out because I remember yeah
you know remember you caught him and you
were like and you said you gave him a
shot and said we worked on like for my
boxing like he I think that was
vandalate when I knocked that ventilated
for the first time I brought a boxing
coach from England okay but but but I
did have a boxing uh coach for the um
for the Tucker therefore I do how good
did that feel because you did go to the
vanderling fight how good did that feel
I'll get that win that was my favorite
one that was your
yeah that was that was the fight that I
was waiting because after you got that
one back I was like God he's got to be
feeling so good about it yeah right now
because I always knew I can beat
ventilate I always knew that I can beat
him but I just wasn't but I just wasn't
prepared like when I first I was fine I
was training with I was spawning with
Jujitsu guys I didn't I didn't have like
a um a team of people to spar and bang
with so I was sparring with jiu-jitsu
guys who didn't want to be in the ring
with me they didn't want to be in the
cage I wouldn't want to be in the ring
with you just being honest it was it was
it was hard it was hard to prepare for
for ventile and Shogun and ninja you
know it was hard because those guys you
have a lot of boxers like like just
strictly boxers no not a whole lot yeah
we missed a good fight uh we gotta keep
the air condition on another supposed to
shut out the response tonight manscape
the official electric trimmer of the UFC
if you haven't tried the new lawnmower
4.0 it's like a spaceship it's got a
400k LED light to help you navigate and
dedicate the dark areas talking about
your nut sacks have your balls feeling
the experience of zero gravity help your
little planet stay protected from the
sun's heat with a performance I know
package 4.0 which includes the ball
toner ball deodorant boxers travel bag
and of course the lawnmower 4.0 and all
the thick boys tonight get 20 off and
free shipping with code CFC at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code CFC at
manscape.com we got the link and code in
the bio
do this guy not look like Tyron Woodley
this is not does not come around
a little bit is this is the next fight
uh no I think the female version yeah
she's good man dude oh yeah during the
weekend they turn the AC off
so hopefully it works
my team forgot to tell no way
yes shut the [ __ ] yes you swear to God
yeah he was on yeah it was crispy
but this one we just said [ __ ] yeah okay
we've been here both times thanks man
this might be your last day
who's your guy that arranging my ride
here who was that guy Ah that's that's
my boy Casey so slap him around bro when
they told me a Prius came to pick up
Rampage Jackson I didn't want to show up
dude I don't want to show up prayers
with no AC and we get there was a
hundred and something degrees 105.00
Yeah I just adjusted it whoa so you came
from a no AC car to a no AC room nice
yeah but they have these fans
and the Prius had a big dent in the
[ __ ] door I was so
[ __ ] embarrassed because I'm
I'm a bear dude I'm random I'm renting
an apartment just close to Antonio
McKee's gym right yeah and so I come
outside as a bunch of other cars people
out there
oh damn Rampage fell off yeah yeah
I said I hope it ain't this prison your
mother had a big ass dinner in the
[ __ ] door his windows down no AC damn
I hope it's not this friend I'm like
Brandon it's brand that's why [ __ ] with
me because I wasn't his coach on
Ultimate Friday
he still got that [ __ ] going on yeah
because we didn't [ __ ] out with those
chickens and [ __ ] yeah I think I thought
you maybe still no I don't know man I
was so embarrassed that listen if I
booked the car it would have been uh
it'd been a nice car that was uh that
made me wonder about your budget for
your show that's what I said that's such
a badly us are you [ __ ] with us he
takes me
why would I [ __ ] with you what are you
talking about he goes you sent a Prius
the Rampage I'm like no that's [ __ ]
way yeah man honestly honestly I
probably wouldn't even say anything but
there was so many people out there
looking at me getting into prayers
because the problem is I leave some hot
chicks still there I had some hot chicks
I thought he was supposed to be somebody
right damn yeah it's tough it's tough
time it's tough yeah it's okay yeah
maybe next time you can slap Casey
around a little bit yeah let me strap
him around I feel a little better where
is that guy sorry oh come over here
yeah I just want to see what he looks
like that's right he's running the show
there yeah he was really apologetic when
he said he wanted to see if I said the
truth hey how busted was that previous
when I pulled up the worst friends you
see the big dent in it the windows down
would you would you book it on Lyft or
some [ __ ]
owned it
I'm not too good to ride in the periods
though I honestly I'm not nobody is no
it's not about that just it's more the
AC thing that would have it was a big no
it was a big dent for me I'm one of
those guys
are you a muscle car guy are you uh I
like I like muscle car I like muscle
cars but I like cars I I like what's
your dream car
oh man my dream car that's a good
question that is that is a good question
um
you know I always wanted one of those
skylines one day yeah yeah
I heard they passed a lot yeah oh man
you gotta show them
which one I thought I'm not a car guy
like that the one with the circle circle
tail lights yeah the circle tell it yeah
yeah
it's like the art ones
that white one right yeah not the
America the white ones
it just passed the wall so you see some
they're like American I mean they're
Japanese muscle cars yeah like like I
was in uh San Diego and they have the
Cars and Coffee up there and there's
there's one of those in Black yeah and
the the driving uh is on the right side
at the left are these cars really rare
right uh the GT2 RS is and then I just
got allocated for a f8 tributo Ferrari
oh nice yep
see here's the thing I've driven a Lambo
I've driven Ferrari I've driven the R8
the r18 is the nicest probably in terms
of comfort you get try to get Adam in
and out of a Lambo on the floor yeah
it's a [ __ ] pan
but they're not comfortable though
Teslas they're not comfortable the
leather and [ __ ] is horrible the second
second tier [ __ ] no don't be wrong
they're fast they're fast as [ __ ]
because there's no they fast as hell
yeah they're fast as hell but they're
not comfortable yeah it's like if you're
if you're paying 180 000 for a vehicle
you want to be comfortable I want to be
able to drive somewhere like an Aston
Martin they're [ __ ] so uncomfortable
you drive for more than 30 minutes
you're [ __ ] horrible oh I don't know
what you've driven brother I I've had
Ferraris Porsches no what I'm saying
they're hard they're hard again all of
them fries and Lambos they're they're
just hard for me to get like I'm small I
can't imagine you guys trying to get out
of a Lambo yeah yeah
you put your hand on the ground
I saw a McLaren I don't know what how it
was they're nice it's one of the newer
ones yeah I don't fit them because
they're in Lambos I can't drive yeah
yeah I love them I love I love my LP
640. I love that car which which fry do
you have I had I had his total now I had
a LP 640.
my one of my friends oh the lambo yeah
one of my friends he like helps me with
my cars because because I'm lazy I like
to sit at home play video games so
that's one of these Services something
he'll help me out and and uh he's like
he's like my brother and so I let him I
let him drive it he you know he wouldn't
go do it for him he didn't charge me no
money so yeah he's driving he goes and
shows out he ends up getting drunk and
told us my car he almost killed himself
the car would flip you see the car you
think what color was it it was lime
green it was that car it was the lp 640
yeah it was a [ __ ] damn but yeah no I
don't have I don't I don't I don't get a
DUI wait what what do you no he he he
left he fled the scene it's so tough to
allocated by Friday like to get in we'll
get MSRP what kind of Ferrar I had a
rose hey what's what's that what's that
bring that up
and by the way you can drive that for
five years and you sell it back for the
same amount of money almost more really
for that so you're driving it for free
this one right here this is the car
you're getting yeah vacuums I just
ordered it yesterday what I like about
Brennan is he'll buy a car like that and
most people will keep that they'll take
it on the weekends for an hour he drives
it every day
where did you live when you were at the
studio in Santa Monica here but my
studio was in Santa Monica gotcha gotcha
yeah we were driving yeah
that that Porsche I was wondering why
you didn't film until like 10. I was
like [ __ ] man get out of bed lazy
she's like yeah we feeling the pretend
I'm like five ten
that's really great damn yeah I love
them I love cars man I can't get enough
I just never I don't know I don't care
do you know who Doug marrow is he's like
the nerdy car guy and he's like the
biggest YouTube yeah card guy yeah I saw
him at that Cars and Coffee man you know
you know you're gonna make fun of me but
really yeah
what's up dog that's sick you you'll
make fun of me but I I I know you like
fashion I've been watching next in
Fashion on Netflix the best fashion
designers like you get any tips because
you're dressed well I'll never dress
that way but I have to say that they're
such artists that I'm obsessed with it
the best they're they're such characters
the people themselves but God damn
they're good at what they do I love
anybody who's really good at what they
do even even fashion I know nothing
about it I love that show so yeah so we
got one more time
one of them should be the girls yeah
yeah she's good she's
a monster she trains out she trains over
a ruca oh god oh [ __ ] our first names on
the tip of my tongue wait no the block I
watched that you see oh we've got we've
got this fight here instead first oh
wait what yeah two more fights did you
see the uh
did you see the [ __ ] uh I mean you
know after a while you're like come on
guys did you see the fight with uh uh I
mean she had a documentary around
Christy Martin no I watched it I loved
it it's so good it's so good dude it's
so how tragic her train so Christy might
you know she's a black Tyson female yeah
she gets on Mike Dyson card they have
the fight of the night and then she she
gets super famous and then they thought
she would like bring other women up but
she was just a [ __ ] talker so she was
she was like kind of all about herself
so all the girls get him for it and then
she starts dating her trainer they get
married and then uh she's a lesbian so
she's like oh he's been hiding that all
her life and then she meets her like it
was like the love of her life from high
school and she starts hanging out with
her and then uh this guy just controlled
everything that's him the scumbag
controlled everything right just
controlled her entire life so she leaves
doesn't tell him leaves and he goes if
you leave I'm gonna kill you she always
comes your eyes and goes then do what
you got to do and then walks out the
door and she's with this girl for you
know like four or five days in Florida
and then he finally gets Holdings they
come back so she's like I'm gonna come
back get my [ __ ] comes back and he stabs
her and shoots her once she survives she
survives yes
it's a crazy it's such a good
documentary what year was this uh that
was like in the 90s yeah she started
stop fighting like 2002 Maybe 2004. yeah
but it's such a good documentary did you
kill her did he just no he stabbed her
and shot her and thought she was dead
and went to the shower and she escaped
holy [ __ ] so he's so tough wait wait he
shot her and then he stabbed her shot
her and then took a shower yeah did you
get all the blood off and thought she
was dead yeah
and now she's Met she's married to the
or She's Dating the girl who she fought
she's she's this other female girl this
girl yeah such a good story man this is
what this documentary is like live right
now yeah just came out on Netflix it's
so goddamn good there's there's that new
document about Monica Lewinsky is coming
out with Bill Clinton and Monica oh
really I guess a new like a whole new
one I guess apparently it's dropping
like
check that one I'll watch that that's
awesome all right we'll check that out
I'm gonna go watch this
what's it called when's that drop
Channel you know
tell us about like her and I guess
sucking off Bill Clinton
think about what she was 22 21 23
somewhere around there yeah oh bill that
old scallywagon yeah
a little bit I voted for him yeah big
old dick Willy
work
dude he has some serious issues yeah
there's a bunch by the way 40 years old
not bad 39 is it 49. at least 39 right
now he'll be 40 here in the next I think
in the next couple weeks though are his
eyes blue there no that's the camera
yeah he's right by the pool or some [ __ ]
he's a stub though man he is man like
he's explosive he's fast bro have you
have did you see when him and uh Jake
Paul sat down to like talk [ __ ] Jake
Paul's not great at talking [ __ ] yeah
yeah I know it's like real cringy and
you know Willy's a real dude the thing
that's funny I noticed is Aiden Ross
made like being sus like pretending gay
really popular on the internet and then
Jake Paul have you did you see the
interview no watch did you did you watch
that interview he just totally ran with
the whole like let me try and act like
I'm gonna oh he's talking about his ass
and stuff yes exactly yeah yeah I posted
it it was funny and Woody's not playing
I didn't see I didn't see Willie's
reaction on the clip and she's not
really reacting yeah so Jake wasn't that
good at talking in the trash it's just
like he just pulled the whole sus thing
and that was it I didn't know it was a
thing I was just like oh this is weird
yeah I mean if you don't know the I
guess the yeah you don't know that yeah
this is very sure the clip the clip I
saw was funny as [ __ ] what is what
happened by the way Jake Paul is a big
he's big dude yeah he's big I think he
cuts to 190 for the fight but he's gonna
walk in probably two
Willie's gonna come in probably 190.
that's what I'm saying the weight
difference yeah the reach the reach and
the height but the speed is going to go
to Woodley for the first time at least
for the first three or four rounds
he is extremely explosive extremely
but he is 39
and
damn I just think the weight difference
right Rampage how do you think uh John
would do at heavyweight Jon Jones yeah
man I think Jon Jones one of the best
fighters in the world oh ever I think uh
I think he'll do do um good against like
the um smaller heavyweights but you
don't think you do well against like
Francis or yeah I think I think he'll
take Francis down and you know so I
think he probably would but I think if
he get hit if he gets hit one problem I
think if he get I think if he gets hit
once he'll probably get knocked out of
that weight class
in ghano I think Cyril gone is going to
give him Gano it's good fights Yeah
by decision they trained together I
think they were in the same camp for a
year no it's not even that long like
France France was like we were in that
close the training party like USC is
trying to paint it like we're all close
like a few times yeah kickboxing is no
joke no his kickboxing and his wrestling
is better than in Ghana's you could you
could argue who's this you could argue
Cheryl gone you could argue that I think
he's had two oh he's wrestling his
wrestling's for sure but yeah yeah for
sure another one's gonna they're they're
not neither one of the top level
wrestlers stuffed those steep base
takedowns like just that sprawl was just
like yeah
shot Under Pressure he shot because he
got also he also stuffed Curtis blades
too yeah
that's big who who was in gandu's next
fight
it's gonna be Sierra gone in France okay
and uh
no I'm gonna put my they're working on
McDonald's contract right now
contract he wants more money he deserves
more money yeah how much does he get
paid he got paid 585 last fight
how crazy is that and then that's when
they said fight Jon Jones he's like bro
pay me like I'll find Jon Jones right
quit paying me 500 oh yeah look at that
holy [ __ ]
yeah that's crazy
is is that's 40 Grand yeah Jon Jones
gonna fight the only reason why he made
well the reason why he made the 85 he's
got a 75 000 bonus okay and then you got
another like 10 grand for a monster or
for whatever the sponsor was yeah
whatever it was from the short spots
yeah yeah yeah wow bro we were there we
were there during the good times in
terms of man I left the uh the UFC
because they took my Reebok deal
Reebok was sponsoring me originally
you're in there it was my deal oh wow
and then Daniel Dana White was like uh
we don't got to deal with with Reebok
like you know you don't got to deal with
none of the other sponsors that I'll be
having on me either yeah and they they
certainly then I said [ __ ] you [ __ ] I
was making I was making probably close
to 80 to 85 000 a fight in sponsors yeah
they took it yeah how much does it [ __ ]
you up well everyone always want to wear
something like Jon Jones if you're a
fighter and you're taking that much time
off yeah does that [ __ ] with your head
he's doing it to build his body that's
what he says but then he's also doing it
because he wants his pay to fight the
biggest heavyweight fight of all time
I'm gonna tell you something about Jon
Jones What I noticed about him and I
noticed it too late I thought for him
his mind it's his mind his mind is is
really strong when I when I followed Jon
Jones I I honestly underestimated him
because I was in really good shape and I
wasn't I didn't have any injuries a
little knee injury that wasn't that bad
back then but I've I've never lost a
fight in that good of a shape I was in
Colorado training and I was training her
for a couple of months my cardio was
meant I was in I was in the probably
like one of the best shapes I ever been
and I've just like there's no way I'm
losing to this kid but his mind is so
strong hold on what do you mean by that
what do you mean like what do you mean
by it he has no weakness like like no
matter how the fight's going yeah he did
he didn't falter there's no quit effort
yeah forever and like he's so strong
mentally like when he fought Ryan Bader
or Augustine he barely trained like
Gusman it was a five round War like War
he barely trained for that fight like
but he goes in the fight believing that
he's the best in the world but here's
the thing like you I want you I want
people to remember this is when he
fought jail
he got through that round with his
[ __ ] foot his toe wrist his bone was
sticking out of the front they actually
panned down they actually had to to stop
it they tried to cut it yeah they're
trying to click like clip away from it
they didn't realize his toe was facing
this way and the bone was sticking out
straight he looked down he didn't even
realize until after the round and then
he looked dead he's like he almost
passed out you could tell he was sick to
his stomach by looking at his [ __ ]
home he's so focused but he was so
focused on beating chill he got through
the front of the rest of the round
finished him some people believe in in
the power of the mind like being
mentally strong some people believe in
it and if you if you tell yourself
something that you really believe in it
and you have no doubt you can do it and
that's how Jon Jones is his mind is
really strong like I don't think John
like I mean he's good at everything but
he's not like great at everything it's
his mentality but he's hey he's he's
like the dirtiest fighter he's the
dirtiest fighter someone told me that no
no no but I haven't seen it honestly
they had to change their fingers they
had to change the rules because of him
when I follow him whenever I was
whenever I was like have any type of
Advantage he'll he'll he'll put his
fingers in my eye let me do this right
how uncomfortable is this right here
your eyeball is your weakest thing on
your body right so when I was fighting
guys enough he was like this the whole
time it's hard to train for this too
he said that he poked me then and then
and then when you come in and Advance he
kick your knee backwards hey you know
you know they should be good they should
make that illegal I saw this guy I was
talking to a real nice guy the fight
breaks out he goes try to break it up
tall kind of thin black guy I guess he's
a singer and uh [ __ ] he walks over
these two big dudes are fighting
[ __ ] you and then he goes you got
he goes you guys should calm down
because they're neighbors and the guy
goes man [ __ ] you and comes at him and
the guy I didn't even see he just goes
like this he goes
lazy with with pepper spray
like that the guy goes
no matter how tough you are you just go
what he crawls he gets on the hand and
he crawls from the street to the
sidewalk finds a doorway and just he's
over there and then this girl goes what
the [ __ ] you son of a [ __ ] and comes at
him like that and he goes
I'll come over and I'm like I'm like oh
no I'm afraid I'm like maybe he's gonna
get me but I was just talking to myself
what are you doing what's what's
happening he goes he goes that's fine
hey wash your eyes out with milk
walked off he walked off he got in his
car a little car a little white car
shitty car and some other people got in
the car he goes get in the car and I go
the cops he goes I know all the cops I
go okay and he just pulls out casually
Putters out just goes
now I go does anybody have any water I'm
helping the girl I don't know what to do
with that so I'm pouring water in her
eyes which apparently you're not
supposed to get the Milky water spread
he's drunk as [ __ ] I'm trying to help
her and I I'm trying to calm her down
and I'm going uh Taryn was there from
pteran tactical so Terence gave me his
milk so I go at the water so I go you're
gonna be fine I go this has happened to
me twice
I go yeah you're gonna be fine you know
it feels like you're gonna die but
you're not it's not a big deal it'll go
away soon as you're spreading it in her
[ __ ] eyes yeah yeah and meanwhile I
get it in my [ __ ] eyes
I don't realize I'm doing this [ __ ] Bro
[ __ ] the whole thing was bad then I go
take a piss
[Applause]
you know when your parents tell you like
don't touch your sister don't touch your
brother and like I used to do this [ __ ]
oh my God he's talking about the Jon
Jones [ __ ] right yeah to your point eyes
are the most I don't give a [ __ ] how
tall is the nuts right
yeah and neck eyes nuts but mainly eyes
right eyes are terrible yeah you smell
like a piece of dust and you're like God
damn game over there
one one of these just go shut up
and kicks you in the knee yeah yeah
every time I every time I got any type
of advantage that I that handles and he
poked me and I he poked me an eye once
or twice in the fight in training camp
when my last Barn I already had the like
you know the little red blood vessel
because somebody Pokemon iron training
camp because we were trying to train for
that [ __ ] and if you can't train for it
no you can't train for so I read my eyes
I was already [ __ ] up yeah yeah so it
was really it was really hard fighting
him so if anybody get any advantage on
him he's going to kick your knee
backwards he's going to figure it out
yeah they should make that illegal yeah
that's stupid that's so stupid yeah yeah
I think it's dealing with you really
right yeah yeah yeah it's been everyone
caught him
that can end people's career and you
know there's just no need for foreign
just one like that yeah he does that
that's a Muay Thai thing I think they do
that a lot he like they get away with it
by saying it's like a a
what do they call it trying to say front
kicks
and they're trying to push your leg but
it's actually your knee yeah
I've always thought you should that's
that I don't like that it should be
illegal it should be illegal but well
because the same thing like you got to
protect the product so like in the NFL
they made illegal to hit quarterbacks
below the knees the Tom Brady rule yeah
so it should be illegal to probably get
a whole bunch of rules though the tuck
rules
that's it so that that you but it's not
going to end your career from a calf
kick that yeah
but what about kicking to the knee to
the side I mean but it's still different
yeah yeah
you can't see your foot that's a whole
different so you'd make that illegal 100
yeah
they're also not fun to watch what did
Big John McCarthy say about uh ning to
the head when somebody's down it's just
it just never happens I like that rude
that's right I love that I wish they had
practice yeah especially a lot of dagger
stands coming over
because they're controlling those again
the fights become the kidney again
decision you you said that with a diet
standings I agree with you 100 they'll
finish more fights but the other thing
though as well is that when they start
to get tired because some of them do get
tired not all of them are khabibs is it
when they do shots and they can't get
the takedown they can be finished too
it's not the other thing because they're
the ones shooting so much so when you
start stuffing their takedowns you start
needing them on the head they all of a
sudden become Gar poolers so now that
changes the game in terms of like they
don't get the takedown you're [ __ ]
them up and also if you were allowed to
knead of the head you would start people
would adjust it would change yeah
fighting but you'd adjust you'd figure
out that'd be great I think it'd be
great but then uh Big John I forget what
she shot it down he's just saying how
hard it is get rules changed yeah I mean
like think about it they're still in
this whole this whole 12-6 uh Big John
he made
with that much power you can break
somebody's face those are illegal yeah
but the bottom line is though is that
it's the same [ __ ] thing when you're
laying on the ground
it's only 12 to six
yeah yeah yeah disqualified you can't
throw it a down opponent like although
although who did that
Brown Jon Jones dude behind the ear but
he drives around with it like this I'm
seeing somebody get knocked out like
that oh with Josh Barnett right
Gonzaga did another Edition
I I don't like Travis Brown at all why I
wanted to go up the Headway just to
fight his big ass I probably would have
lost it so so bigger than me but I
wanted you like that because I had a dog
I had a Cane Corso that I got from from
one of my good friends I love it and um
and Travis Brown uh Hans molecap told me
I got some I can train your dog and gave
him Travis Brown Travis Brown kept my
dog for like six to eight months and she
came back dumber than when she left
yeah that's disrespectful and I paid him
he never reimbursed me I'm like man give
me get my money back or something my dog
is dumb as [ __ ] damn for six months and
that dog cost me so much money I got a
Cane Corso expansion
no she passed away uh two Easters ago
she she just destroyed my backyard you
know what I'm saying she kept she she
kept like destroying stuff and maybe
maybe he tried and the dog's just a
dumbass maybe I don't know maybe maybe
he could have talked to me or whatever
but maybe maybe maybe maybe he did well
the big boys
fights what's good he's done already
he's done that's what they want was it
how long are these rounds come on get
out three minutes three minutes wow all
right one minute are you stood up at
nine that boy he was doing all right
40 seconds ago he was good is that what
she tells you you're doing all right he
doesn't belong in there oh yeah
he's fighting back he looks fearful oh
[ __ ] he should be trying to hug but this
black guy from England yeah he's a huge
favorite
come on just
oh my God man
Italian yeah it must be Italian it looks
like it's time
he's like give me my check I'm literally
just trying to see this Jake Paul like
check please
uh what's the record yeah if you get
knocked down three times you're done
I think so I can't hear it right now he
doesn't
oh
there we go all right there we go one
more fight into another huge mismatch
that's like Bradley and Dylan Dallas
right there right get him Bradley get
them get them baby
zero chance
especially because think about the Jake
Paul crowd they're like it's broken or
something this one knocked they like
they're just they're just foam at the
dick for Jake Paul yeah you know what
I'm saying without it well they don't
even have all those fights then like I
don't know I'd be fine with no undercard
right but then it's showtime right the
real production like so there's the
women are fighting now yes okay yeah
they're good though yeah absolute models
monster dude she's [ __ ] amazing you
said model but the model is kind of
she's actually about looking there she's
not she's cute she's cute can you pull
up her Instagram she's cute just for
research purposes someone just want to
see what's going on and she's like what
17 time world Champs I'm sure like she
trains over so like they have like with
Biz being Perillo that whole group she's
over there every once in a while
she's cute it's cute she's a stud
y oh yeah
she's from Puerto Rico I'm at it
okay
yeah Jake was the one fighting for the
fighter pay on that right
which is dope for what for her yeah for
everyone everyone in the car now we want
to make sure she got paid in everybody
on the card but especially her [ __ ] I
train with a girl who was she was
smaller smaller Karina Moreno she was
the 104 champ 108 112 in boxing and like
the most she ever made was like 25 Grand
she's a five she's a WC WBO World Champ
five four or five time World Champ
what's her name Karina Moreno Karina
yeah like no money felt so bad it's like
it's like nobody's gonna watch it's like
how many seats are you selling yeah
socks damn but that's like that Christy
Mack shoe saying I didn't make money so
I thought on the Tyson card everybody
knew my name then after I was making
real money because before that though I
was fighting for free Yeah well yeah
it's like stand up is stand up any
different same thing if you can't put
butts in the seats you're not making any
money and there's some great Comics who
can't put butts in the seat but if
you're a club owner what are you gonna
do you're gonna bring the guys it's
expensive yeah they're like dude we love
you you're great comic yeah you can't
make money off of you and it never
cancel stay relevant too you got to keep
doing your [ __ ]
chat boom I'm just I'm just letting the
chat know that I'm here
that guy was clearly not in the same
league I hate when they do that
heavyweight annoys me
the big boy
I'm gonna piss hold the four don't be
good buddy I got you oh yeah want me to
secure your hips are you okay also chat
talk to me what's good you're gonna be
all right talk to me I'm reading the
chat I know they want this what is it
I'm reading the chat what's this chat
about the man Dragon no no no no they
want the man Dragon at the end but but
right now I'm reading the chat and I'm
gonna make sure we're talking to the
chat so chat talk to me what's going on
hey test Rampage no no I'm not testing
that's not a good idea not a good idea
just do what's good for your health no I
don't know what's good for
I don't think they're talking about math
um
they loved your stories though by the
way oh thank you yeah they love your
stories Rampages
um right now uh yeah I I got um I was
supposed to be doing a movie and uh
when is it maybe October uh have you
taken any acting classes or you just I
had I had an acting coach and stuff
before yeah oh thank you man for real
Chad going crazy you're you're one of
those guys it's interesting some people
can just stay relevant
and I feel like you're one of those
people that would have been successful
at whatever you did you figure your [ __ ]
out but that's my that's my that's my
problem that I don't I don't really care
about being relevant and stuff like that
it's like it's like my things right you
know it's just uh yeah yeah it's like I
love I love fighting yeah but I'm gonna
be honest some people get mad at me when
I say it but I have to keep it real if I
you know when I when I first started
fighting it wasn't popular right right
and and uh if I had known that I had to
take pictures every time I go somewhere
never would have done that is
a fighter I'll be a construction worker
my family owned construction companies
back in my hometown I'll be there within
Memphis in Memphis doing construction
all right most likely or but I wanted to
be a pro wrestler but you know I I guess
I didn't think about the picture taking
part but I probably would have been a
progressor with a mask on though like
you just don't like that I never liked
taking pictures because it's like I I
never I just never liked the pictures
I'm one of the people that don't like
pictures yeah and you know I grew up
with ugly duckling you know my fan I was
so ugly my family called me ugly my mama
everybody I remember one of my one of my
most memorable moments about my auntie
is she's always called me ugly right and
I said no I'm pretty she's like yeah
pretty ugly
that's my that's my that's my
grandmother's sister
no no no no I was ugly as [ __ ]
scarred though yeah yeah no matter what
people say I'm less ugly I'm less ugly
than that job has body dysmorphia he
still thinks he's a fatty fatty pants
because because he yeah
it stays with when you when you the [ __ ]
happens to you when a kid it stays with
you right I had scars all over my body
I've been hit by cars a lot and uh I got
the older sisters scratch me up and [ __ ]
and my nose was was it didn't grow into
my face it was real big I got a big gap
and can you not got scars all over my
face big ass nose big ass Gap I got
scars all over my body and [ __ ] and were
you always athletic though yeah always
tough always tough my friend thought I
was gonna be big like Shaquille O'Neal
because I was just like a big kid how
much you weigh
right now current ain't nobody [ __ ]
I'm 260.
when you were fighting what was your
weight I used to fight it um 205 and
then heavyweight 205 man that's yeah
that's your frame though that's when
you're shredded yeah they're two or five
yeah wait is that is that you right
there yeah that's me that's you right
there that's me at 17. damn is that when
you were a shitty High School wrestler
yeah
I want to see that in high school but I
was undefeated I was undefeated yeah
that's not shitty my brother brought me
the chain when my brother my little
brother gave me the chain and after I
saw I won a chain I went undefeated
until until Regional finals I had a
wrestler's guide I beat twice and he was
a senior nobody no one knew who I was
because before I was the cameraman
nobody knew who the [ __ ] I was and they
they cheated me and let him win damn how
did they cheat you they let this time
stall out they didn't give me points
they didn't give me takedowns they gave
him points for stuff do you still go
back to Memphis really
really oh you're crazy
stronger than you
he's strong I don't know I saw you
curling like 100 I'm stronger than him
you are yes in the gym and what stuff in
anything
look you want to fight Dylan danis no no
I'm not talking about fighting this [ __ ]
I'm talking about I'm talking about in
the gym lifts I'm not talking about
who's your max [ __ ]
475 500 that's more than me oh 425. what
was your dad
bro I mean I could probably do 750 right
now oh Jesus Christ
that's crazy strong
the goddamn gym I I work out 750. yeah
[ __ ] you've been living away since
elementary I haven't well yeah since I
was 15. no he's stupid strong [ __ ]
because some guys are body Builders
aren't necessarily that's what I'm
saying you're talking about me fighting
this [ __ ] Dylan Dennis kid and I talk
[ __ ] to him on the internet he never
pulled up to my gym I I bet you're gonna
hear from him now cool I mean he jumps
in my life all the time and talks [ __ ] I
said come here's my address
you cannot fight down downstairs if he
grabs you it's going to be bad you want
me to FaceTime right now
and he's really
classic yeah you'll get caught in some
[ __ ] I promise I promise you you're
gonna get choked out I I promise you in
a street fight I'm not talking about
doing Jiu Jitsu against this guy do you
know Jujitsu I mean I've done a little
bit I don't know it like he knows it
obviously he says it's 170 right here
yeah but he walks around 185 so it's not
perfect it's not fair because he don't
do
we all know though when you when you
were a black belt I don't care what
black belt you are when you start
getting [ __ ] punched in the face you
become a white belt real fast this is
all I'm saying I'm not he's made his
career off of [ __ ] proving black
belts and white belts real quick
is that you is you wrestling at the UFC
Institute on your uh IG yeah bring that
up chin
critique is uh honestly yeah IG all
right yeah
no no I didn't wrestle nice but at least
[ __ ] athletic no I'm sure you're
athletic but you know what I'm saying I
want to wrestle you and see if I'm
stronger than you because yeah I love
you because you're strongly living ways
I can't live ways strong [ __ ]
oh look Bradley's got it you got a great
body when you're athletic as [ __ ] but I
mean you look very good but I don't
think I don't scroll down I just think I
just think that this is a different
thing oh that when I'm wrestling Steve
you mean Steve is two tooth go up what's
up it's right there on the right Bradley
if you go just just
15 to 20 here
this guy let's not cut your hair like
that are they good yeah okay who is
Steve what does he do it's my buddy
Steve Steve will do it they all know
Steve will do Steve's a regular guy
right yeah
I don't know
but I'm not wrestling the guy I wouldn't
be wrestling the guy you act like I
would just try to wrestle him but now
you're going to try to stand no Steve
get out of there Steve Steve get out of
there man
nice side choke now watch this
watch this oh
yo
he [ __ ] himself
we're just having fun yeah
you think you can tap Joe Rogan tap Joe
Rogan I don't know I I don't think so no
I don't think so
talking about me tap him out no no I'm
not talking about rolling you never like
you were like the Anthony damn yeah I I
never I never um I never loved Jujitsu I
didn't love it I didn't like it I I you
just didn't like gravitate towards it I
didn't I didn't like it because I'm
low-key a germ freak and he rode around
with sweaty ass dudes I bet dude sweat
my mouth and [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] that I
stopped liking I'd ramp it I had Rashad
Rose be a dick on my face before you
were a cop I was like bro what are you
doing yeah it happens I used to train
with Tito and he's always one of those
those shorts with the flames on it yeah
you don't wear underwear bro and he got
a long scrotum and one time
it tea bagged me bro and I was like done
the most erotic thing ever happened he
was Rashad you he was a spandex yeah man
you have a cup on I don't want to say
anything you know let's roll it yeah no
doubt and then he went to you know like
that north south which he already kind
of went and it just did you did you tap
out from there or did you yarn she's
and she could box yeah she's a baddie
so Dylan wants to fight you you're
saying he just talked he wants to five
years
but his thing Bradley wants a fight he
like he's asked me like he wants me to
find him a fight oh you want to fight I
want an MMA fight though I don't want a
box
hey why don't we do why don't we do this
thing with you what we can do it for the
we can do it for like a podcast we do it
for a show so My Buddy Rich ciao he does
this whole whims to Warrior they train
you they come in they put you in a gym
they train you for six to eight weeks
and they schedule you a fight and they
make it like a charity event it's a big
deal let me can I go ahead all right I'm
sorry here's the problem so from wimps
to Warriors I don't know who they've had
on there okay the issue is Bradley is
very successful in his space yeah you
want someone of equal clout which is
very hard to find
no no
no don't be under over here I'll be
trying to do this to me right now for
real not right now obviously but at some
point I would I want I want I've asked a
long time I'll do it all right come down
yeah come down Tony McKees yeah who else
who else Brendan finds you and actually
I think Brendan is being tight-lived
right now but I think Brandon would
steer you away from Dylan Dennis busy
here but but I think I think you can
find him another YouTube 100 you can
find somebody he's being a little bit
serious and you're making me mad right
now you're being I can see it but
Bradley is athletic and stronger than me
hey you heard his numbers Hey listen
bring you the money hey look at me over
here I know that and I see your I see
what you're doing and I can because I
always know you always know what
Brandon's [ __ ] around because he'll
start doing this yeah
it'll be fun
but Brendan knows he's like just the
[ __ ] around and you do too hey and
you're a [ __ ] bad guy and you're a
bad I am a bad guy I am a bad guy
because you're both bad guys because
you're like this yeah
the thing is is he like he won't like
just [ __ ] around like he'll train sure
he will I'm sure he will and I like this
guy and he's not a he's a he's got a gym
he's a good guy he has DJ and I I'm I'm
a little protective over you frankly I
appreciate it I happen to I I I don't
want to see you do something silly
because it's a it's a language you're
not you don't he's very fluent in that
language and you will make a mistake
like give him your ankle and then you're
not tap it until for about nine months
on your knee that's what Dylan dance can
do to you I promise yeah and then your
legs go from being able to squat 700 or
something to like all of a sudden yeah
worth it something bad will happen
Bradley Bradley numbers though man yeah
Bradley just smash him bro smash him
look at me I'm your friend they're not
Bradley
yeah just smash him bro just [ __ ]
shop over here
you'll be all right bro you know what
Fighters with spiders when a civilian
says I want to fight that guy fighters
go like this they go good
see what happens because they know but
like I understand that you're a big
strong guy so you're confident
it's like a D1 lacrosse player says I
want to fight that guy who can who can
and then he
it's just different it's a different
language right different sport different
sport you're very very strong because
that's your badly go ahead
I went to I had lunch with this uh when
my son's uh friend's dad we like all
went to lunch he's this dude from
Houston he's like Houston Houston dude
he's this black dude and we're talking
about fighting some and he's like you
like you tell me right now you you could
have beat up Kimbo Slice
what he's like like I've been street
fights man he's like if you mean he's a
bigger dude he's like if you may get a
fight man and I like do a right hand
you're telling me I'm like you don't
think I've seen the right hand before he
said I know but it's like I'm pretty
fast so if I like police I'm like yeah
but you don't think I've seen a loopy
right now before bro yeah he's like damn
that's crazy I'm like it's not though
man the best it's just like the best is
I I'm I'm I took boxing seriously for
what two maybe three years two maybe
three weeks world champion completely in
the Olympics 40 48 years old and Wayne
is they call him the pocket rocket five
seven five six Legends but Wayne because
he I'm paying Wayne and he loves me I
love Wayne Wayne would he did an
interview I would box he put me in there
and I'd do my thing and then we would
move around a little bit and then one
day he said on a radio show in Ireland
Brian can fight he can fight I put him
in there with anyone
and I went uh yeah you did his voice
dude I went really and he goes I put you
in there with anyone and I was like oh
so then one day Wayne and I decided to
do a little boxing and Wayne just puts
his mouthpiece in and I start going I
start using my jab because I'm I feel
like
bop bop and all of a sudden Wayne goes
he's he's a fighter so I started hitting
him and he goes he turned it up a little
bit turn it up a little bit yeah and
he's he's a here on me and he turned my
[ __ ] head around he turned my head
went this is three years of me really
work my head went out like that and then
he hit me in the body and I went and we
stopped and I went he goes you all right
I go well hey wait a minute hold on wait
a minute could you knock me on the first
round and he goes and all he did was
poke me here he goes I'll get you there
and yeah but you didn't learn your
lesson because remember you're paying
your tennis trainer and you're like I'm
actually pretty good dude like you're
paying the guy though he goes yeah
you're not doing it tennis too well both
there yeah no here a little for me I'm
pretty bad at times I'm ready for the
championship yeah you ready and I'm I'm
the biggest violator of that that's why
Bradley when I hear you like I work at
it and I and I but let's take Dylan
Dennis out of it like say it's another
YouTuber who doesn't have fight
experience Brad's gonna [ __ ] him up
that's why this is hard to figure out
because he's a big strong guy
this is what I was talking about though
he signed up to fight Bradley right but
this is what I was talking about with
Bobby this is this is the issue that I
have a little bit tonight with t wood
and Jake Paul is that you're saying
you're training with who's this guy
so you're training with him like I said
I was sparring with uh Robert the ghost
Carrera like he he like in any he he's
he's he's 147. I was walking I was
probably about 175. he's just like it
doesn't matter when they want to turn it
up they turn it up and I'm fresh for
first four rounds I'm training for 25
minute fight coming up I'm in the best
shape of my life probably one of the
best for sure he's just getting warmed
up yeah
he did another [ __ ] eight rounds with
two other guys that were world champions
in different weight classes yeah and I'm
like yeah he's he's [ __ ] piecing me
up put me on a stanky leg in the fourth
round kind of ramping it up like hit me
to the body boom this is you boxing this
is me boxing only and that's my point my
point is they're like look Jake Paul's
no no no no no no Robert Guerrero but
I'm saying like but guys that just focus
strictly on boxing for a certain
duration you can't do it in 10 weeks
which is what would there's not enough
hours there's not enough time see I
don't I don't want to hear that because
my next fight is going to be a box of
math yeah
different though wait you're gonna take
that I'm going to take it I always
wanted the box but that's a heavyweight
fight though that's not angles that I
mean there is it's not the movement it's
not the output but the only thing is is
Rampage your career was based off
stand-up yeah you know yeah it's a
little different for you that makes more
sense yeah and you've been fighting for
a long time 20 years but does it does it
like that's the thing I know you're
right it doesn't matter I thought for a
long time too but when you get in there
with guys that have been doing it like
Robert's been fighting since he was
[ __ ] like five yeah that kid yeah the
one thing they I noticed that they're
just like just like with Jiu Jitsu
they're ahead of you so we've seen it
all they've seen it they're [ __ ] set
up things they're like a mile ahead of
you it's not even close now this is what
it is what you guys don't understand you
heard what he said he's been doing since
he was five so
they're Master at it correct when you
start doing something young you're a
mess like my oldest my oldest brother he
started driving when he was three years
old and and my mom told me yeah wait
what no wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait no no no what's going on
a lawnmower three years old three years
old no yeah
is your brother Lewis Hamilton I think
it was five maybe five no my dad my dad
my dad told him I drive you know sitting
in his lap yeah so so my dad did the
pedals yeah but my brother was driving
my brother's in full control but but
when my brother was five my mom had like
one of those little one was a little bit
at uh Pontiac those little hatchbacks
I don't remember what it was but but my
mom told me she just let him go to the
store and buy her cigarettes it's the
South yeah we knew the owners of the
store okay you just write a note yeah
yeah my mom said she wants me like hey
give me something you drive up to the
store get get the [ __ ] cigarettes
come back and my brother is a really
good
he could drive anything because I'll
tell you my family does construction oh
yeah you drive all different type of
trucks all different type of Machinery
yeah he's getting it he's a master he's
a master and like AJ McKee I've seen
that kid I've seen a kid in the gym I'm
gonna tell you I'm gonna tell you
something that kid since he's three
years I was training with his dad stuff
right I seen the kid do stuff in the gym
like I hope he doing in the fight he
does more to come back [ __ ] in the gym
oh he's such a badass I just hit him
does like crazy foot sweeps and [ __ ]
like that and like I mean haven't you
rolled with guys like Crown Grace here
guys like that who are so far ahead of
you they just have to yeah so I'll tell
you guys a story about BJ Penn so so I
was training with friends so I came down
I had I had like probably about 10
fights before before I came and trained
down in San Jose with Frank Shamrock so
I trained with Frank Shamrock and
BJ just came into the into the scene
when he started training AKA so it was
like 99 2000 so BJ comes in he's
trending AK he's getting ready for his
UFC fight he's the first American to
ever win uh worlds which is down in
Brazil he's the first guy to ever win
world as an American so he wins it
and he comes in everyone they keep
telling me how good he is how good he is
I'm like I think I couldn't train in the
afternoon with all the fighters trained
because I had a job I was poor and so I
was [ __ ] training at night just like
from basically 4 30 to 5 30 until like
[ __ ] nine nine ten o'clock at night
train as much as I could and so then
they they kept telling me he's this good
he's this good he came in I was like
there's no way this guy ain't that
[ __ ] good I'm you know I'm tapping
all the Frank's guys I'm running the
show kind of thing it's me Bob cooking
Frank
he [ __ ] comes in BJ [ __ ] worked me
over I would say six six seven minutes
tap me prom six seven times
it was like that no it got to the point
where they brought him in specifically
just to Grapple With Me Josh don't do
anything until you guys already grapples
don't do any rounds don't train with
anybody else just you and BJ wow it was
it was embarrassing it was embarrassing
when I saw you with Hannah
holding this like I've seen him I've
seen him personally tap Big Time
world-class Jiu Jitsu guys and Fighters
nobody talks about it but I've seen him
do it with heavyweights Big Time guys
right so look he's a beast I'm not
trying to stroke his Eagle the first
time we grappled it was in Hawaii yeah
BJ pens uh the gym yeah Anthony Pettis
and Mark Munoz so we were there I was
like I started falling like man I'm
gonna pass this guy's guard he's gonna
throw me around muscle neither this dude
has some technique and honestly I gave
you a lot of problems when we did Big
Brown breakdown I was like yo he's very
he's good his ground is good especially
off the back too because he was like he
could have gone on top of me and just
smashed me he's like now he played the
guard game but he was [ __ ] working
again
yeah he he flowed real well and I was I
was thankful because but I watched
Henner I watched Henner just wrap you up
and he and Leota Machida back to back
remember and I was like and I was like
this I see Hannah just wrap these guys
up like it was yeah and I remember I was
like this girl my mouth was open I was
like yeah how did they do because he
started on his back yeah he started on
top of him and and he turned and I was
like and Brennan goes oh you've never
seen oh yeah Sarah's been doing it since
he was literally two yeah how many
diapers do you have 14 in Jiu Jitsu no
[ __ ] so he was doing Jiu-Jitsu when he
was on Ultimate Fighter show yeah he was
like weren't you a football player first
yeah in the NFL yeah uh I had like a
cappuccino of the Buffalo Bills
he was there for a minute he was there
for a minute yeah
I talked to Pro guys who played in the
pros and said the only reason you
weren't in the pros is you weren't seen
by the right guys though it was tough
tough gig
thanks it's a [ __ ] situation right yeah
like it really comes down to like if
someone picks you up and they see
something new the your your whole career
could be amazed but then it was weird
because when you're not drafted you
don't have like anyone that like there's
no stock in you yeah so the guys who
were drafted because I was on uh
undrafted free agent so like the guys
who were drafted would get like 40
opportunities in practice and I got one
yeah so it's like you have the one shot
to do something then they don't throw
the ball it's like all right because
it's because you never met the casting
couch there you go that's what it was
I don't play that game you got to get on
that well Harvey Weinstein yeah
on that couch whatever that couch was
that was a tough gig man now is this
fight I mean does anybody know about
this she's good she's the biggest
favorite on the card okay she's a
monster yeah hopefully it doesn't go
long let's be honest how many rounds is
it is the Jake Paul
yes but this is this is uh this is a
real fight though yeah
though
two minute rounds oh no for this one
yeah it's only two minute round hey you
so if there's two girls fighting should
they have ring men I agree is that a
ring girls I think so your audition for
the job dude I would love to be I would
you'd be so good would you do it I shave
down tan up you can see that get my hair
done yeah I can see it I agree I'm
agreeing with you I couldn't see it all
right would you do it with me no I
wouldn't know why Serrano installed as a
minus two thousand okay yes they got
that yeah I wouldn't do it bro there's
other girls are minus two thousands
I wear hot pants I look pretty good in
football those what are those shorts
don't say FUBU though tight little
shorts why you can't say that well I'm
just saying that they're not FUBU shows
no what are those little those little
Zoom guns yeah I look I look all right I
got I got an apple bottom on me I got a
piece on me I do all right what kind of
sauce are you talking about yeah Brian
got some balls on him I'm looking a lot
of you guys so you you have you have the
Tito Ortiz ball sack
the big scrotum for 20 years
yo weird man first day I'm taking a pee
first day I'm taking a pee like this I
grew up in locker room
oh look at him like that and he goes
just checking out what you're working
with
friends ever since
yeah
bro
like my best friend in college with my
best friends Lawrence Vickers he was a
All-Pro in the NFL captain of our team
bad [ __ ] from Fifth Ward Houston
just a real like hood dude who's this
who's this Lawrence Vickers he's my best
friend one of my best friends in college
and I just I just couldn't get over it
like I If you had to bring attention to
it like you're in luck room he took his
pants off you know we're about to take a
shower and his his dick was this
microphone I was just like bro like put
that [ __ ] up
I found it hilarious because after that
I know it's funny because after the
fight he would act like it was a mic
he'd be like the thing is Brian
he's talking in his own yeah I wouldn't
want my [ __ ] that caused my own face it
was so big he'd be like listen about the
game he's like talk serious and we would
laugh
anyway I have a question if it's that
big did you ever ask him did you try to
suck it yeah why is it that big
disaster super stuck damn such a good
leader man he was a captain of the dude
the way he talks that then that one
[ __ ] clip about oh he's like
chocolate make you my [ __ ] remember
that he's such a bad [ __ ]
oh my God
so how much boxing man is it you just
know you just can't do [ __ ] why do they
put us by the Mexicans no that girl's a
stud Brian that other girl it's a real
fight it's a real fight yeah that's a
real fight she's 10 years younger though
yeah she's a stud I don't know
I don't know wow no this is this is
super high level female boxing B yeah no
okay you think they've been boxing since
they were kids too yeah both of them uh
I would I would imagine that girl's from
Mexico Serratos are like the best she's
a mom she looks amazing
that's the difference between boxing and
MMA a lot of boxes have been fighting
since they were kids yes
man you can see it
I think now like kids who are born like
five years ago they're gonna be MMA and
have like fights yeah yeah yeah that's
what it's going to be like that's what's
going to be like yeah because no like no
kid grows up like especially now like
one in the box like UFC so mainstream
right yeah right yeah it's gonna be
crazy actually like a whole breed in 10
years 10 20 years is gonna be like the
kids are gonna be good at everything
yeah I want to have another kid now just
just for that put them in some fight in
the train I always went from dude my
thing is I I follow like certain boxing
trainers like Tony Yanko boxing Mustafa
boxing coach Anthony I love watches I do
because I watch them like teach kids the
way they teach the way like the details
those high level trainers on footwork
and oh I [ __ ] I geek out on that kind
of [ __ ] I love boxing that way
because I have a bunch of kids and says
dropping off Antonio McKee's gym
but here's my question to you would you
want your kids to be a fighter
only if they want to be I think my
daughter I think my daughter could be a
fighter but she's super tough she's a
basketball player she's really good at
basketball she loves it it'd just be a
lot of pressure on your kid Rampage
because you're their dad it's like it's
like Michael Jordan's kid when they're
playing basketball like dude rap or
something dude my 21 year old son I
don't think he feels the pressure I see
he he hasn't had any fights he had two
gym fights he had like a uh one gym MMA
fight smoker oh well yeah he had one
smoker but one kid uh one kid challenged
him the kid dad said oh
um my kid can my kid could beat
rampage's kid and my son was sick he had
the flu or something and they went they
told him he he he he was standing at
Tony McKee's house he they said he came
to the gym beat the kid up went back
home
and then he had to smoke a boxing match
at uh sick dog I don't know if y'all
remember him uh Ramirez and he he won he
looked like he was moving his head like
a box is just natural damn he just he
just got it and he said he don't feel it
like you were uh he he he walks around
he walks around like 205. you know what
my thing was with that Rampage is like I
don't know how you grew up did you grow
up with money or no no no no so you know
what I'm saying so those kids like you
you've done pretty well for yourself so
it's like my kids growing up with her
grown up bro fighting it doesn't come
from those yeah you know like you know
the famous Samuel sleeping yeah but my
kids took cheats and then because yeah
but you know I never I never really
treated my kids and stuff like that but
they did grow up in Orange County but I
never you know I I kind of didn't want
to make [ __ ] too easy on them but my
youngest is not to because yeah
my younger kids are totally different
their mom's Japanese so they're they're
totally different tight ship she's like
the worst tiger mom I ever [ __ ] met
oh he's the worst like how so
my if my son is he's really smart he's
normally makes Straight A's and he's in
honors and stuff if he make a B on a on
a on a not even a test like an
assignment or something oh he's it's
like the end of the [ __ ] world he's
in trouble he can't play video games
so so it got to be eight if his a is a
if it's a minus then he's in trouble
again by the way Korean Japanese
yeah I don't know yeah I don't know if
that's good right that's not that's not
that's not good but but he has both
because he has her and then I pray I've
been through the cool day yeah I'm not I
don't know super cool that's how I am
the question is this discipline like
that is really good and it'll get you
into Harvard but does it make you a
creative being creative is a different
story because a lot of times some very
successful people struggled in school oh
yeah I was terrible
issues in school and then yet you know I
noticed it turned him into a liar
because she's so strict so he lied he
lies he lies about it yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
yeah my mother forged my report card so
my dad didn't have a bad day did you
guys all go to school graduate college
I didn't graduate college I went to
school yeah yeah I went to yeah I went
to college but I didn't finish would you
go uh so I was at North Idaho College
Russell there and then I got down there
I just came down here for college and
didn't finish up
I got injured in college and they just
threw me away yeah I mean colleges yeah
they're ruthless man ruthless it's such
a business registered where'd you go I
went to a junior college up in Northern
California lasting yeah last is good
good wrestling school wrestling we
wrestled you guys every year yeah it was
a good school I was getting good no I
was born and raised in San Jose
then my parents got divorced wow
he changed the game I've never seen that
in my life
that's your phone yeah
it's here put anything you want on your
phone and it'll do that unless Woodley
hits it with a body shot that [ __ ]
blows up you came to my show in Houston
like when I worked the the Logan Paul
Floyd Mayweather fight uh Logan's entire
team was all pro MMA fighters yeah and
so I was making a joke I'm like would
you beat up Floyd Mayweather's fat ass
bouncers I was like they're bigger but
you guys have skill so it was like this
whole debate interesting
I said I had you guys minus seven
thousand yeah they're like really I'm
like yeah this is big dude that don't
mean anything what was about to put on
fights like that bodyguards versus
bodyguards this is like the old UFC [ __ ]
oh that'd be dope that'd be dope
I'm starting my own MMA league in Mexico
are you ready I'm getting it all set up
right now it's gonna be it's going to be
told it's Rampage style totally
different some [ __ ] I ain't never seen
before really and I want to do it in
Mexico because I want to I like I like
the pride energy you know what I'm
saying it's my favorite yeah yeah like
it was like a performance it was like it
was like yeah everyone was like the
Super Bowl like it felt special everyone
felt like it was like a real special
like spectacular yeah it's a fight man
you and I should do that [ __ ] yeah she's
tough girls no joke man she's giving it
she just stands there and comes right
back yeah they're [ __ ] she swerves
she just takes it and then boom
she's a bull
what would you smash her then
you smash which one would you think for
me which one this one the one in the
black uh I like the black I like the one
in white the one in white you would yes
you smashed she's such a good fighter
too Brown be very attractive very
attractive I'm attracted to fighter
girls he likes any woman that can beat
him up those are hot and I think uh
Fitness girls are I like and Tommy fear
oh Fitness girl I like that yeah I like
Fitness girls too yeah
come on down the zoo some MMA girls man
come on it is I just I just I just
admire it and I I just think it's yes I
want to fit [ __ ] a chick so I can stay
in shape because I didn't know they know
how to cook and make you eat yeah yeah
like they're never gonna have like
Cinnabon around yeah yeah sometimes big
girls and maybe eating all bands [ __ ]
[ __ ] up yeah I want I want to date me a
fit chick yeah but you know what but not
too fast it would be a little exhausting
it's annoying no not really they're
always like doing CrossFit and [ __ ] and
eating healthy and you're like God damn
it my buddy's girls like uh she's got
them on a diet all the time
[Music]
like his girl is a trainer and she wants
kids with him so she's like you're not
gonna die on me I'm Gonna Get You In
Shape this motherfucker's allowed to eat
one thing pickles so he's hiding food
and [ __ ] she caught him eating crackers
she's like hey put it down now he's a
[ __ ] if you knew the guy bro I need to
know who this guy is he's allowed to eat
and by the way can't eat a whole jar
famous actor yeah he's great but he's
one of our best friends he's like he's
[ __ ] salt and cute he's one of the
most talented guys on the planet he's
incredible yeah damn I'm really
interested he has the biggest cats
you've ever seen I've known guys
in my head I think I know the best guy
in the world he probably doesn't care if
I told him hey you know you know who's
been uh girls on the road
yeah I heard young Val Kilmer whoa he's
baby Val yeah he's crazy
he goes on the road and because you know
there'll be a line waiting to get into
the venue and they see him and he's
getting blown up you can't get the
[ __ ] AC on it look man he's a camera
guy wait what's going on what happened
your mom should be proud dude that's
awesome I like this I like it right now
you're in my bed but the other thing is
is uh our boy uh uh David uh Lucas did
re give him a nickname calls him Bud
from uh oh my because he calls him Bud
from Married with Children but Bundy no
you remember Bud Boy
but Monday yeah yeah
there you go Faustino I'm sorry I'm
sorry yeah I love David love it but the
nickname it's kind of stuck it's yeah
you're feeling well though buddy you're
[ __ ] proud of you all the videos you
see all the thick boy videos that's all
him all the pictures
but he can't turn the AC on
[Music]
five
everybody should have at least one fight
in their life
yeah you learn a lot and it's like you
know when you fight on the street you
just you know it's dangerous but you
know it's dangerous it happens it
happens you don't have to think of it
you want to think about it but when you
train it for a fight for eight weeks
eight weeks you better get in the fight
it's different it's different I think
everybody should do that at least you
know what hey then what we gotta do is
we gotta start our own show it's called
Fight Club we just do a real fight club
we set up
bodyguards versus bodyguards yeah
bodyguards yeah camera guys versus
camera guys okay so we could have you
fight by producer podcast Dave I'm so
down I'm so down cheating podcast
hey what about Jamie can we get Jamie to
fight JV
young Jamie
it's not it's not they're fighting in
that kind of fighting it's not the pain
it's the exhaustion I go to I'm in
Arizona sugar Shawn and Tim Welch's
coach go come to come work Alice we'll
do a little slow grappling I'm like I've
been doing a little wrestling so I was
like all right I'm when I say flow we're
just going through [ __ ] Yeah by minute
like by minute I think we're doing two
minute rounds I think by round three or
four I was so tired I got embarrassed I
had to crawl off the mat because the
Gypsy rounds were like eight minutes but
bro it was just two we're just doing we
were doing takedowns and [ __ ] and then
going this is hard man
but I hadn't done it that's why you see
those stud routers at the highest level
where they're like I don't get why they
don't shoot it's because then when we
get tired oh bro they're scared to get
tired bro yeah just moving around not
even wrestling like just I was I was I
thought I'm an old man but I thought I
was gonna [ __ ] die I got embarrassed
I was that tired I got embarrassed
didn't you wrestle with cats and counter
too yeah yeah I train with her a little
bit
high altitude that's right is Pretty
Tough you wrestle girls do you get a
hard on while you're wrestling uh no sir
because she was [ __ ] your mom
somebody was wrong you're just trying to
[ __ ] she's tough man she's Scrappy I
got the rotation with in AKA Luke
Rockwell just throws me headgear and I
had my where were you there I had my
mouthpiece a while back I had my
mouthpiece yeah 74. I have my mouthpiece
in my [ __ ] thing I put it in and and
Daniel Cormier goes I got him first so
Daniel just I'm trying to hit him and
doing my stuff and he's like and then he
just double legs me and puts his [ __ ]
shoulder in my chest and he goes Luke
watch watch and he just gets up on his
toes well I I couldn't breathe
yeah it's a whole different thing I lost
it was a surprise surprise to him okay
he started his career at AKA with us
[ __ ] he can't forget from the from he
can [ __ ] wrestle oh you were out of
vacation yeah
dude
I didn't know because John Fitch John
fish is taught me what it's like to
wrestle with khabib no and Finch walks
around at 205.205 and he goes if I can
stand up on the day if I can stand up
again so it's a good day I was like yeah
and now Market jobs that bad
[ __ ] he's good did you ever roll
with khabib yeah all the time nightmare
he so I I actually because
when he first came to the gym not a lot
of people wanted to go Corner him
because the English he was English was
good but it wasn't great so like so when
someone hop is like look I don't know
Chicago and Coach him our Corner him
other guys were like yeah I don't really
know him yeah whatever I'll go he yeah I
roll with him I train with him you know
I spot with him you know he was one of
my training Partners would you wear that
first yeah even from the jump we always
bring the furry no he never wore it he
never wore it except for at the
weigh-ins and at the uh at the after the
fight yeah but I mean [ __ ] he's look he
was one of the guys that came in super
humble I celebrated his 25th birthday
with him his his birthday is the day
before mine he's the 20th and the 21st
of September he [ __ ] is someone that
like we showed up he took me out to
dinner it was his fight it was his fight
here I am I was the number two guy in
the world he's not even the top 15
rankings but he's taking me out to
dinner for his birthday he's such a
[ __ ] great guy he seems like a
beautiful he's he's he really is what's
the X Factor with
besides his wrestling because a lot of
guys wrestle what what why do you think
we're talking about earlier mine it's a
mine it's a mine you can't beat him
mentally look like I've said this before
I said this I think on the first fight
man you're here I said Islam Market Chef
is way more talented than can be better
striking better striking better Jitsu
not maybe not as good at wrestling but
but it's good like different style of
wrestling yeah they're both tens they're
both tens like 10 they're about 10 11
category anyways but with Islam it's the
men's the Mind khabib believes he can
never be beat which he obviously hasn't
been but what I'm saying is that with
Islam he has that he has that feeling
there's a [ __ ] here sorry it's my
hand I appreciate you for doing that
though thank you
yeah and so the mindset though with
Islam he knows he's good but he still
has a little bit of a trickle of a doubt
him tell in the main event yeah and so
like when the two of them Spar like you
know I've seen could be go through guys
that were khabib's had problems with
I've seen Islam go through them like
[ __ ] a hot night butter just foot
sweep some hook sweep some [ __ ] hit
toss them make them look like they're
[ __ ] their sisters like oh it's my
little sister I'm just tossing around
worse could be about a hard time with
that person in training sparring all
those things Islam [ __ ] him over but
you put the two of them together when
the lights are on and when you put the
two of those guys together Spar and
training it's like big brother little
brother I have a theory yeah just yeah
just it's like doing me wrong like
Islam's always making sure that Kabuto
doesn't get hurt because it's you know
he's getting ready for a fight it could
be oh yeah yeah
that's crazy man because I feel like
some people like khabib who are True
Believers like I feel like he lived such
a Pure Life like like there's no [ __ ]
truth there's no dishonesty doesn't give
a [ __ ] about money man because he
believes in something
yeah yeah
I cornered him for his first three or
four fights now I don't know khabib I've
never met the [ __ ] but somehow
I'm blocked on Instagram oh man what
yeah because I tried because if you're a
sinner dude
on Instagram
sometimes it's a mistake yeah sometimes
because there was a lot there was a
purpose yeah no no no there was there
was a while there was a wild where even
though we're friends he follows me I
follow him I couldn't find him no no no
so I think maybe it's like a translation
thing he thinks
hey some [ __ ] up [ __ ] let me blocked
this [ __ ] have you ever say
anything bad about him never ever I
don't know him he's a nice guy man that
whole crew of guys they're they're
they're they're all nice man yeah from
what I see from his interviews and stuff
but I'm telling you I didn't know who I
don't watch uh UFC I don't watch anime
that much yeah so I didn't know khabib
was until he fought Conor oh really yeah
I didn't I didn't yeah I trained with
him when he first came in I think he was
like 18-0 when he first came to AK he
was 18 19 or 18-0 I think when he said
these guys are like they stayed like
Anthony Joshua I think still lives like
just above his parents I think no he
lives in a huge man does he now but he
for a long time
khabib up until he fought khabib up
until he fought
um he was still living at home
he was married and he had he had his I
think he had his daughter first then he
had his son next but he had his daughter
first but he was still living at home
with his married and with his khabib's
kids monsters too no they're young
they're young they're like they're only
a year maybe two years ago yeah but he's
got a three-year-old now he's got a
three-year-old I think like a three or
four year old and then like a
one-year-old he's never coming maybe
a new one was like boxing match he just
signed he just signed with the soccer
team a European soccer play soccer
he was doing [ __ ] you'd never seen right
yeah it's just different type of setups
they live their life here like I was
trying to explain when I talked to him
about fighting he's like he's like yeah
me being 39 I always say you don't
remember I have 250 Samo fights yes
those are MMA fights just with the
[ __ ] yeah like don't let's not be
mistaken they Punch Yeah they Punch or
something yeah
Market Jeff is a two-time world champion
Osama world champion he's so funny
people around his father I think were
both world champions
in the mountains
yeah so seven thousand altitude though
like living Dyers
50
000 square foot gym there just so people
can start training so he can start
helping all the kids that are in his
community he's amazing is he the best
guy ever yes he's close he's pretty
close he's a good dude man people give
him a lot of hard time he's getting a
lot of flack right now on on the
internet there should be female uh ring
card girl useless yeah something about
the he's like he said he's like they're
useless it makes there's no sense he
said Marine car girls yeah for MMA he's
like they're useless
if he doesn't like it and he has his own
organization yeah that's his opinion
yeah there's there's different ways to
look at it though too like he looks like
I need to have three men though I think
he looks at it from like a standpoint of
that women are not supposed to be hit
touched like abused like that and that's
kind of where I think that's his culture
you're right but I thought that's what
he grew up but I've had that
communication and talk with him he's
like I just don't feel like women should
be hit women should not be touched it
shouldn't be well I should agree with
that because I love watching himself
he's like Brian so you know like Rush is
here it used to be a part of the Soviet
Union okay and it's one of the countries
in like where chechnya is it's in the
caucus it's the roughest yeah it's the
roughest it's like a mountain instrument
yeah
I was pretty good with it so you see
Georgia izerbaijan Armenia that's all
this whole area
there it is
the toughest people in the world yeah
they're all their entire area
let me know
if you if you watched this last 2021
Olympics you have people in the finals
from Georgia from chesnia from from
they're all from Texas it's
Mongol so that's that's where khabib's
from
that's where he's from how you pronounce
it
yeah go ahead say it again
I couldn't say his last name forever no
matter what I do oh really nine years
I say khabib but I know it's Habib I
just don't feel right saying yeah
I don't like to do that I feel bad I
like Turkish kind of no I know but as a
white person
how long you been white man I see it I
know for about four years man yeah
no man one of your grandparents black
quit lying homie
facial hair yeah
your dad looks Native American sir I
mean he looks like 100 yeah Cherokee and
I'm I mean if I were casting a movie in
the Old South yeah your dad is yeah so
my mom my so my grandmother was full
like Spanish Mexican yeah and then like
she's like Mexican they call her Mexican
but she has like the light green eyes
you know but my grandfather was 100
yucky Indian so my mother is 80 Native
American so 80 yeah
my dad was Scottish Dutch oh that's
close yeah so yeah okay well
yo let me second guess me if I have my
mom's last name Vasquez on you wouldn't
be saying yes oh [ __ ] Josh of course
you're Mexican yeah [ __ ]
man I wish this girl knocked the other
girl out I'm looking like oh
um look at those guys those the lighting
on that picture is not the best huh
yeah is this your gym yeah how far is it
from here
God it's close to my house this is very
close oh so you're not far then yeah
it's very good MMA caves you know Jim no
it's just all it's not enough space in
there for that
uh you're moving locations yeah we're
moving to a bigger spot aren't you
moving a new jib in Austin are you
awesome or Dallas oh broken guys I'm in
Dallas that's a lot of house in Dallas
wow
um the one in Dallas would probably be
in Frisco yeah that's where I'm at yeah
I'm right there in Austin obviously yeah
South Southeast Austin like uh Lakewood
like uh
Ramen area like Cedar Park or you're in
downtown south east Southeast of
downtown Southeast okay so more towards
Tesla they're going at it yeah yeah
exactly that looks 300 pounds in that
picture get it off he does look huge
right there
and Mark's hair looks looks like it
should have his own TV show Danny's
[ __ ] he's jacked Jesus Mark Mark's a
big kid you know I I honestly because he
we we follow each other on Instagram
he's always saying so he he seems like
such a [ __ ] nice guy we met him here
you went to this fight last time so he
came Mark yeah Mark's a great guy he's
[ __ ] yeah he's a super nice guy he's
great super nice guy um I can't believe
you deadlift that much that's crazy
weight dude that's not that much really
yeah it's not that much yeah it's not
too bad could you go to the Olympics for
lifting weights
um they I think they just started
including powerlifting yeah but I
wouldn't know there's other people who
are who are much better than me at Power
oh yeah have you ever seen the power
lifters they're like you know not to be
they're like real thick boys they're
like fat and muscle because the more you
weigh the more you can pull why is it
because I can wait it's the body weight
this is they're like 300 pounds so they
try to be that that size on purpose yeah
like you like you have seen the
strongest man contest yeah they're huge
oh yeah they're massive it's so big you
think Arnold Schwarzenegger could win a
Strongest Man
contests that's what you're dealing with
see that guy on the right that guy's
that that guy's is he the strongest man
in the world Eddie Hall had uh set the
record for a deadlift yeah
some of those abs like he bought them
that guy on the right weighed like 440
pounds and set the world
records who's that guy right there go to
the left Chin Chin thank God the guy on
the left the guy from Dagestan on the
far left that's a fake guy he's fake
he's fake yes
the guy on the right is a professional
body that's Phil Heath looks like no I
thought that guy was real Bubba guys on
the far left is fake no I don't think so
I think he's the he's the Iranian Hulk
they call him he's yeah it's all fake oh
you know
Flex wheeler what's his Instagram you
got an Instagram he does yeah yeah
what is that from you know I know he
said he was Natty though you know so
what's going on over here oh hold on I
heard that you said Fletcher where was
Natty no flex wheeler used to claim that
he was now oh he lost his legs because
that was real that guy's real problem
that's not real no Photoshop is good
these days
yeah yeah you know look the same in the
videos yep bro notice how you can't see
his body and you guys are down on T-Rex
yeah I do because because you know how
it started you know how to hold titties
conversations going on sorry how did
these things start the whole the whole
thing started we just we're just all
joking around titties explain this I was
on The Ultimate Fighter season 10. he
was a coach on there and there's a kid
on our team named Daryl schoonover yeah
so now showing how I think so now and he
was kind of like you know kind of out of
shape dude he's from I think New Mexico
I don't know where he's got it he was
soft
he's soft okay and he kept calling
titties you called him titties
nickname was titties would you hate it
no at first he didn't mind it but then
once we kept going yeah at first it was
funny it was fun I think you kept doing
it because he went with it he went with
it yeah it was all sort of fun and then
so how did that oh [ __ ] it ended pretty
bad because we because we started like
because everything got heated on the
show and we me and Rashad was going
ahead and everything and then then me
and um I'm not gonna call them titties
anymore Daryl Daryl yeah me and him we
we got heated we almost got in the fight
I wonder what he's doing yeah yeah I was
ready to fight him he's about to get
[ __ ] up yeah I was ready to fight him
yeah but so so listen now now I feel bad
because now I got titties [ __ ]
you ever talked to a shot or you're
still bad blood
with cornrows yeah we did a movie
together they made us German twins we
played German twins
he's a beautiful fight this was
yelling at her he's yelling at the other
coaches maybe because he didn't stop the
fight
she got cut really bad yeah the next oh
there's Daryl shooting over
man well he's still uh no that's not him
no no it is not there maybe damn that
was a good [ __ ] well you could see I
mean Daryl were you cool with him he was
he's like a tough guy get to know yeah
those guys yeah there were 15 people I'm
like that makes sense did the corner
stop it yeah
10 Rounds he's like number one oh yeah
yeah we got Jake Paul Tower in Woodley
right now oh my god
there you go right there oh my god there
they are right there there you are wait
is that he actually didn't have titties
I was just this no he did and it's fine
the thing is is he just kept harping on
it I think it got to him this is the guy
dude I'm doing a reality I'm doing a
reality show and I like to be
entertained because I'm a [ __ ] coach
yeah so I had I had a I had to make up
for it so you're so fun on there yeah I
had to make up I had to make everybody
laugh and show my my personality because
you remember nobody in UFC knew me
before this yeah but I came from Japan
or something and no one knew knew me did
you already fight Marvin or you did this
before you fought Marvin so you fought
Marvin yeah
I didn't do this and this Chuck was a
champion this is my second time doing uh
The Ultimate Fighter I was the first
coach was Chuck The Champ at the time
when you beat him yeah
so tough and then and then I fought Dan
Henderson after that and unified The
Pride belt yeah I'm the first one to
ever do that and then the UFC gave the
credit to um Anderson Silva man I was
kind of butt hurt about that but he was
never champ over credit for what no okay
Dan Henderson had two belts he had the
205 and the 85 though and I took the 205
belt off him after I fought Chuck yeah
and and I was the first ever unified
Champion oh wow and then Anderson Silva
did it after me he fought Dan Henderson
oh that's right but after and then they
gave it and they and they told and they
told Anderson they said Anderson was the
first ever oh weird unified Champion I'm
like wow I just I just did that yeah
that's weird yeah I just did that that's
a shame and they didn't give me the belt
and didn't give me the belt in the cage
they gave me the belt later and Lorenzo
told me don't ever wear the belt to the
fights
when he told me don't do no more movies
I can't look at him I kind of looked at
him wrong I was like why why wouldn't
you want to do movies but the the 18
[ __ ] they [ __ ] up that fight with
Rashad because they wanted you to focus
on fighting they were they [ __ ] up my
fight with Rashad but it would have sold
more pay-per-views though if I would
have done been doing movies yeah but but
I chose the brand but I had I chose the
movie over the fight with Rashad this
was fighting my hometown I did I [ __ ]
up but but they don't know they don't
understand is that uh the 18 movie was a
couple years in in words just my lucky
came right at the same time yeah
yeah I don't what do you want me to do
I've been I've been working towards this
movie for a couple years and then it
came right when Michelle fight supposed
to happen yeah what can you do this
chick has three belts yeah it's a hard
decision she's legit bro Jesus she's
good
great boxer holy [ __ ] I didn't I didn't
think there are honestly I didn't really
to entertain everybody you know we're
reading the subtitles here and I'm a
[ __ ] coach
yeah good coaches right here yeah yeah
yeah girls you have Tiki yeah
oh I love Tom he was great yeah who else
we have 30. wait so what was it again
she's 40. so she's 40 and one 41-1
foreign
listen man if you haven't bailed on
hairy balls it's time to buzz them nuts
with landscape the officially we gotta
keep you want pizza he said I can redo
this read uh the official electric
trimmer of the UFC get your rocket ready
for takeoff with the new lawnmower 4.0
kick your bush to Pluto manscape is
taking off right now it's available in
not only the US of a but Canada the UK
across Europe Australia South Africa
Singapore so we got a bush in Singapore
we got you covered manscape are the
leaders of Men's Grooming I threw that
in uh the new lawnmower 4.0 is
waterproof has advanced skincare uh skin
safe technology so your balls are going
to be safer and sound all thick boys get
20 off and free shipping with the code
CFC at manscape.com that's 20 off and
free shipping with the code CFC
manscape.com we got the Lincoln code in
the bio enjoy the fights so can you like
shave your balls
yo don't ever [ __ ]
he moved in with me to cook for me he
cooked all my meals and between him and
training Antonio McKee I lost 30 pounds
I don't want you eating pizza not the
chef man this guy this guy is great man
he make like healthy food taste good as
[ __ ] I'm a picky eater you have a chef
too Bradley or no no not yet yeah no all
right the chef is the one that's going
to get mad
maybe we're gonna bring Tiki now he's
watching the fight somewhere else yeah
[ __ ] it no no don't eat the pizza all
right
yeah you guys see the chicken season I'm
about to send something to McDonald's
well no there's the Irwin up the street
with healthy salads and [ __ ] yeah
uh Pizza would be good but yeah Pizza
would be good yeah I don't know don't
there's a pizza place you hate Pizza I
love pizza I just don't want you to eat
it I just combo good choice let's go
combo you are you really strictly
combination for the most part yeah
me lovers Pizza yeah meat lovers Pizza
meat lovers Pizza yeah what are you
getting it for what from what my
wallet's up there just take my leg out
to Irwin and get that giant pizza I'll
pay for the pizza
you took it you took a Prius there I
guess eat two slices no
my wallet's right on the table there
just get them a Caesar salad that's
perfect with chicken you could just give
us all salads Caesar salad no it's Irwin
it's really good pizza oh it's Irwin oh
[ __ ] yeah wait a minute
hold on oh man I'm asking like this
you'll like this all right no they bite
they might or if anywhere does this
whatever you get okay I'm trying to look
like you
sausage
Main Event time hopefully they don't do
the boxing thing where they drag it out
to some of the fighters have to walk out
a certain time yeah what made you saw a
thick boy at clothing
it's thick and then there's like at my
shows there's so many like thick like
dudes who look like me so I start the
thick one just caught on this is for
bigger people yeah that's smart because
it's not you know go shopping it's not
that many clothes for big people well
it's like like we don't do like big and
tall [ __ ] but it's just like you know
like most dudes aren't built like
Bradley or you know so like the common
dudes like normal you know so we're
thick boys that was a good idea yeah
it's gone well man
yeah I did a podcast with um DJ Paul
from um the other day and he does
clothing line and stuff and he asked me
hey let's do something together I said
okay cool but I want to do something big
and tall because before I lost his 30
pounds I had to buy some more clothes
and stuff yeah with the big and tall
this [ __ ] sucked oh it's terrible yeah
yeah I used to work on this oh awful
it's awful and like and then we get big
and it's all boxy look at that [ __ ] and
that's gonna look good it just don't
look good that's why like this company
built they have shirts where it's like
if you're a bigger dude like even you
have a tummy but it hides it yeah so I
rock them all the time these built
shirts they're great I never heard yeah
I'll send you something oh they're great
man yeah yeah I want I want I want I
want big and tall I have like some
designers yeah like some fly [ __ ] so I'm
trying to design some some fly [ __ ] for
for the big people because it's not that
big and tall dude I know big guitar but
I don't fit on other stuff so big guitar
I go there you like it too big
you're a thick boy you're a thick boy
this is going to be good here we go is
it is it though is it Brian is it going
to be good no matter what it's going to
be
[ __ ] well look Tyron Woodley is a great
champion and
this is amazing now here's my question
to both of you guys and all due respect
when I the only time I've seen is we're
about to say something negative right
now with all due respect yeah I see him
hitting mitts yep I don't see I don't I
just see mitts and I'm not seeing I'm
not seeing any specific
this is what scares me right now I don't
see a sweat on him right like that's the
thing like you got to come out a little
bit damp you that means like because I
actually trained I used to train this
girl named Jermaine Deuteronomy so she
yeah she never warmed up she's from
Holland she's a kickboxer she never
warmed up she's got a highlight reel of
her on YouTube knocking on a guy Frank
Grillo yeah our boy oh yeah there he is
this is called Cop Shop this is this is
uh I think uh Carnahan produced this or
wrote this yeah Conan wrote this he's a
dope writer 300 guys is that the 300 guy
yeah no no no yes yes
Butler Butler right yeah
[ __ ] man yeah Frank's the man
Butler's cool too he's cool yeah he's
really cool I can't wait to see that
yeah Frankie he's dope yeah I love his
movies he's so good great guy too he's
legit like Hollywood tough guy too oh
yeah [ __ ] box fight
and and Jujitsu actually come on man
give this main event he was a Hixson
gave him his purple belt that's cool
yeah
he's No Joke Man Frank as far as actors
go
wait but Corner hand is a dope ass
writer people don't know this but he's a
great writer I don't know if you get
credit for it but he actually wrote 18.
because he didn't like the script yep he
named the script so he changed we was
working on the movie without a finish
script but he was writing the script
he's such a good founder it's weird like
somebody he's such a good writer like he
and his brothers are [ __ ] great
writer too here we go eight rounds
Cruiserweight 188 right
damn money dude you know how insane it's
gonna be if Jake Paul knocks him out I
mean it's gonna be nuts
I do think I do wonder why Tyron isn't
he does look very dry and you want to be
able to yeah I don't know well they
could have shot that way earlier that's
true that's true as well
but I have a problem I I always warm up
pretty well then by the time I get to
the cage I'm I'm dry I don't yeah I
don't know how to and it's cold yeah
you're all sweaty and then when you walk
outside it's so cold yeah but you always
bring a change when you walk outside
yeah so what I do is I'll bring two sets
I'll bring one sweat suit to one weapon
I change out of that put on a dry one
because I can keep my sweat going until
I get to the cage because when you walk
out when you walk out when you get the
rodeo Auditorium it's freezing the
reason why it's freezing because the
majority of the time we fight in ice
skating rinks that's true when you go to
places right because that's the 18 to 20
000 seat Arena so most of the ufcs are
in 1827 seed Arenas so they're usually
ice skating rink so there's ice
underneath
he was great too yeah yeah
him and boss Skeletor there we go
Skeletor a lot like dude he's a nice guy
but tomorrow commentary wise this guy's
a [ __ ] man yes man moro's the best
man yeah he's good I if I was to say
anybody that's done commentary I put
really I put moral first and then I
probably have like I right now I
probably have an egg next who's that
annik you know you put Rogan in there no
no I'm talking about they're saying like
that yeah this yeah what is this
play-by-play there's a play by
play-by-player is not to play no color
he's color he does what he does what I
do and what yeah and like what Biz being
does
I never understood that yeah yeah one
time I did I did I did and they called
it color I thought because I was black
[Laughter]
does like all the commercial reads they
do all the ad reads they do all the They
lead up they lead us to everybody yeah
they they toss like you know like Anna
be like Joe what are we seeing here and
then Joe will break it down oh okay so
what they do is they carry on the
conversation when there's really nothing
going on so like if the fighters are
just hanging out against cage he's like
the color will say yeah so so-and-so's
sister had a baby back in like 1422 and
like they'll talk about they'll they'll
have they'll fill in with like knowledge
was so good and they call that the
colors the goal is great I think
Goldie's great oh good man the the
look the thing is when Goldie left the
UFC in the Bellator and Goldie's amazing
I I want I want to see him change his
style a little bit from place to place
that's it agree because there's that UFC
like yeah his brand and then go to
Bellator and then when it's not UFC it
was like a weird mix it just didn't it
was it was the same it was used as the
exactly along the same stuff here we go
oh yeah he needs to be like because he's
here's the thing he's [ __ ] Super
Creative like he's got a lot of stuff
he's so [ __ ] good but the problem is
it was like when he came when he left
UFC he went to Bellator it still had
that UFC feel I was like I think yeah I
understand what you're saying because
you're so used to it yeah yeah yeah
because he's he he is so good at
everything he does yeah he just had to
mix it up himself that's it are there
any fights that you're dying coming up
next
coming up next the fight I want to see
the one now that uh Giga just won I want
to see him and Calvin cater well that's
a great fight him and commentator doing
wrong I know he called out Max Holloway
but that's a big jump Max has a fight
already that's a big jump though for him
to fight Max like go to Calvin kator oh
you know Max was supposed to fight Zaire
and then Max had to pull out yeah like I
just said yeah yair though is yeah who
knows
Tommy he's up and down
I would have loved to seeing Giga fight
zabet but zubby it's not [ __ ]
fighting yes it beats the beat's also
ranked weird and yeah what about who's
next to fight who's who's left for Izzy
is he supposed to fight Whitaker but he
got postponed because in New Zealand one
person got covered shut down that's
right one person and it shut down the
whole country yeah that's crazy yeah
Dave Chappelle In The Crowd Oh damn
is he from Ohio as well no he's from New
Orleans Louisiana Louisiana
he's great he's a good guy he's a good
kid he's a very good kid great guy funny
oh Chappelle
lacyto right there he's a great boxer he
thought he thought uh he fought um
Mayweather um he did a great job
that's neon spring sign yep yeah man
Andre Berta is a bad [ __ ]
that's what looks like Michael Irving uh
she's a Olympian yeah
she's that she's my parents you don't
want to get caught smoking weed no no no
no I shouldn't go to the Olympics she's
I think she won a gold right no bronze
that would be a bronze and homeboy has a
silver but they don't care that guy got
gold I don't care I don't care about
swimming was good for him damn he has to
wear though they're like dude you can
come but you gotta bring your medal he's
got the [ __ ] I bet he won that swimming
with his ears there's Boom Boom Mancini
right there
that's funny
his father was his coach man they find
it a lot of fi when fathers are coaches
Sons those the ones that if you look at
like the statistics they're the ones
that
usually die in the ring
not a lot of gays have died before but
there have been enough in the ones
they've done they're always dead because
the dads want to let them go it's
because the kid doesn't want to you know
he doesn't want to you think he's the
opposite yeah I would but it's [ __ ] up
that makes me upset what is Logan saying
right now I like how his tag is [ __ ]
can you hear Jim is that anything good I
mean we can but no we can't hear we'll
get kicked off here you're like anything
good
I don't know why chin doesn't get to
listen to it no I can't even do it you
have a hard time reading the
it's going fast enough
it is fast
that's the fastest kid man captions I've
ever seen actually agree yeah they're
behind yeah
wow I'm really trying I wish they could
get a shot of this so like the internet
it is kind of bad hey real quick who was
I arguing with oh Andrew Schultz he's
saying you think this fight's gonna be
bigger look at that Arena compared to
when Jake fought Ben askren that arena
is no this is way bigger yeah but I
don't know but you have to remember
though that that show what Ben Oscar was
on triller right
yeah oh that was a [ __ ] the whole
production the whole production was a
[ __ ] show this is also the most horrible
man I've had a lot of time horrible like
now we're like wait a minute
bigger because it's a tougher fight it's
in his hometown like but this is a real
production they put money yeah
trailer was a night like yeah
all right
that's cool
he said he was gonna if he wins that
championship fight which he did he goes
I'm gonna buy your car man I said no
don't do that invest it in real estate
yeah he loves cars man yeah he loves
cars he has that little uh it was a
little rocket yeah it's a Civic yeah
yeah he's learning how to fix it yeah
he's a real good kid man he's a great
dude I love him you know he adopted his
little brother oh damn yeah his little
brother he's a little brother training
at the gym he's a really really good
dude he's a good dude he's taking a
little brother on his wing not his
little brother's getting his [ __ ] well
look at the other guy the other guy that
that trains with Joey Davis yeah that
kid is you just got to get his mental
right that kid's [ __ ] phenomenal man
he is so damn good he's got a great dad
his family loves him like it's it's
crazy look at these guys they started
off with their jackets and their [ __ ]
ties off
either he I like Dave Portner I don't
know him but he's yeah I like big cats
who is that guy over there on the right
yeah big cat he's he's a talented dude
man is he why did they decide to match
this is a little awkward he's a guy for
Barstool he hosts the the show uh part
of my take
I like that I like bars he's good man I
like it cut the sound off yeah it's
great
again yeah the flag is and pull us off
YouTube That's not like me and Rogan for
years with fight campaign like he he'd
never play the sound because if it does
it they pick it up and shut it down
we're out of Technology even with Rogan
being the face of the UFC that he still
couldn't play the sound yeah wow
technology you think show time be like
yeah you can play the sound you're worth
real time
maybe they won't pull us you know they
give us a little leeway but I can't like
air the fight I mean no no just
pay-per-view the sound you think
yeah you think damn
maybe just gives like earplugs you know
a little airpods I know it's the problem
the problem
we wouldn't talk that's true I never
thought about that put it in one of us
good yeah yeah I'm the you know yeah you
should [ __ ] internet guy here yeah
you're right I'm reading the [ __ ]
chat shout out to chat by the way you're
in the chat oh they love this [ __ ] you
can do it all you can do it all I think
we had over 25 000 lives 28 000.
where'd you uh where'd you grow up San
Francisco
yeah I've lived in L.A though for the
last like [ __ ] 13 years huh yeah
but yeah I'm definitely a social media
guys for sure yeah he's the social media
Wiz so I'm watching I'm like yo I get a
lot of tips from it really
there we go
where'd you come with the name Zoo
culture
oh there's a long story for that one man
um
that's like Todd film he's like long
story short and 50 minutes later yeah
it's so it's a really long story but
essentially I wanted to blend my other
logo the raw gear Diamond the logo into
what the name of the gym is going to be
so you'd have to see the logo of zoo
yeah it's it's a kind of like a very
complicated thing but in the logo Zoo
another logo right there this is the
rock here this is the rock I'm already
getting bored so exactly see so it's
like I don't want I don't want it this
is gonna be a thing that we can't do wow
that sounds called raw gear
it's like the gym it's it's yeah I'm
there every day it's great
but I wanted to blend them and like if
you saw the logo you would see how it
Blends but those but the logo but the
name Zoo came from where well just be
like it's wild for it's for what I
wanted to blend this into that it needed
like visually it needed the two o's like
I needed to think of something that made
sense oh word yeah so it's kind of a
longer sword just I don't want to
[ __ ] no yeah I mean we got it
I always love those guys say hey long
story short but it's [ __ ] already
been too long until they get there yeah
you did your best yeah I mean listen are
these guys talking smack here so you
live nearby then yeah so you're here
you're here your Gym's here yeah that's
how we met Shane where you live
so Brian and uh chin live on the west
side it's a [ __ ] show down there but
this this was another reason why I think
they were so happy to promote this fight
is they actually have footage of Tyrone
fighting because of Strike Force because
Showtime had the footage of him that's
true because so then it makes it easier
to market the fact that he's a stud like
he's knocked out all these guys remember
this also came this this whole fight
came to fruition when
um
when Aston was fighting Jake yeah
Woodley was going to ask her and he went
into the locker room and Jake's corner
and started talking [ __ ] to Woodley and
when he was like we can do it right here
man and just build the fight up do you
think some of this stuff is staged no
because the guy who that's it wasn't
really Jake starting it was this
cornerman who was a box that nobody
knows and he should start talking [ __ ]
to him wait you just said this [ __ ]
isn't staged you think none of it is
staged that that was organization they
go into these things no for sure like
we're stealing their hat or got your hat
oh that's all planned you think that was
a plan
Jake and uh Logan around the past flying
in and Jake goes I'm gonna take his hat
and Logan goes I wouldn't do that dude
don't do that and then Jake just did it
and that's when he got jumped I mean
that's why I came just jumps not playing
but okay but that's not stage if the
other person don't know about it no they
don't know yeah
yeah yeah they played it 100 like Jake
was like oh I'm gonna do this and Logan
told him that's I mean that's the thing
man these kids are not stupid they're
very I totally know how to use the
internet like you can't deny any of that
but it but it helps everybody like it
helps the fighters of course Woodley's
getting more eyeballs than he's ever got
before yeah so I thought it was the
other brother that stole the head it was
this [ __ ] yeah he got yeah I get them
mixed up and he got beat the [ __ ] up by
Floyd's uh bodyguards yeah
oh yeah black guy he got an uppercut
they like jumped him
and then Logan rushed over there oh so I
got I was uh the whole time Floyd was
like I don't know how Logan did it yeah
no because I was thinking why would he
why would he do it why would why would
Jake do it just talked about all about
drama starting to drama get more than
the narrative was Jake like everyone was
talking about Jake because he did it oh
here we go here we go come on here we go
come on damn this is exciting though I
can't lie as much as I think it's a fake
ass fight I'm so excited hey I don't
think it's a fake
it's obviously not a fake fight it's
real they're actually fighting but yeah
he's not taking a fall I don't know man
he didn't take a fall but he didn't
prepare for it yeah so that's kind of
like taking a fall you don't think he
trained at all no bro he ran he just ran
out there and got punched in the face
and fell down yeah
this did he get knocked out though he
wasn't knocked down
man yeah yeah
you can't be a former world champion in
any organization give a [ __ ] and go out
there be like oh
who's that rapper walking out with him I
don't know he's not famous oh that's uh
[ __ ] I'm not up in my pop culture I
didn't listen to new Kanye Genesis
OT Genesis yeah OT Genesis is he famous
Isaac he is kind of kind a little bit
Coco he's not like mainstream I thought
you said something how do you guys keep
up with this [ __ ]
about five years ago it drives me crazy
maybe I I promise you that's what I
thought you said
your [ __ ] arm's gonna be tired that's
impressive
yeah
let's see probably about three yeah man
that's boxing though man what song is he
I just wanna know what song is he
playing
it's you know what it's never good when
they walk out and sing it yeah it never
works out
um
when I fight Shannon who would you have
yeah don't have a dog Memphis dude like
yeah I'm from Memphis and I think
y'all's kind of mad at me I never I
never I never like I never really came
out to a lot of Memphis songs and like
when I started fighting on TV so um
this is what you do when you have them
walk you out don't have them don't have
them sing have them lip sync to what the
music yeah that's what they usually you
should have an opera singer come out no
three six would be sick and what about
some ballerinas yes what about little
Naz x wait wait wait I'm just
spitballing ideas
I'm gonna tell you why not him because I
didn't like his music video which one oh
yeah the last one I'm God Street Soldier
I just did you know oh yeah the [ __ ]
the devil thing and I just I don't I
don't I don't like it I don't like the
devil yeah it seems a little much yeah
yeah I just don't I just don't like I
just don't like it they got pulled right
because little kids got pulled yeah come
out with my shirt off and I'm just like
I don't know what I'd be doing just
clang in a [ __ ] like whatever scene
you against Shannon Bridge oh my God
sick Shannon Briggs yeah do that so if
you beat him you're gonna fight him MMA
or he has to fight MMA either way either
way
that's the only reason why I never came
after Three Six Mafia because of that
name because I am God Street Soldier oh
word but but but I I met I met DJ Paul
and he not like that no I'm sure he's
not like that so now I you know I'm cool
with since I've known him all these
years but before you meet somebody you
don't know yeah come out to judge people
you got to come out to Slob On My Knob
is
[Applause]
he got a lot of fights on he has a lot
of fights here we go here we go hey guys
here we go wow look at the Indian dude
Yahoo Indian on his shoulder that's sick
what does that mean that so that the
Cleveland Indians can't use that logo
anymore so they changed the Cleveland
Sentinel symbols yeah it's weird
so he just represents so he put yeah so
he put the whole Cleveland Show oh [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] dope though damn
that is tough is he from Cleveland yeah
I'm gonna say
that's tough though here we go yeah here
we go that's a tight move
damn how nervous does it look nervous
look how sweaty is hey look how sweet
how is it looking impossible he's warmed
up I'm never nervous yeah
like they don't the attention because he
ain't been fighting he doesn't yeah he
doesn't realize like the repercussions
that could happen because it's for the
Cakewalk yeah before he this is his
toughest yeah I think he looks nervous
he's sweaty I think I mean you're gonna
be a little nervous right of course you
have to be but he's also there's there's
also he's also so used to it there's a
difference in being nervous and there's
there's a difference between like
anxiety like almost like that excitement
to get this [ __ ] over with like hey in
what eight rounds he's getting paid yeah
when he walks out at the end like that's
that's like all my fights at the end I
was always in 25 minutes or in 15
minutes I'm getting a check that's all I
cared about I didn't think about
anything else
all the hard shit's over man this is the
fun part the fight part the fight was
the best part is taking the seriously
yeah I thought the money when I got hurt
and trained again I'm like man I don't
want to pull out man what was your
mentality Rampage going in like walking
to the ring yeah like this one I'm a
different person you were there um no
I'm a totally different person I'm I'm
most of the time I'm rampaged but
sometimes he don't show up yep sometimes
Rampage does nothing he doesn't want to
show up yeah sometimes you don't show
them you don't want to fight what do you
mean by that like you show up and you're
not motivated to fight no it's just it's
just that um it's a weird thing it's a
it's a switch it's a switch and I can't
control it it's a switch and and I'm
Rampage but I remember uh one fight I
knew I wasn't Rampage somebody was
walking me out and he dropped like a pen
or something and I was gonna bend down
help him pick it up I'm like oh [ __ ] did
you lose that fight I think I lost it
damn but but
me Quinn has won some fights before but
most of the time it's Rampage in there
do you get nervous yeah yeah you know
but not not the same that's why I want
to do boxing too because even when I was
fighting Fedor even though I was I was
unhealthy I was out of shape I trained
really hard for that fight people don't
understand that but I had like a um I
got misdiagnosed and some medicine like
[ __ ] me up and I was and I just wasn't
you know I should I should have pulled
out and and fatal is a dangerous
[ __ ] yeah yeah it was not
challenging for me I've been fighting
for so long I said I want to do
something different boxing now I'm gonna
get nervous all over again there's gonna
be something different where you don't
know you know you don't know what's
going to happen yeah yeah I want I want
that feeling again back like 10 years
ago you know like when you see what it's
not fun
you have a great Camp you wake up in the
morning like damn today's not the day
yeah there's nothing worse when you're
back there you're like oh I'm off I'm
just not feeling it man for the fire
yeah
time to roll and you're like [ __ ] I
don't feel like doing [ __ ] I couldn't
imagine no there's there like you you
have a great Camp you're like [ __ ] I
feel the best in your head no injuries
show up in like the morning of the fight
you wake up and you're just like I'm
tired I've asked myself a few times like
why why am I doing this yeah
I've asked myself that a few times maybe
like three three times yeah why am I
doing this then when I get that paycheck
oh that's what I'm doing that's right
yeah then me then I'm on a high if I win
I'll knock somebody out I'm gonna I
don't I can't even really sleep that
night
I'm like still I'm still adrenaline
after the show after the fight yeah
especially a knockout especially about
fighting Vegas or something I don't I
thought it was even in Japan I stay up I
stay up all night party in the clubs and
drinking and stuff I don't do no drugs
some of you guys need to know about me
weed is the only drug I ever tried in my
whole life I've never even tried any
other drug no never and I started
smoking weed as well choices yeah
alcohol I drink I've never eat mushrooms
never never I'm I'm totally against
drugs never tried
Coke hand though never tried
I mean the bathroom was like 10 minutes
I don't know I never tried it and so I
can stay up if I can stay up like people
that natural just like my friends be
doing stuff instead of just right
Williams after a fight I can do it that
drilling going yeah Josh you look like a
seasoned drug addict yeah he actually
does Josh is all quiet but I like Josh
because Josh is like
no you actually you don't do any drugs
look at that guy you're clean no how old
are you Audrey I'm 43. young as [ __ ]
young 43. you look so young yeah don't
you look good so young yeah try man I'll
try no I mean Audrey I drink quite a bit
now especially now that I'm done
fighting yeah you gotta remember I spent
20 years just sure I drink after the
fight and then by Monday I was back in
the gym just training back on track I'm
like all right whatever so all right all
right that shit's about to go down so I
don't know Tyran still has his music on
it's just a little nervous I'm gonna
take Brennan's money Tyrone is the
second time in a row he looks smaller he
didn't pay me by the way last time I
haven't got the money
he has those headphones personally I'm
rooting for Tyron I just I want Tyrone
to win me too I want to see we're doing
let's go hopefully Woodley's
bless you know what I want to see this
is what I want to see I want to see a
knock down [ __ ] drag out fight and
then wood knocks him out like in the
sixth or seventh so they do the rematch
and then it makes the rematch more yeah
but I think if that were to happen Jake
Paul's gonna win more fans even if you
were to lose
a fighter he's gonna win more that's
what I'm saying the rematch will be
[ __ ] yeah even way bigger you got to
respect this no to do the fight period
like that takes [ __ ] balls man who's
the better boss how much
between him and his brother yeah him and
uh him and Logan who's older who's older
Logan's
Pam good old Pam oh his mom not bad I
like men oh yeah what the [ __ ] I got a
guy right there whoa
yo could you imagine right now oh and
the lights
everybody calm down
okay everyone be cool all right the
fight hasn't started yet all right calm
down guys we lost signal I'm telling I'm
telling everyone this thing right now
okay
[Applause]
oh well all right all right here we go I
have no I'll tell you right now if Jake
knocks him out with with ease it's off
to the [ __ ] races
without a doubt oh man so many other
Fighters can come out the Woodworks
trying to fight him I'm [ __ ] nervous
now I'm nervous oh [ __ ] why is he why is
Woodley so low like that hey and when
you short it's better to be shorter are
you it's better to be shorter it's
harder to fight a shorter guy if you you
got to get loyal when you're shorter
[Music]
wow feel them out a little bit here
we go wow
it's gonna be different here
relaxing relax tea wood more controlled
relax
yeah he's way more controlling all these
others nice slow jab there
and see what hits come on what dude what
has the white stand yeah and he looks
big
[ __ ] strong
yeah that's respect out of Jake though
that just shows a sign of intelligence a
real different pace for showing this
fire and all the other ones
I wrote the [ __ ] move man yeah you
can yay before yeah yeah
he looks [ __ ] good
yeah wow so I don't need to double that
jab I'm still shocked that this [ __ ]
belt that he's got on his waistband well
his waistline that's dope yeah look
there's LEDs on his sh paint oh [ __ ]
even at his hips up nice job he's
doubling up that jab man yeah he's
reaching there though that's trouble the
reach yeah
how did boxing how did boxing get did
get to this huh YouTube
LEDs on their belts and yeah listen man
it's always because the boxing promoters
wouldn't let the it's always a fight
show that we wanted to see put on yeah
so then somebody's gonna step up I blame
it on covet yeah
yeah
we was bored for a long time like we
were watching goddamn thing yeah right
yeah oh
all right those are crispy nice shots I
don't know why will it does this
sometimes come on he's not he's like
he's pretty tentative oh man yeah he's
always been that way over there smile
it was like that when he was Champion
though was it come on he's never really
been a pressure fighter oh okay okay I
don't start a fights like you got he
usually fires off the back foot he fires
that right hand off he's not going like
he's not going in at all he's he
all right
Jake looks huge
Tyler's got some own legs
oh
he's got he borrowed Mark Hunt's legs
with his [ __ ] fight man short shorts
yeah there's like no media it's just
Logan down there dude with the camera
you gotta take a Polaroid look at that
oh oh that was a damn
Logan down there talking [ __ ] to see
wood right now as we're fighting yeah of
course is he yeah if a tea would just do
the right hand and Logan starts laughing
t t wood looks just as fast and crisp
though yeah that's good
he looks good
dude I don't know Jake really doubled up
on the jab maybe that three minutes
yeah dreaming around is it two or three
I think there's three I know I know Jake
wanted three minutes because he thought
he'd get dragged with uh aspirin it was
two minutes so I'm not sure if it's the
same
this is eight rounds right this is three
minutes we're not sure we'll see I think
it's three I think it's three minutes
eight rounds and for some reason there
was talk about there's no drug testing I
don't know what the [ __ ] that meant but
there was a whole wait there's no drug
testing no no no no but the night of
they probably drug test before but no
they didn't hang up so they took so I
got no problem so they can take whatever
which is wow
I agree I agree for these guys yeah I
think I don't think Fighters should be
able to take yeah I don't think so no
it's super dangerous no yeah nobody
touching Pride but anyways
yeah anyway so everybody was on the
process for me yeah damn yep almost
everybody was everybody you think Fedor
was on you think Fedor was on it I don't
think Fedor was on yeah yeah
is this gonna go to [ __ ] decision I'm
going to be pissed it feels like it's
going to decision well no yeah well at
least not well I mean they're both but
they're feeling each other out that's
what they're doing yeah the real boxing
match are feeling each other out now if
they keep feeling each other out for
[ __ ] we're getting the fourth then
we're in trouble
him
damn because in order for Willie to get
knocked out he's gonna have to take a
chance because if he keeps riding like
this going this conversations
he's definitely gonna lose a decision
like unless it's like yeah you're you're
catching elbow and gloves though you're
in Cleveland Ohio that's where he's from
yeah you ain't winning that decision
yeah I mean but you want it's like a
real box yeah you know I'm just saying
based on the cooking punches [ __ ] I
mean they're gonna want him to win Jake
Paul looks good man he still looks good
dude for only having those shitty fights
yeah he's [ __ ] [ __ ] he's going to
fight for about three years
a little bit right there I don't know I
don't like his technique I don't like
Jake Paul's technique that much well
he's
Woodley's been super timid maybe just
trying to drag him out and then open
like I like Jake's movement though he's
keeping that jams oh
he's got he's got long
arms yeah both both are super timid to
throw something Brandon you don't miss
this [ __ ] at all not at all
no yeah why are you retire so young [ __ ]
man stand up oh
I don't miss this
I've noticed that I have noticed how to
do this [ __ ] ever no zero none someone's
like oh Rampage
you know what you fight Shannon maybe
yeah yeah I don't I don't wanna I don't
want to miss it I don't want to miss it
because so many if I could have done it
all dude
who got rocked oh he didn't get wrong
gloves but but Jake is being more
aggressive well Jake's actually doing
well which is freaking crazy Jake didn't
have to open up though you did you think
he wouldn't do well
I'm shocked I am because herons and
that's fair because we don't know much
about Jake you've only seen two right
hands out of them yeah that's a real
fighter yeah but when you start getting
into like a bit man when you're starting
to like conversations with people that
have trained with them people that have
worked with them I get it it's fight cam
stuff and I understand that but it's
still shocking though yeah it is man
turn multi-time championships I mean it
is boxing though it just goes to show
that anyone can watch in though it's
crazy
see
he's not way bigger Tyrone's [ __ ]
he's thick muscular but Jake is just
bigger he's just you give that recipe
yeah
I just want to see someone get knocked
the [ __ ] out man I'll be honest yeah we
all do what was the BET what you put it
on with t-wood what plus what just has
to win uh level plus one 180
earlier today it was 160. yeah
Jeff Leon love that's a huge
as far as the main coach I think that's
him right there right the Leon lover uh
straight bet uh plus 170. well that's
cool
yeah plus 170 is the best line I got
what do you think he's saying to him
right now uh throw punch dude yeah get
active yeah yeah let's try and hit him
this round who is his coach right there
who's that guy
no idea I don't know man
I mean if I'm T wood I'm hiring the best
he has good coaches yeah yeah all right
yeah
oh you want to give Woodly fighter
advice no no wait a minute no no don't
please tell me what you're saying I want
I want the best coach the best boxer
coaches oh that's true but that's not
boxing though is it now oh that kind of
caught him there
see if I'm Willy here I'm here yes hang
on him and just body shot hang on body
shot
come on now let's get into this
oh nice jab to the body there thank you
as a Parry
damn yeah I'll make it a little uglier
if I'm Woodley I'd make that skinny
Steve Harvey break it up dude
our time I put his ass in the corner
yeah I do I may get ugly I wouldn't sit
back here like he's doing no he's Timmy
Timmy Jason
oh he rocked him
he rocks
yeah Jake he gets hit how's he respond
man get get him
yeah oh
yeah it is yeah well they're smart
straight right to the body same as that
combo no mystery boy Woodley had that
was a crisp you think you think Willie
knows that oh oh
do they both look good it's freaking a
trip yeah there yeah they do damn
well I'll tell you what by this fourth
fifth round somebody can drop yeah I
think so yeah I think four
oh [ __ ]
I think fifth round is done I'm calling
fifth round yeah fifth or sixth by the
way Jake hanging just at the edge of the
pocket like that
that's good man
you think boom boom's like hating in the
back of his head right now because
Jake's making more money this month than
he ever made
oh [ __ ] you know he got hit if he shaked
his head that was nice
Jake Paul with a big flurry right there
that was a nice long uppercut damn
that's Paul Bros can fight a little
can't they just kind of throw man come
on wood throw yeah he ducked his head
what has to open up yeah you just gotta
throw he has to risk it was looking very
good man
how much time figure I thought that fan
cuts off the clock for me
Jake Jacob's confident man he's getting
more confident
double up the Jab oh oh oh
he's going he's going for it bad
intentions
damn that cat's good this is actually
really good yeah this is good
now did Kyle pass away getting the food
or yeah
yep
did this no no slipped them all
look at that technique
but here right here at the very end
right here at the very Freelancers watch
right here
right on the [ __ ] button
he's like what look he takes it he takes
oh he took it Paul's a [ __ ] fighter
man he is he's actually good he's a
[ __ ] good technique right there
that's good cornering right there throw
some ice on the floor
let your guy get another 30. press with
Jake Paul yeah I was no doubt I mean we
Just Gotta Throw man
come on wood fourth or fifth
loose now we're getting loose Brandon
here we go
oh little exchange let's go who London
oh this is amazing I love this watch I'm
enjoying this [ __ ] now come on T would
you just accept it you said that he's
hunting him down he was hunting him down
I would say Woodley's down two rounds oh
two one or two or three zero two guys
got some fire right now yeah I think
they're gonna throw some nice [ __ ] right
here baby throw if T wood throws man he
I think he's getting you can get him out
of here they're throwing right here he
just Gotta Throw he just has to open up
yeah they're throwing more action he's
so timid come on t
oh what is he trying to like get
decision he's trying to bait him in
yeah
no
no
oh yeah that was a power shot yeah it
hit his elbow though yeah yeah damn
little faints I'll tell you what we
don't want to have happen this goes the
seven and they're both really tired they
don't look too tired no they look good
see what looks good they look good right
now are the three minutes right yeah
three minutes I said earlier man oh yeah
he bailed on it I didn't think tea was
gonna look this good and going into the
floor yeah by the way whoa whoa
[Applause]
all right
oh my God I missed come on
he's in trouble actually hurts he's in
trouble he's actually hurt he's in
trouble and he's never been hit before
no not like that he was not like that
he's actually oh he's [ __ ] oh he's
done he's done look at his legs he's
done 100 he's done I don't know what you
mean
he's just chilling right now just relax
relax
right hand come on oh come on he got hit
right there he got hit Willa got hurt
come on oh my God look at Chappelle on
the back yo he's [ __ ] lit I can't
even see what T Woodley there he's a
champion guys don't [ __ ] around you guys
keep [ __ ] talking about Jake Paul
I've been telling you from Dale
I get a little [ __ ] come on come on
let's see five seconds he let him off oh
he's loading up no don't load up just
throw just throw oh man
hey by the way hey by the way props to
Jake Paul got [ __ ] rocked and smiled
right here
boom yeah definitely behind me right
behind the ear yep
all right that one rocked he uh
good defense that one I don't know if
that one or is it this one see
that one that one that one
yeah oh my God through the ropes yeah oh
his eyes are all [ __ ] yep you know
what oh
if he didn't load up on that he would
have landed by the way by the way Jake's
Never Been Jake Paul's got back like
this still on his toes
it's three one or two two oh wow
that hurts in the old third round's
close okay true it could be three one
but yeah all right I'll go too too is on
his toes and he's a real oh yeah dude
he's answering back oh nice
big opportunity
you know what he's playing with the big
boys Brennan
if you want to [ __ ] with the big boys
you're gonna get caught this guy's a
king flip he was so relaxed right now
why did he [ __ ] fight like this I
know oh [ __ ] because yeah that's true
that's like Jake Paul that's true Colby
Covington dude this is actually a good
fight
and look at look at T wood this is
actually really interesting
man he's not a social media guy don't
[ __ ] around everyone three one or two
two yeah
that third round was the third round was
closed it was close yeah you can give it
to him Jake had more output but he would
land take over though
he's taking over
yeah he's he's interesting to put combos
together and I quit trying to land one
big one oh I don't know so he'd be
working on him we're gonna have to drop
him for him correct yeah exactly you
gotta make him hit the mat at least once
you are correct yeah
you know what Jake's a little timid
right now and he's breathing heavy needs
to be people got power still and and no
no oh
you can still crack
I don't think
how much damage do you think the body
shots are doing to Woodley right nothing
nothing right not much this guy's
[ __ ] it's really a good one it's it's
bro that guy got abs on absolutely what
about the straight body's house like
that they don't really do much do it
yeah we gotta be careful on that right
there that little boy oh that was a good
thing
let's go that was a big house
come on that was
oh it's hands up come on hey what though
no matter what happens Jake is the real
yes yes he is the real deal yes he is
he's tough as [ __ ] yeah no shots yeah I
like it yeah me too he's a legit dude in
general I mean
uh
Nascar event okay
this is one of our entertaining yo this
is this is actually really entertaining
I'm loving this [ __ ] you could tell
because we're kind of quiet it's funny
yeah
he was a way better boxer
and shame on me for oh you said you're a
better boxing Woodley no I never said
that oh Brendan don't say dumb [ __ ] all
right oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
if I was judging but according to the
farhood who does the non-official
scoring for Showtime he has him down
where do you see that it showed at the
bottom got a while ago
you hadn't just picked his head up
Maybe
are you sure you know what's gonna suck
is if Jake Paul does get knocked out and
you have those electric things on your
shorts yeah
that's not fun damn what if it just said
KO oh what's just goes
disease
caught him with that check hook right
there disease look at him
but Jay caught up with me either way
it's money signs yeah either way either
way that makes me angry I get angry lots
of money all right let's do this let's
do that I bet farhood has it three two
oh might as well go
yo let him what the [ __ ]
the way this fight's going to the
rematch not mad at no me neither me yeah
I'll definitely watch it again same time
same background yeah nobody's
embarrassed no no this is great [ __ ] no
I think he's a little off dude I mean
remember he's not the official judge
yeah caught him in the ground yeah
that's a nice shot they want you to they
want this direction if it's going there
okay T come on oh
why are you grabbing them though
well coming in close listen remember
what I said when this [ __ ] started
what'd you say oh it's fake yeah man
yeah this is not fake dude they are
swinging for the fence but at the end
though oh if he goes to judges it goes
the judges all day yeah boxing corrupt
is [ __ ] yeah yeah so that's what I'm
saying
and you're in Cleveland of course right
yeah all right all right come on wood
throw oh Jake opening up
a lot of white people yeah he's tired
I'm real tired right now
so does he think he knows he has to
knock him out though no no because in my
eyes tired I mean he's winning this
round Tyron is patient look at how far
he'd scored it like he's Gotta Throw him
see he's not cutting him off he's
following him a little bit too much well
because because Jake Paul Jake Paul's
throwing more
so that's probably why he's giving him
round throw together you just gotta
throw man and also cut him off if he
throws he's gonna win this fight
someone's getting a little tired though
yeah you talking about Jake both both
what's slowing down they've definitely
come on
well sometimes you take a round off
they don't got enough rounds to take one
out yeah that's only eight rounds oh oh
how about oh
my grazing on top of the head too
Tyrone just keeps coming forward man
I know get in there man
get fired up man
[Music]
oh that was a nice day not to this [ __ ]
now yeah I know they're both Jake's
breathing hard
you think he doesn't see that though six
rounds oh oh
I feel like if the weather would put the
pressure come on he could really
you could I do too yeah
um
More Than Jake though Jake through I
don't know the body a couple times yeah
you got he is he is kind of he does have
ring control he is pushing the fight
right like if you're gonna score that
like who like let's say the strike goes
even you gotta go to Ring to drink right
yeah damn
all right so does online have Jake
winning or what they said uh chat what
do you guys think who do you guys have
winning
spam it in the [ __ ] chat way off
let's go what do you guys think far hood
off am I off spam it spam it talk to us
whose phone I don't know yeah okay
that's the prettiest guy
now did he make the pizza himself or
where'd he go Dominic a lot of people
are saying Jake
also order a Postmates a lot of people
are saying Jake's up a lot of people are
saying Woodley though too it looks yeah
I think Woodley's up one round that's
how I have a scored all right I think
it's ties the next two rounds three
three right now three three or it's
three three or four two for Jake that's
a good up oh oh yeah
three three or four two for Jake
okay let them apart damn it
come on man I think three threes the
safest ball to make here we go here we
go so if it's three three
wow
damn he gave [ __ ] Paul that last
round remember man he's just throwing
more yeah he's throwing them you tell me
Willie's won one [ __ ] round you're
out of your mind
no disrespect Steve firewood see see and
his Corner crowd telling him that he's
winning so he's nah he can't be doing
that
you know do you think that's what I'm
saying do you think he knows that he
needs to knock him out no because he's
he's uh yeah big big John Big John just
said it's 5-1 Jake
what yeah so he has it five one for Jay
because what will he's just too square
and he's not thrown enough I think I
think it's four two oh nice and nice
that's a nice cut that's it you just
said the same thing he's like Wooly's
just not thrown enough if he had more
output he'd be one of the fight I said I
ain't gonna argue with Big John why is
if Big John says five one it's [ __ ]
probably five one yeah yeah so we're up
I'm off five one yep just throw so you
probably needs another yeah he just
needs it just needs a throat do you
think it's funny because he was Big
John's off of I'll buy a round that's
four two he's still yeah I I have it
four two John has it five one damn then
I feel like this is it then yeah Woodley
needs a knockout calm down buddy
you got one more round you got 10 grand
on this fight don't yep
11. you're counting the ground to him
you gotta count that yeah see that's how
I feel when someone says they spent
money
oh damn
he's just not throwing punches answered
a lot of [ __ ] questions oh kid can
get hit yeah stay in the fight stay
focused it looks good answers more
questions about Jake than Woodley he
looks good
and he's got Endurance by the way so
Jacob beat that that time I think so
yeah 100 he's beating that kid
yeah man be a good next up for him too
yeah
these fight guys with no wins but I feel
like he's gonna steamroll that kid he
would probably knock him out yeah come
on Tyler get the get this get this W man
Jacob's tired though look he looks tired
but he's still fighting
Tyron might be tired too though man the
bummer is in Woodley's Corner they need
to be like dude you're down [ __ ] six
rounds bud you gotta we gotta go balls
to the walls here especially if you want
that rematch well he's following him but
he's just you know he's just he's just
not throwing yeah that's what I'm listen
yeah oh [ __ ]
that was nice he caught him he caught
Woodley with that I think caught with me
I'm convinced that they just want the
rematch
there's no rematch though yeah right
yeah it's only if Woodley wins if Jake
wins he moves on he's doing great he's
doing great that's what that's why it's
you know if Woodley wins you automatic
rematch if he wins there's no rematch
hey what'd you think of Dana's comments
about the Jake Paul thing which which
comments oh he said he said uh because I
Jake said it's a flash in the pan No No
Jake said that he's like he's like if I
ever run into to dinner
said well that's about par for what he
would suggest he's like get in line
there's a bunch of people that want to
knock me out and he also said like he
goes it seems like it seems legit the
long lines because you fight people who
are older than you and like that's
hilarious yeah he goes pretty funny yeah
he goes he goes uh he's again it seems
like kind of in line with what he's
doing he's like I'm 52. he's like I'm 52
he seems like you'd want to fight me
that's what he's doing he's fine [ __ ]
50 year olds one one zero Dana
no that's a great shot man he's he won
this fight
he won this fight how insane is this
let's see what happens come on yeah I
said no he's down his route
yeah
Jake Paul dude if you had told me a year
ago Jake Paul's gonna be Ben Aston I
know it's just so crazy in your [ __ ]
face yeah man one more round
when you open up Jake and Jake can
weather your storm and catch you he just
started throw a back fist there he goes
there he goes oh come on come on come on
I think my thing is what is Jake do so
he fights Tommy and then is it then
where do we go find some real guys his
brother he's gonna keep trying to talk
[ __ ] to Connor he wants to fight Connor
did Dana well the only way that can
happen if Dana allows him to fight that
ain't gonna happen dude Connor small
dude that's like I said counters 170
when just walking around maybe like
maybe one he's a lot smaller maybe you
might know who the Dana might let him
fight is one of the deals Bros yeah yeah
I think he let him fight Nick he's gonna
fight Nick Nate still awesome
dude they're not gonna let him yeah
Robbie Lawler loses they would let him
take that fight yep but they didn't want
to be cut in on the promotions yes right
yeah what's that do for a jake though a
few fights Nick Diaz
Nick Diaz hasn't fought him I'm sorry
is no in the mind of a lot of Jake
Paul's audiences but that's the kind of
the point right now
UFC Hall of Famer yeah he's a huge name
one of my favorite Rings Nick brings the
audience that will sell so much more
compared to Woodley not even close way
more Nick cousin in five years and he's
fighting [ __ ] Robbie long it's been a
huge dude I mean also Jake Paul fought
Ben Astron
we're talking about people that are in
line with his families like he's gonna
fight anyone he thinks he could be I
can't well he's going to get the
crossover because his fan is going to
watch him fight a turkey so he can fight
anybody he fights and you get the Diaz
crowd of course he's huge masses
now does he beat Nick no
Nick can [ __ ] box man yeah that's
that's okay
the amount of output look how tired Jake
is now Nick is gonna push him to the
brink of just [ __ ] just quit all the
way
around
trying to hold
he didn't win that fight
and I had him cards a little bit oh man
I said he'd land up the the heart of
punches but Jake Paul just at work
though no no
shots
yeah right yeah yeah so that's why he
thinks he won yeah I know man
that Willie's gonna yell the mic and the
guy was rod blah blah but it doesn't
matter
like if your corner man ain't telling
you you would think you're winning too
because he's hurting them yep so Big B
Jordan said six two Paul yeah yeah six
two yeah that's fine that makes sense
yep that's fair you know I would love to
hear what Jake says on the mic here look
at his mom I bet you Jake's pretty
humble on the mic he's gonna call
somebody out but I bet he's pretty
humble yeah you gotta turn the subtitles
on
oh that's not that's not something yeah
I want to hear this so bad I do too
Tyron Woodley you have headphones over
there Tyler really did well though you
know hey Bradley you were right man this
was fast
those subtitles were fast bro
you're so damn fast like everything
involved like what what yeah anything
but yes it ashamed of it it looks like
it's Jake you gotta be one of those fast
readers I just flipped through
regardless of the outcome from here L.A
we look it's just you can't even do this
holy [ __ ] Jake definitely outworked them
look at that that is so [ __ ] crazy
you got a special that Jabs
the length the length
that was great
it was a good fight it was a way better
fight than I thought it would be yeah
you're competitive than I thought way
better for sure somebody was gonna get
drunk yeah and Jake Paul showed you know
what they did he came to fight he was in
shape it's not like Jake beats him just
[ __ ] dude Jake Paul fought a real
guy he's impressive yeah the main things
he got rocks so what do you go from here
if you're if you're Jake's manager what
do you do I don't I don't give him to a
a really good no I don't do that I don't
do the DS fights no I would do Tommy
fear if you want yeah Tommy Tommy be
good Tommy Fury you would like Tommy
Fury up I think so
um but I think he's very serious so he's
going to want to push himself the Nick
Diaz thing I don't you know I mean but
Nick has to fight Robbie but yeah
um uh Diaz ain't the way to go if you're
trying to get a win
Nick Diaz is not a good idea
no as Nicky has been training this whole
time
he's doing Triathlon yeah have you not
seen him like how old is Nick probably
about two three years ago he's 38. he
hasn't found five years it'd be a good
time to get him I think it's a good
fight he's always trying so if you have
to pick the two I guess you go with Nick
if you want to say an easier fight but
Nate would mop the floor with him I
think
it's just a bad idea with this their
cardio their chins their boxing style
it's a bad idea so I wouldn't do that
um they're not giving you Dylan Dennis
because they've done that was good you
gotta you gotta have a real fighter you
gotta have a real boxer if you're gonna
step in there well you gotta you gotta
have you gotta know how to box bro who
do you think it is not too much I want
to see him fight a real boxer man it
depends what he wants to do if he wants
to keep going it's like you do look at
this I like this though 78 74. I like
this I like the score
78-74. yeah it depends on what do you
want thanks for taking that die I
appreciate it
if he wants to fight for the next five
years then you do the next step but if
you just want to continue no get paid
you fight your brother there you go but
I want I don't I want to see Jake Paul
fight who I want to see the what level
you want to see this is a pretty good
level Man fight some amazing boxes what
level you want to see him get to you
know what I'm saying like what's up
ceiling at his age like
[Music]
are you hearing this 77.75
what
77-75 775 for Woodland you know what if
they're smart they give it to Woodley
and we have the rematch correct yeah let
everybody get paid let everybody make
crazy 78.74 you'd have to oh yeah that's
right yep check once he deserves it
that's fair incredible
the kid deserves it should have been a
split but yeah but it was insane so
insane I think he's good for fighting
and I think he's good it was it was a
good fight it was a good fight both of
you guys yeah everybody here where's his
ceiling at like how far is he gonna go
did he just fight like these old and I'm
not saying Woodley's washed up that's up
to him I think it's up to is that the
like that's the model I'll tell you what
the ceiling is I'd love to see him Julio
Cesar Chavez Jr is is his ceiling that
level Julio Cesar Chavez Jr the one that
Anderson Silva just made a call damn
that's his ceiling right there it was 50
and four world champion though four-time
world champion how about this hold on
yeah wait wait wait it was 50 and four
yeah let me ask you this wait they're
trying to make money fights though but
I'm saying no he's saying what the
ceiling is yeah I'm saying like I'm
saying like in the years like two years
two three years I'd say that's like how
does he do it again is a monster I would
love to see that all slows down so
mazatol slows down he's got the power
boxing matchup yeah he's amazing he's a
bad matchup
doesn't he's also a very slow paced
fight so he'll he'll pick him apart
yeah he's playing this game to make the
most amount of money until he loses
someone that is like I'm losing
everyone's gonna go like Logan oh of
course you lost Conor McGregor yeah but
it's the biggest fight ever I and Conor
is a much better boxer but Conor is
smaller I don't know that's what I'm
saying but I'm saying I think that's the
feeling that's the real Fighters
he is right he's so good
he didn't beat Khan it just seems like
it's not a normal fight ceiling I don't
think it's like oh yeah I don't know
like like who knows Chavez Jr it's like
that's not
he wasn't big in boxing anyways it was
good it was decent but yeah
he's never like beat anybody like yeah
he lost answer and Silva what about
Anderson Silva
I like that I like that I like this why
not Oscar De La Hoya Oscar's fighting
vitron X figure guide that's where he
gets too much of a [ __ ] he wants to
because they want the popularity
I think he's I think so I think so too I
think so I think Anderson still was the
best next who's he calling who's he
calling out
okay well let us know because he's going
to say something yeah he's gonna say
Conor McGregor he's gonna say Tommy
Conor McGregor swimming fairy Conor
McGregor he's gonna call it Connor 100
gonna happen yeah right that's Connor
got a broken foot I'm calling it right
now it doesn't matter let him call him
out after this huge win is going to get
it's gonna go viral so much traffic yes
that's all he cares even though he's not
gonna get the fight all he wants is the
traffic Conor McGregor I guarantee but
his ankle is hanging it doesn't matter
Dylan dance he's not going to call Dylan
Dennis no way Dylan does not have enough
clouds to this guy no he's calling out
Conor McGregor I was scared my fat ass
out
you'd kill that guy man yeah see all
respect to Tyrone he's a Hall of Famer
yeah kind of a good fight he's Class Act
man I love this kid I love him yeah come
on man he's a [ __ ] he put He steps in
there and [ __ ] does some [ __ ]
is coach on the right eyeballs are
popping out huh
his blood pressure
foreign
[Laughter]
come on
yeah
that one judge probably wasn't around
the internet started he's right I mean
I mean dude we're looking looking all
good we've still got the victory okay
come on man yeah waiting for the Conor
McGregor call out to be fighting for
barely three years and be able to beat
it it's nuts unbelievable boxing though
different game man he's talking [ __ ]
about Tommy Fury right now I knew it oh
the first I see you see Tom Fury 7-0 he
goes four rounds I think he knows he's
making sense he's like fear's been
fighting he has seven fights he fought a
four-round [ __ ] fight look at me I
think he knocks Fury has that pizza we
have a bunch of pizza did you just get
it from Italy yeah no no no no it's done
we don't want to eat on the mic we'll be
done as soon as he just get his opponent
we're out I don't know who to find I
like anything like that McGregor I like
that happening
at all yeah I like Jorge oh look you
have called out names he's McGregor
[Music]
uh brush my teeth my nose is crooked
dedicate the past he's a tough [ __ ]
kid to this I might need to chill out
and wait for Conor McGregor I made that
up but uh yeah yeah that's what he's
doing
you know you got to ask yourself for
real like okay so you want to get really
good at boxing is it worth the brain
damage that this is that when you're at
this age you're making mistakes you're
fighting good guys no no for him is it
worth the money 15 million 15. it's
worth it
hold on I wouldn't I don't think you got
much break bro we've traded it for way
less than that
no you don't you still get it though
boxing might be a little different
because with boxing if he wants to get
really good and go the next level with
mozvid on guys like that he's gonna have
to train his ass off he's going to be
getting hit by really good guys is it
worth being dizzy losing your memory why
do you say there's less brain damage
than MMA than there's more grappling and
wrestling
so long when we train also there's a lot
more wrestlings I take things to the
ground right I'm not just constantly
getting hit different a whole different
approach yeah you know MMA once you get
dropped real bad the fight's over here
they put you back out there you're not
getting you another got it got it and
they're just the Jazz and when you get
dropped like this that means
uh I mean he's crying huh um he just
from here he's yeah
honestly I I it's like you can't even
hit on Jake Paul at this point no at all
at all either of them what Logan did
with Floyd's no yeah I love him man
it completely flips boxing on attack
they're fun and hate on because they're
just they're so such showman but they're
awesome they're not gonna they don't
want to fight each other but they're
going to they're close they love money
I've been waiting to post this after
this fight so I'm gonna post what you
posting yeah
I just decided about this current chance
I want to see all the kids out there if
you ever get more keep your head up
confident look the Box some bullies all
right we can wrap it up he's not calling
buddy out guys thanks for watching love
you I will be in San Jose September 9th
the 11th and then the big boy San
Antonio September 24th and 25th one show
only at the Bud Light Event Center all
right come on out tickets at fatkz.com
or thickboy.com I'm gonna be in uh
Buffalo the 9th of September to the 11th
Buffalo helium then I got Denver
September 23 24 25 and then Schaumburg
improv Chicago September 30th or 31 and
October one San Jose I'm gonna be at my
gym all week San Jose buddy I'll be
there uh he will be at his gym all week
and I'm gonna start working out there
and I'm gonna get [ __ ] crazy jackets
thank you guys we love you until next
time this is the funnest one we love you
guys thank you thank you guys
that was fun